the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
the saint louis rapid and blitz kicked
off the penultimate leg of the 2022
grand chess tour in beautiful st louis
missouri the capital of chess in america
with only one rapid and blitz event left
players look to cash in on as many tour
points as possible in the faster time
control frenchman a laressa farrugia
started off hot and never cooled down
leading the event after two days sharing
the lead only briefly with fellow
countrymen maxine bashir lagrange at the
conclusion of the rapid section despite
an impressive 12-win performance from
blitz legend hikaru nakamura his
incredible second place finish was
overshadowed by the french phenom who
picked up right where he left off
winning 12 as well dominating the blitz
section and cruising to his first ever
victory in a grand chess tour event
perugia's win catapults the young
superstar into the thick of the gct
standings going into the final leg of
the tour the 2022 sinkfield cup the
illustrious final event will crown a
champion and provide the epic conclusion
to the incredible 2022 grand chess tour
[Music]
[Music]
this is it the granddaddy of them all
welcome everybody to day one of the sink
field cup we start the day in front of
the bush stadium home of the most
valuable franchise in st louis the saint
louis cardinals while we have the most
valuable chess players ready to battle
it on the chessboard let's go to the
studio and start today's action with
yasser peter and alejandra
from the home of chess in america
welcome to the singfield cup the
flagship event of the saint louis chess
club last stop of the 2022 grand chess
tour
welcome i'm peter svidler and with me is
the one the only
i run out of words to say to say about
you you are peter
remember everything about just exactly
the same for you too wonderful to be
with you in studio hello everyone
welcome to our live coverage of round
one of the sinkhole cup and my goodness
what a roster of players we have the
creme de la creme of the chess world
here we go peter do the honors tell the
people who's in the tournament let's
take a look
uh and here we have our our field indeed
a fantastic event
generally speaking pretty much always
the strongest event of the year perhaps
outside of the world championship cycle
magnus carlsen leading the field there
as you can see are reserved a second
rated uh jan nipomnishi who played the
world championship match against magnus
carlsen last year and will play one more
next year although against a different
opponent uh and then wesley uh maxima
shilograph who won this tournament last
year fabiano caruana who
won at least one very very important one
here yeah live on erroneous jacqueline
miguel of linear dominguez and at the
bottom they're a very very exciting
american youngster uh hans neiman are
very good and our format leader
this is a template around robin as are
all the gcg tournaments uh the time
control is the sort of the feeder time
control the well accepted period type
control yeah uh 90 minutes for the first
40 moves and then 30 minutes for the
rest of the game with a 30 second
increment starting from move one draw
first no very good and the
traditional scoring system is very much
in place here and our schedule peter
uh the schedule is uh as you can see
we're starting today with round one we
play five rounds in a row uh ending on
tuesday september the 6th uh then there
is a resume on wednesday
and then four more rounds uh to go
finishing on september 11th and there
will be playoffs on that day if if
necessary outstanding and uh we're very
fortunate to have with us in studio
alejandro ramirez
good afternoon alejandro great to see
you in studio you look wonderful
good afternoon guys what a pleasure to
be back here at the singfield cup and
you mentioned it what a tournament we
have just with the list of players alone
but not just that yasser it's also the
final stop in the grand chess tour this
year and we have a competitive grand
chest to finish it off look at the
current standings it's the frenchman
that are currently leading the gct
maxima sherlock graphic 26 and a half
points but he's trailed very closely by
alireza ferrugia only one point behind
he just won the saint louis rapid and
blitz alvarez that is so he certainly is
looking forward to winning this
tournament and taking the tour for
himself levonado and wesley slow with 22
and a half points they also have an
outside chance in the case that they win
or they get second and somehow the
frenchman aren't able to get good points
but of course let's talk about our
leader maxime bashir lagrav currently
the world blitz champion he is not only
strong in blitz of course he is very
strong in classical he won this
tournament last year in 2021 but he also
wanted a long time ago already it feels
like five years ago did mvl win this one
so no stranger to winning classical
events in st louis and another player
that is no stranger certainly to winning
classical events is a certain magnus
carlos and he's definitely won the same
field cup he won it in the first year he
wanted to end 2018 as well tied with
lemonade and fabiana carrana and he is
of course our world chess champion it's
going to be extremely exciting to have
him here back in action in classical
chess and with us we also have a woman's
grandmaster anastasia carlo which she'll
be in charge of social media and a lot
of very nice little interviews around
the tournament so make sure to follow us
on our social medias we see alireza
ferruccia entering the hall everybody's
going to be talking about this young man
anastasia what was your perspective of
the st louis rapper and blitz and this
tournament that we have coming up hello
alejandra hello everyone it's i'm so
glad to be here in saint louis the
tournament is going to start very soon
and i will make sure that we have all
informational news i will come back and
force to the studio and um i think it's
going to be a really interesting event
and i'm i'm really don't know if it's
going to be a dominating result from one
of the players similar to what fabiano
carano showed in 2014 or we are going to
have a big fight a big battle between
few players um what i can say for sure
that is one of the strongest events of
course and we have um all the winners
except dinglery and playing in this sink
world cup i'm really looking forward
what about you peter and the other
anastasia first of all big welcome
really looking forward to all those
interviews i know it's tough to get
those players after the game they're hot
to say some words but thank you for all
the things you do
i'm expecting a very competitive event
uh but first let's uh take a look at the
pairings do the honors for us peter as
we get underway and this these are our
pairings for round one with shakaryama
mijarov playing white against wesley so
linear dominguez uh wide against uh
maximum grave alireza ferrugia playing
against fabiano caruana uh
hunts and even plays white against
lewanda and then also this pairing
between
and yanni pomnishi which we may have
seen before and it's a it's a good
starter to the tournament
no question about it and let's go over
to tony rich ready to start round one
hello and welcome to the playing hall we
have just moments to go before the games
begin the players are all arriving
they're being wanted by the security
staff they're in the process of filling
out their score sheets and shaking off
those final nerves
we'll throw back to you guys and we'll
start the rounds in just a moment
outstanding and we will uh have our
predictions as i'm going through the
roster of players and i tell you uh just
so many
champions former champions i think
anastasia
mentioned to me uh earlier that only
being there in this yes
of the form of of the former winners of
the uh singfield cup always
missing wow
sadly i do think
on the question anastasia mentioned
whether this will be a dominating
performance by one player or uh or a
scrap till the end i think a scrap till
the end is much more likely
uh without a 10 player field of you know
as tightly packed as this one is
but of course you know you can't rule
out
uh someone and
maybe someone
yeah a man on screen perhaps perhaps
running away with it i think you know if
we talk about running away with it he
remains
maybe the go-to person in every
tournament but uh
we've just seen that there is a score
like 75 percent of points
in a very similar in a very similar
field and they're going to be fighting
very very hard over the next two weeks
what are they fighting for peter the
prize money for the classical events uh
during the gct tour is twice and i'm
twice the the prize money for rapid and
blitz so uh 350 thousand dollars total
price fund with a very cool six figures
price up top their hundred thousand for
the winner and going all the way down to
10.5 for last and the g60 points stay
the same uh meaning that the winner will
get 13 points or 12
uh if there is a tie break and
and can this young man alireza keep the
momentum going i mean what he did
in the rapid and blitz alejandro was
simply amazing
watching him keep the lead and then just
keep his foot on the gas how did he do
that it was astonishing he reminded me
of how magnus carlsen plays blitz it
doesn't look like blitz it looks like
he's playing a classical game he was
very precise he was calculating very
quickly he was playing quickly and he
put the pressure on his opponents in
every single game even after he won the
tournament right he still kept up his
pace and that just speaks volumes to
this young man's desire
and hunger for this game and he has a
great challenge ahead of him today he's
had traditionally some problems with
fabiano caruana in classical chess
remember that fabiano corona beat him in
the grand swiss to qualify to the
candidates last year so this is a big
matchup for me this is as interesting as
the carlson napo game absolutely yeah
and uh one thing that you you brought up
there uh we didn't really we spoke about
a lot during the coverage of the rapid
blitz but for those who perhaps have not
seen the tournament as closely he won
the rapid and blitz a tournament of
absolute elite elite strength with four
rounds to spare it's been a while since
i've seen this
exactly
true that all the way i mean four rounds
to spare it's always nice if you win it
when an event one round the spirit then
then you usually fall flat on your face
by the way after doing that but uh four
rounds to spare and there we see a
newcomer uh hans niemann and
gentlemen do your best introduce our
audience to hans neiman who is this man
hans demon is a
he's a player that is a grinder as we
have a genie singfield about to start
the tournament with the traditional ring
of the bell just wait for it
please remember that
will not automatically add the 30
minutes
move they will flag and then we'll get
the extra 30 minutes at that point okay
please remember you want to stay in the
playing area at all times once your game
is finished
we'll either ask you to go for an
interview or you can leave by the front
door again
if you need to go outside please i'll
tin and harbour let's go with you
restrooms and refreshments in the
playing area here
media and guests and everybody else we
are going to ask you to leave after
approximately 10 minutes of play
this is so we can ensure that our
players are
um talking to anyone that happens to be
in here at that time and we can give the
players the best conditions
they can have so they can play the best
chat
[Applause]
ringing the bell today we have virginia
current sink field so on the sound of
the bell
please go ahead and start mike's club
genie
and there we have it we're underway and
as you were saying alejandro introduce
uh hans niemann hans dewan is a grinder
he spent most of the pandemic playing
chess he was trying to find tournaments
after tournaments wherever they were
happening and he just kept playing them
he did not stop he's a player that went
from a mid to high 2500s to basically
high 2600s
in a snap he played hundreds of games
literally and he just tried to find ways
to gain rating he's very hungry he's
trying to prove himself only 19 years of
age he's definitely not as well known as
some of the other players he hasn't had
the success for example of perugia but
he has been testing himself in open
tournament after open tournament with
incredible results he's almost at the
2700 mark i believe that this is going
to be his first real test in classical
chess but he's been very vocal that this
is exactly what he wants to dedicate
most of his energy on
is the classical side of the game not
the rapid and not the blitz peter uh a
big ask of anybody 19 years young
he's got the big target on his back
everybody says you're not magnus carlson
i want to beat you how does he deal with
that kind of pressure i i we will see
it's difficult to judge he's also a very
very interesting very he has a very open
personality he is
by this point
in particular sort of in this news cycle
let's say he is uh he's become very
famous for being very outspoken in in in
post-game interviews which i think he
got some flack for which i think is
entirely uncalled for
uh because uh
you know
being just disapproving of people being
honest and sincere
has always been kind of annoying to me i
think that's incorrect
i think i think we should encourage
people to be uh to be open in interviews
whether it sounds arrogant or otherwise
this is how he feels yeah and uh that
wasn't really arrogance there was i mean
one perhaps the most famous beat was
maybe a little bit
premature but but in general uh yeah i
thought i thought he was
uh
unusually for chess chess interviews uh
very very honest and very open about how
how he felt during miami and
uh it uh
generated a lot of internet traffic
which uh good for the game yeah and i
guess i guess not bad for the game
speaking of miami it was an interesting
tournament but for hans it looked like
such a disaster right he did not win a
single match in theory because of the
way that
things were scored in miami he scored
zero points zero out of seven if you
want to look at it that way in match
format but he actually beat a lot of
people in that event he was consistently
losing his matches two and a half four
and a half and it felt that he could
hang with them that he was unlucky he
was impatient at some points he was too
emotional but his chest was there yeah
yeah absolutely and also on a slightly
lighter note i feel that i i don't have
the exact timestamp but he is
i think maybe a year and seven months
away from needing to be higher rated
than aneesh giri
so that's another topic that we like
what is that at some point he they they
had some very kind of a feisty exchanges
with anish on twitter oh cool and he
told anish that you know within two
years i will be higher rated than you
are oh oh oh so smackdown uh
that i believe that was maybe may or
thereabouts so it was definitely prior
to the olympia so
the clock is ticking we're watching yeah
how close is he well i mean i don't know
70 points but those are difficult 70
points maybe 80 points i'm not entirely
sure uh we i don't think it's a novelty
a2 a4 but it's certainly off the beaten
track
it's gained traction recently oh really
yeah and also i wanted to say that
i was a bit kind of worried when i saw
hans go castles and then rookie one and
i thought maybe he actually wants a kind
of a soft plain into the tournament you
know
a way to make a very very calm draw in
round one right if i know something
about hans is that there's nothing yeah
there's nothing calm about his chest or
his demeanor so i i would never expect
him to go for something very quiet
actually his repertoire was something
that i'm a little worried about because
of this level of com of competition
sometimes when you play too many opens
you have all these tricks and trappy
lines because you're trying to beat
opponents consistently round after round
and it's not necessarily what you need
for a tournament of this level in a
close setting um take it
why a4 and why a6 a4 you defend the
bishop i get that yeah but if black is
willing to return the pawn why don't you
just go bishop e7 castle i think the
point here is we go i believe knight c3
castles d2 d4 we're just not recapturing
on e5 in the normal fashion we're trying
to gain uh
yeah it's and
that pawn often gets returned like i
think e5 v4 here is the main move as i
also i see on your screen i would have
said that but it's nice to have
confirmation right i have a feeling we
may have even had there was this for
caruana dominguez game in the rapid and
blitz i believe which followed all of
this and it's uh it's become a very
serious topic black has a number of
replies uh and even the position we have
on our analysis screen right now i think
is pretty much equal although you can
ask some questions there but a6 is much
less much less popular it's it's
obviously a
a natural move a reasonably natural move
but uh compared to bhp7 uh a much less
often played one uh even though uh there
on your screen you we have a game by
jordan varfanfarest which i think is an
indication that you know it's a serious
move and uh
people have looked at it quite uh
uh
i'm trying to use a different word to
seriously and
failing utterly here uh whatever you're
investigating yeah
but alejandro first blush to my eyes the
inclusion of a4 a6 and if you're
transposed to some of the lines we're
more familiar with well the inclusion of
a4 and a6 should favor black why not i
mean a4
i'm not too sure about that actually
okay i actually think that the pawn on
a4 gives a little bit of a space a
spatial advantage in some symmetrical
structures the ability to put the putt
on a5 can also be very annoying this
bishop will retreat to f1 one day and
believe it or not this pawn actually can
become a target you can play b4 b5 in
later stages of the game so i am not
convinced that a4a6 favors black my
first instinct actually is that it
favors white just because it gives you a
little bit more space to the point that
people are not playing a6 they just play
bishop e7 they could play a6 but it's
not the main line by any stretch of the
imagination i
believe that levon must have some idea
in this position but if i saw this
without any knowledge of who's playing
i would just think that a4 and a6
included must be a favorable rook e1
variation of the berlin
wow and that's why we call it a sport
yeah and
in a more sort of a
long-term fashion if we talk about the
the the
the positions that very often arise in
these types of uh lines
uh let's just make some moves 95 rookie
five okay uh castle castles i don't know
just some simple moves clear castles
default six
just the most more straightforward stuff
like rookie one knight of five i am
ignoring move orders i mean
all kinds of finesse whatever just
putting c3 c3 g5 bishop f4 okay uh let's
say black goes i don't know uh
c6 here okay white's plan here very
often actually is connected with the
eventual we try to get the knight to c5
right very often in these structures
via either b3 or sometimes d3 like f35
g3 later in the game right right and the
inclusion of a4a6 here in particular if
we have time to play for a5 here
safely
definitely makes a number of end games
which would have been completely safe
for black with a pawn on a7 right at
least somewhat problematic right because
if you imagine your your structure
frozen in place there with the pawn on
a5 and the knight on c5 in some you know
distant future obviously it's not going
to be easy to realize
yeah and i'm guessing c76 is actually
quite incorrect here i would
probably play bishop g5 g5 a6 a5 i think
would be a decent move too but then we
won a tempo
so we we're definitely achieving
something here i feel like it might not
considering how safe these structures
are in general it might not be enough
i'm you know i don't think it's possible
to argue this gives quite a tremendous
advantage i feel i'm getting a chesable
course
on the anti-berlin this is great stuff
everything but it's kind of comical
because i know nothing about the opening
and would never presume to speak on it
but let's take a look at two of our
marquee matchups the first of course is
uh
magnus vs nepo a re uh reenactment of
their world championship match in dubai
and we've got a queen's gambit
decline yeah and i wanted to ask you
about this yeah like you're you're this
is my stuff yeah is it yes i've played
this yes she takes d5
this early
well i like it as black when they do
that
this is what i was provoking you to say
yeah yeah i like it as blasphemous
newfangled stuff like this is not
supposed to be anything at all
if i had a student that's around 1600
and they took on d5 i would spend like
15 minutes explaining why you don't take
on d5 later the bishop on c8 to f5 this
looks like an amateur mistake doesn't it
it does absolutely
so but magnus has done this before it's
it's it's something he does very very
seriously it's obviously not a misclick
of any kind he connects it with very
serious ideas and this move he makes
makes right here after knight bd7 the
move h2h3 is i think an indication of
what those ideas are because
uh that's to preserve this but also i
get the feeling g4 is not very far away
uh the point is people when people do
cd585 this early with the bishop uh
coming out to f5 so comfortably
they often follow it up by playing
bishop d3 and sort of playing to play a
kind of a solid boring game right and
then very often black is slightly better
straight out of the opening because the
bishop 27 is arguably slightly better
than the bishop on f4 with the structure
of being what it is
why needing you know
an active plan an active plan and not
really having an active plan your your
minority attack on the queen side
without those light-squared bishops is
going to be severely diminished in
strength but magnus is not planning to
do any of that i'm pretty sure magnus i
think is
uh is going to be playing some kind of
you know hybrid uh
hybrid plan where i think g4 is quite
well
was asking the question are you playing
g4 or not if you're going to play bishop
d3 well thank you very much i'm not
quite sure how useful h2h3 is if you're
going to play bishop e2 well thank you
very much uh or
are you going to lay down a challenge
and go g2 g4 uh chime in on this one
alejandro do we have uh games from this
exact position and if so what's the
theory say g4 is certainly the main line
in this position we only have about 20
but there's a very juicy one there at
the top it is from a world blitz
championship it's not a classical game
but after g4 bishop b4 we have the game
between vichy anand and assertive magnus
carlsen magnus carlson played this with
the black pieces ended up winning that
game in 2009 but remember it is a blitz
game i don't know if he will remember
exactly what happened in that position
but this particular version is is very
rare and g4 i'm being told has been
played already so we're gonna see a very
fun one the expansion here it it's going
to be dangerous for black you have two
options bishop g6 and bishop e4 uh
bishop g6 is definitely the more popular
move but bishop b4 was the world
champion's uh choice back then well he
wasn't the world champion in 2009 but
bishop e4 i think bishop b4 is probably
already played actually
not on my screen but on yassers for four
i think i'll wait for my update maybe
not yet it's definitely the more
ambitious movie bishop g6 gets the
bishop trapped i assume that at some
point you can go knight knight h4 and
bishop e4 there we go yeah there we are
it hadn't been played but you had a
premiere yeah your expectations were
high my
price abilities are on point today
exactly okay
e4 and nepal didn't spend any time on
that right we know that he's a very fast
player right but there's a difference
between a fast player and not spending
any time means that he must be well
prepared in this variation
okay and please alejandro continue
uh
your discussion after bishop e4 what's
what's topical and
what are the various
ideas for the two players well let's
start with the obvious question why
don't i take this bishop it's the middle
of the board it's spending my night
what's wrong with knight takes the
problem with knight takes is that if i
was forced to take with the d-pawn and i
retreat then white is very happy you're
going to be able to play bishop g2
castle target this pawn on e4 which is i
call it artificially isolated it's
isolated because this part on a5 f7 is
the only possible defender by a pawn on
this pawn on e4 but if you play f5 i
simply capture you you can't defend this
pawn in the long run the main issue is
that if you take on e4 you take with the
knight and this dark squares on the king
side they're allow black some easy play
you're never going to get h4 or g5 in
because this knight controls g5 this
diagonal is uh currently defended and
playing h4 in the long run is going to
be difficult uh so it's not recommended
to take on e4 immediately most people
have chosen to develop the bishop either
to e2 or to g2 in this position i like
g2 keeping the option of taking on e4
later and if that was the way that this
anand carlson game went the claim
followed castles and castles in this
position as well now this bishop is
going to be taken at some point um
magnus played the move rookie aid and
eventually won a long game but you can
see that this gives up the hopes of
attacking on the king side the other way
the other way to do that is to play the
move bishop e2 and put the rook on g1
then follow it up with a very quick g5
maybe knight e5 completely different
directions that the game can take in
right now depending where white develops
the light squared bishop now let me take
you to another game which i thought was
really interesting from the opening
we've seen the english many many many
times and this has become quite topical
knight c6 e3 e5 and everybody here has
been playing the move d4 people have
also been very seriously trying to move
bishop e2 as well and despite the fact
that this has almost a thousand games in
my database nobody has ever played the
move that alierez have played
queen b3 i think it's been played
recently maybe
not entirely i think i've seen it in one
of the very recent online events in an
online event that's my that might be why
it's not appearing here it just prevents
the move d5 but the queen is clearly
very awkward on b3 peter what do you
make of this move
it looks it looks kind of ridiculous but
i mean i'm glad that you're the stronger
player you can say
but you can sort of understand why it's
being done right because uh playing e5
and c5 you're always
at least a little bit interested in
pushing d7 d75 as early as possible and
placing the queen on b3 uh sort of
unprovoked it does feel uh you know a
bit
a bit odd and uh we're being told it's
been played it's it has been played but
only twice in the
uh in the previous
hundreds of years of chess development
uh so what you're doing is you're sort
of postponing black's immediate
counterplay
while also definitely somewhat
misplacing your queen getting a queen
arguably in the way of your most natural
continuation here which has to be like
rook b1 a3 a3 and b2 b4
and or d2d4 as alejandro was mentioned
yeah or or the usual or the usual
default play which leads to very very
sharp positions
uh so you're sort of slowing slowing the
game down for both sides i guess if you
want to
like discuss the future plans once while
it finishes development which i assume
will be g3 b7 already played i assume
the idea here is to play which between
castle kingside
and after that i guess knight d2 bish
per three and try to play on the light
squares okay
like let's make a move here i know rook
b8 or b6 ap6 looks
very yeah but yeah that would be some
kind of an ideal yeah bishop f3 here
rook c8 we go knight ge4 we trade one
knight we play something on the g5
square either the knight or the bishop
and we play that position i'm still not
sure that even in this absolutely best
case scenario this is what you've gotten
because yeah there is one which is uh
that's what i wanted to ask the whole
queen b3 gets in the way of the natural
development of the bishop if you play
d2d4 the bishop's coming out if you put
your pawn on b3 the bishop is coming out
absolutely and alireza actually goes in
a slightly different direction playing
g3 immediately saying that same idea
that you just pointed out just bishop
should or does belong rather on the long
diagonal that's why why not do it
immediately and save some time for the
future so if we get something again
in this case maybe
uh it's making it a little bit awkward
yeah it will be easier for me to get in
uh the the fast development here again i
have five maybe
six yeah
there's no way i want to invite the
knight a moment ago you were playing
knight d2 to e4 peter and playing
knights
as well yeah um
i mean these are just very playable
chess positions i don't think i don't
think we need to assess an obligation to
you know attach an evaluation to them
immediately
it's just a position with 32 pieces on
the board which will be fun to watch i
have no idea if white has anything at
all well let's take a walk around the
plane we can do a leisurely stroll if we
like
we'll bring up the game between uh
shakaria mamidarma mary daroff and
wesley soh two players who certainly are
familiar with one another and this
particular line of the taraj yeah is
it's become tremendously tremendously
popular
interesting that uh well i mean not
probably not very unexpected but you
have to say that in the rapid and blitz
uh shahriar had actually a decent amount
of success playing it to e4 here instead
of bishop g5 exactly and apart from that
game against jan nipomnisch in which he
made two illegal moves in one game uh
but he was trying yeah yeah yeah i think
i think he won one and drew one
completely winning position
in the e4 lines but here he switches and
goes for the more kind of the more quiet
but the more
uh playable and less concrete uh setups
with uh
with bishop g5 and death e3
positions within with an isolanian d5r
have never really been my specialty i
find it kind of difficult to judge
uh when it's completely fine and when
it's not
my initial reaction here is i don't
think black is fully equal okay but i
sort of distrust my evaluations of these
positions quite seriously and also this
is wesley
and wesley is very very welcome
extremely well prepared hasn't really
been burning much time
so you know those kinds of
thoughts uh
collide with one another as as we get
into it feels to me that uh you know
your typical counterplay in these types
of positions uh
is comprised of
you know perhaps getting united to e4
and having it stick there
which would be very useful for playing
for g5 yeah those those would be those
would be the things right bishop g4 is
currently completely unplayable because
there's a queen on a4 so i think it just
loses material to bishop takes f6 very
very possibly exactly uh knight takes
knight to e4 is we've
the the e4 square is as well protected
as you can protect it in these types of
positions as possible in fact three also
also not really great
d5d4 i mean it's sort of playable
because you can then you know having
blundered this pawn you can then play
against it you know right right but
it's your weakness yeah right but it is
a blunder because you sure you cannot
win it back because of bishop h7 check
you can make some kind of a quiet move
like a7 a6 here and kind of pass the
question back to white like what is your
plan here sir right but i think i can
find a bunch of moves here which
improved white's position a little bit
like a3 to stop both bishop before and
night before long term h3 is never a
stupid move 9294 is perhaps something
that i would like to do long term just
to have a very firm control over the g4
square well let's not reinvent the wheel
and invite
alejandro in on this one uh first of all
alejandra what is the kind of
percentages that the player scores it 52
54 in favor of white what's going on
assessment wise well it's not about
percentages because they have been
following one game for a long time but
only one if we go all the way back here
to this position after knight c6 even a
couple of moves before i believe this
move bishop d3 is actually very rare
coupled with the idea of rook d1 if we
go back to this position after bishop e6
the main line of this position is to put
the bishop on e2 instead of playing rook
d1 see here in this position bishop e2
and it's been played by many people
including the game ahmed yarov against
wesley so from last year so certainly
not a
surprise for anybody if you go down the
list it's mamadiaro
rajab of wesley so harry krishna wesley
so you can kind of think that this guy
knows what he's doing rook d1 is a
little bit of a twist it was played in
this game after bishop v6 bishop d3h6 we
see only one game from this position
despite the fact that it looks more or
less normal it's only been reaching the
game between uh radoslav voytashik and
jordan van forest in 2021 and they
followed that game for quite a while
actually the novelty is this move rook
fd1 uh voytashik actually chose to move
h3 which peter you were mentioning is a
very useful move so
let's find out what the ideas are for
both sides after the move rook fd1 what
the engine wants to do as white is to
remaneuver a little bit towards the king
side play the move bishop b1 and queen
f4 i don't actually know what the queen
is doing on f4 but it's actually pretty
insistent on putting the queen on f4 in
many variations now for black this is
where it gets a little bit awkward
you've fully mobilized your pieces the
knight on f6 is fine c6 is fine the
bishops are okay the rooks are in the
center your queen's a little awkward
your queen is a little awkward because
it's attacking a pawn that's defended
you're not really pushing d4 anytime
soon so what is the queen doing on b6
but it's not easy to do something about
it you don't want to trade into an end
game you don't want to play a move like
queen before because you do have a
permanent weakness the isolated pawn on
d5 the engine top engine move according
to my computer will i don't think ever
be played it's the move g6 i think to
stifle this bishop a little bit but i i
hate that move it creates so many
weaknesses on the king side it must be a
very specific move otherwise you can
just play a move like a6 and i think the
difficulty for wesley is to find useful
moves the engine doesn't care the engine
says zero zero but it produces very
strange moves a6 g6 at some point he
wants to go king f8 to defend the bishop
on e7 moves that
i don't know if they're very human alike
and i think this is mamadyarov's
approach to today's game get an equal
position but not necessarily something
in which your opponent can find easy
moves i wanted to mention king of faith
specifically yeah i i very much agree
with you that g6 like your
physically i think you're incapable of
playing
if you're a human being and not a
competitor taser that yeah i i think
your your
all the years of being taught never to
do that
just prevent you from ever playing that
move but king of fate
is not only are you off sort of
protecting the [ __ ] 27 for some future
eventualities you're also sidestepping
the space seven checks meaning that
perhaps it introduces the immediate id
of d5 d4 although with the move bishop
b1 being very very easily available to
white i don't know if it does very much
because i don't think we're pushing g5d4
anytime soon
i personally
when alejandro was explaining and
breaking down the position for us i
personally found it shocking that the
engine was trying
time after time to play queen f4 because
that's not the square i would normally
want to place the queen ever i mean i
like it on h4 i like it on g3 f4 i've
never really broken it's a bit
surprising and not because i don't like
the square specifically in these types
of structures like if we imagine let's
let's play 76 here as a kind of an
example queen of four
bishop d6 will be going on aren't you
just being driven back yeah exactly like
why you have to have a very specific uh
kind of a situation on the board where
queen 4 will do anything at all because
exactly it gets hit by a bishop six at
least of course you've always got to
calculate what happens i think i think
those are much less likely because
with with this much of black's material
being kind of locked out on the queen
side you don't want to offer it but it
is the bishop d6 yes but bishop m6 kind
of bothers me anyway plenty to play for
and yeah that one big one for me i mean
talk about a theoretical dual peter i
mean this uh game between lanier and the
mvl
very very very sharp um yeah i want to
say najdorf yeah this is an extremely
topical line of the b3 najdorf and
they've been discussing various bhp3
nidorfs uh for the past couple of years
uh lanier famously won what was awarded
i think the best game of the tournament
the brilliancy prize absolutely it's the
2021 singfield cup yeah now that you
mention it
is there a brilliant surprise i remember
being somehow
roped into trying to make it a difficult
decision and it was only because lanier
offered me dinner that
i ended up voting for him
dinner it was very good it was very good
no but he deserved that was such a
brilliant game that it played against
mvl and you guys were mentioning this is
a theoretical duel and lanier keeps
trying new ideas in this bishop e3
setups and if we see this position right
now
the one uh that happened a couple of
moves ago let's just wait for the board
yeah the updated board is g2 g3 yeah but
the updated board is here to g3 but
let's go back a couple of moves here in
this position
um yes before the move a3 you go bishop
d3 and everybody plays bishop d3 in this
position right including a certain peter
svidler yeah yeah i had i had some of
some guilty
so bishop d3 everybody plays and a3
actually which has been played before
but not anybody of dominguez's level
is stomped by share a little bit you can
see that he has one an hour and 32
minutes in this position and after he
plays queen c7 he had spent 13 minutes
figuring out what to do trying to
compare and contrast because clearly he
was no longer in book now quintesson is
the main reply against bishop d3 anyway
so he thought okay what is the
difference and we're gonna have to
figure out what this bishop is going to
be doing with uh with its life because
it's most natural to put it on d3 you
always have ideas of f4 even f5 in
certain situations normally in this kind
of positions you see that white has
sacrificed a pawn in the center what is
your compensation normally it's to bring
a rook to e1 very quickly and smash the
center with f4 taking advantage of the
fact that if you do castle kingside this
structure here will be easy for me to
target so i'm going to play h4 g4 and
open you up that way and sometimes even
with as i mentioned bishop d3 and if you
already have the rook only one to go f4
f5 and smash the king side that way
these pawns are very easy to target and
the fact that i have a light square
bishop and black doesn't means that the
central control is a very difficult for
black to achieve if you ever able to
remove this knight and play d5
congratulations you're in a great
position but it takes some time to do
that and even though it doesn't always
guarantee equality and
i was going to bring that up but i
wasn't sure of the exact move order
we're actually still following that game
that i remember very vividly just not
the move order of it uh between uh
linear dominguez and uh
that was a stunning game that was it had
it had so much of everything
including the
40 move uh 40th move blunder
oh no
that was another deal that was that was
a different game no no that was a game
where eventually linear won by self
pinning a bishop on a7 with the king on
a2 and that somehow was uh was good
enough because of very very beautiful
geometry uh and uh
that is sort of interesting in that
mvl should really be expecting this
and he seems to be playing quite slowly
for somebody who has been playing the
night of his entire life and is also
facing something that his opponent has
played in an incredibly high profile
game
uh recently recently uh now that you
mentioned the dioc game could you just
refresh our memory peter what happened
after g2 g3
yeah i mean i would if i could
but i can't so i won't yes
precisely yeah we need to
i could i could look it up yeah we hang
on a second this will
uh
this will only take a moment
famous last words uh
g2 g3 i understand alejandro
that from lanier's point of view but
there's uh bishop g2 rookie one f4 i
kind of like
what uh
linear might be trying to achieve if you
yeah exactly and on the topic that
alejandra was was talking about i think
uh you know the fact that i played
bishop d3 doesn't make it a good move
and you can you can definitely make an
argument for exactly the plan uh that uh
yasser was referring to and and and
alejandro was referring to rook to iban
and then f3 f4 right the bishop on jitu
arguably supports it better than the g3
yeah
so you can you can absolutely make a
case for
at least not committing to a specific
square for this bishop for as long as
possible and i think this might actually
be one of the
uh
very specific reasons for why we're
making this slightly kind of weird
non-committal moves in a position where
we've sacrificed a pawn by move 12 and
appeared you know we
you would assume we need to play as
quickly and as concretely as possible
but
you know for the time being
uh we're not doing very much the game
continued rook d8 and i'm actually a
little surprised it's not popping up on
my database because i looked it up and
it is the exact same position and i
remember and even the exact same move
already you started a three g3 i thought
maybe it was g3 and then a3 but no exact
same move order and rook the eighth and
then and now bishop d3 actually actually
bishop g3 and then knight b6 was the
game yeah i remember because the engine
was also considering instead of rook d8
to long castle in this position or we
haven't castle is always a plan here
long castle is always the at least a
possible plan here trying to get the
king to b8 and
uh solve your issues uh uh that way
perhaps mvl is trying to remember but
unveil in particular i think very often
uh sort of commits to things
without you know double checking them
for for for half an hour and
it would be extremely weird for him to
not have
repeated any of this once again
considering the fact that
you know it was played very recently it
was a very high profile game and yeah
i'm just gonna yeah he won that
tournament he was there
yeah i i'm going slightly slightly mad
there because i actually decided to
double check whether we covered that
tournament i shouldn't i should know who
won it but right i actually scrolled
down to the cross table there to to
confirm before before making an idiot of
myself he was probably walking past that
board like
every two minutes so he should know this
position exists very very very nice uh
all right
alejandro uh we i think that that goes
through the whole
um five games uh but uh what games uh in
particular caught your eye i'm always
gonna be looking at this game between
magnus and jan and the character of the
position has changed a little bit even
though we only have a couple moves the
move bishop e2 was played and castles is
the more natural move i think in this
position castles and i had mentioned
that rookie one was an engine suggestion
and off we go on to the kingston jan
didn't want to see any of that instead
brought the queen to b6 said hey you
have a problem on b2 immediately how are
you going to solve it and it's an usual
problem in this queen gamut decline when
the bishop goes to f4 or g5 very quickly
this counter play attacking this pawn
here on b2 and i thought well what's
wrong with defending it here with queen
d2 and the engine says well the problem
is that you just retreat the bishop
onto g6 and now 94 is a tactical threat
if you castle this is not the setup you
wanted you would rather have the bishop
on g2 if you're going to castle short
and magnus said you know what let's go
into an end game do you want to dance
there because queen b3 at first glance
looks very awkward right you could take
on b3 take on b3 spoil my structure on
the queen side but the engines are not
impressed by this for black at all i
think they value the pair of bishops
very highly and since this bishop on e4
is going to be taken very very soon
there's no way to
prevent white from obtaining that
advantage now this bond structure is
weak the problem is that you can't
really get to it it is weak in the long
term sense but you can't really put a
knight somewhere that attacks this pawn
on the b3 squared yes it's true that i
don't have b4 b5 i would love to be able
to play that but if i do somehow get to
play b4 and i do get to play b5 white
has a beautiful position if i can play
b4 force you to go a6 and then maneuver
this knight from a4 to c5 i also have a
beautiful position and of course for the
time being i do have this pressure on a7
so it seems that the dynamics of the
position give white enough compensation
to be able to spoil your structure like
this now of course nothing is compelling
black on to take on b3 the engine says
that queen b3 is equal but it also
considers just playing the move h6 kind
of forcing white's hand at this point
you do have to take this bishop on e4
before it runs away to h7 and you don't
have the option anymore so we'll see if
nepo wants to take on b3 spoil that
structure but defend against the pair of
bishops uh i'm a pawn grubber guys i i
just got to ask the question queen b3
queen takes b3 a takes b3 you mentioned
it's hard to attack the pawn on b3 with
him
yeah but that was kind of what i wanted
to see i wanted to see you bring your
knight away from the d2 pardon me
to the d2 square away from the e5 square
and then can't i rescue my bishop
but what if i just attack your bishop
are you actually taking it on btw
kings
specifically rook c1 if you play king d2
and uh oops uh no squares to go to other
than c4 yeah that sounds great and then
if i have to go back now that being said
you could make an argument that the rook
is worst place though maybe it is
slightly one yeah maybe the rook had
more uses useful role okay intriguing uh
queen's gambit
uh position and like you said there's no
no compelling reason uh to have to play
queen b3 maybe h7 h6 yan looking a
little bit
scance there
h6 might be the best let's jump back
because i'm really curious as to how
this experiment well experiment how a2a4
worked out for hans well he's gotten a
version of what we were talking about
because instead of c3 i mean it followed
a very similar path to what we're
discussing but he played knight c3
instead of c3 which is obviously a kind
of a more aggressive move a more kind of
a straightforward move but getting the
knight to c5 is much much easier much
much easier by the b3 square because on
the way basically all of your stuff
remains
uh
connected and protected whereas here
you can't really play knight f4 because
the a5 pawn just will get picked up
precisely and preparing knight a4 is
extremely awkward like if you if you
dedicate your entire energy here to just
straight up preparing knight if you can
play maybe queen g2
and maybe you will get to play knight a4
but in the meantime black will play 96
knight a494 and how much of that you
will enjoy is very questionable exactly
uh so you probably have to uh
and yeah he he played a very normal
looking move he played this before here
but quindy to this yeah
bishop would have been interesting but
unfortunately d4 the d4 pawn
which is why i made that horrible move
22 just to demonstrate right and now
only one probably in some order goes 96
bishop f5 and right uh remains
uh remains of his balanced feels
balanced uh alejandro uh jump right in
feels balanced to you guys but the
engine just says plus one
plus one huge advantage for the white
side they do not like this opening for
black at all and it is because of this
move bishop f4 first of all it's not
plus one because it does the engine does
says plus point six with the ugliest
looking move ever i don't think it's
going to happen the move b5 ruining your
structure on the king on the queen side
yes because you have a double attack on
b2 and d4 and there are some dynamics
the problem with the position is how do
you develop this move knight d6 you guys
were mentioning a4 but then knight a4
now the queen is stuck you can't defend
you can't take on
a5 because d6 is hanging plus two plus
two yes immediately the engine goes plus
two nine jumping to b6 or to c5 you're
running out of moves so i thought well
what about a natural looking move let's
develop my own bishop to f5 you put
yours on f4 and the agent says hey
tactics i don't care that
what the structure says knight a4 anyway
how's this work so queen takes a5 and
this is the surprising part this is very
hard to see g4
you might be wondering what
the problem is that if you put the
bishop on e6 i go knight c5 okay and uh
this is a discovery against the queen
and i'm going to be able to take on e6
on the next move now of course this is
not completely clear it's not like the
line just ends there the engine does
think that this is going to eventually
be better for white and i'll guess queen
b6 for example it doesn't take on e6
immediately it first reinforces the
queen side with c3 you cannot take on b2
because you're according to the engine
the queen gets trapped and e6 will fall
eventually what do you mean fall
eventually well i'm gonna give you a
sample line with bishop f5 knight a4
take on a5 g4 what do we retreat all the
way to c8 that way knight c5 doesn't
attack this bishop check this out g5
only one move for this bishop to d8
c3 before coming by by queen
save the queen
how do you save it yeah exactly i'm just
that's it the queen is trapped there's
no way to save it that's yeah remarkable
that's right and uh
it did feel a little bit that maybe
levon's approach was kind of let's say
fair if i'm using that correctly you are
and it is
uh
i think he just assumed that you know
the the solidity of the structure and
the general kind of drawing tendencies
of the opening he is playing will carry
him but yeah the more [ __ ] before is
clever i thought i could play 96 but if
96 is unplayable here because of knight
a4 you're really not enjoying why these
two moves away like i'm playing queen g2
next yeah and then
yeah and and then after knight a4 is
definitely coming and here you have the
uh the heads up record of those two guys
one game one game only one game that one
game did go in the one's favor but uh
hans is still very young he is only just
starting to play against people beat
them while they're young okay if i can
make a
an offer knight sees okay
anyway i'm convinced that knight a4
knight c5 is terrifying therefore
knight c7 knight a4 96 i mean it's an
exchange sacrifice right i can actually
play knight b6 here right you might be
okay like by this point i'm wondering if
you're supposed to go for this exactly
but the knight comes out like you if you
had a very nice accuracy
like if you could jump here if the
bishop was on d6 and you could play
queen g5 or queen h4 or h3 or something
but the knight will come out in one move
i will place you three i will play queen
g2 or g3 and i will start moving those
pieces back i mean you're not even
getting a pawn yeah i i i'm desperately
looking how i am going to get upon
it's so weird there's just no like
bishop h3 i'm just going to ignore you
play push page three here go knight b6
right exactly my king side is entirely
safe with him i i really think i have to
hit the nail very very fast with
something like c5 but you're right it's
an exchange sacrifice uh knight c7 so
yeah i think and also by we see there
live on levon on our screen in a in as
usual a very kind of a florid nice
actually not that flurry by his
standards although it does feature
flowers
but yeah his his expression is
definitely not very florid anymore i
think he realizes now that he is he's in
for a little bit of a bumpy ride a very
good from here on out because yeah if
you allow cringe until night a4
yeah you're just going to be
you know in severe severe you know
self-loathing mode for the rest of the
game some very uh unusual tricky
approaches if you don't mind i'd like to
jump to the ali
raza fabi game because again as a long
long long time english player myself
it it amazes me a move like queen b3 a
move i would never have considered 20 30
years ago is because it's all extremely
modern yes
the the rigor if you will uh by the way
after g3 we left it here castles bishop
jitsu and then he took a very concrete
approach i like that before you've left
your pawn on pre do you see and also
this is why i kind of i was leaning
to and castles instead of this because
it feels like i didn't really realize
that before existed but g3 bishop due to
did feel that we're taking liberties
here with the amount of time we have
while we're still not really entirely
developed
uh and uh
yeah i don't know i don't know how we're
supposed to react maybe 94 maybe 94 to
protect the pawn the funny part is if
for example queen d1 bishop f5 isn't
white
going into a kind of a symmetrical
appearing position with maybe an extra
tempo
maybe this is what you do maybe you play
queen g1 you you wait for bishop five
you play four and you claim that yes i
have that that little bit of extra time
and i'm okay with it yeah which
preferences though we can take a look
because i have a feeling that maybe
black has something more
more immediately ambitious or not or not
i tried d5 yeah like i was e5 i was
looking at the 65 but it needs to be
sort of explained to me like i'm five
year old right um why doesn't this hang
the pawn let's start with the five year
old um and queen d1 played so we will
have the possibility of seeing d5 it
just doesn't seem very fobby like to go
bishop f5 and just retreat
he's a very dynamic player when he's
given the chance it feels like if you
give him a little bit of rope he'll take
it he'll he'll fight you for it and in
this case i feel that if he plays knight
before and he assesses d5
he'll go for it and let's look at some
of these variations
because you were mentioning okay the
pawn is hanging right he could play
bishop f5 it's the second best move
according to the engine
but d5 is currently the top
for me the big question here is c takes
d5 now takes e5 i can sort of imagine
the outlines of why it will be playable
but cd5 followed by 95 is what i'm
currently
kind of struggling to refute yeah knight
f takes d5 knight takes e5
because if
this is the one that was kind of
confusing me a little bit but you think
three and then
yeah yeah and
yeah i mean the variation continues cb4
b5 rugby one
bishop c3 i guess bishop c3 check maybe
uh
i mean even that position is very
playable for white i go bishop d2 if you
take on g3 i take take i play queen g2
i'm going to at least pretend that i'm
maybe slightly better here because of
the bishop
is it a pretention it's very very no i'm
not better at all yeah yeah see before i
blundered to be honest no but even i
don't think cb4 is that big of a deal
but if at the end of the line
oops sorry
yes go forward
yeah i'm
trying to
i'm trying to yeah okay there's a little
hiccup there yes please no but the the
take on d3 take on c3 take on c3 queen
d2 it takes a bit for five i guess it's
also takes and play first rook d8
because the king just doesn't have a
good square you don't want to shut down
your rook on e1 he wants me to take they
could take onto and give a check yeah
that also is probably completely fine
yeah and uh
making the claim that black should be
fine yeah because it's difficult to find
the good square and d5 is on the board
yeah i
he's given this chance he takes it he
loves making complications out of the
opening if he has the choice
wonderful okay so now we we really do
have a big test yeah
as for the immediate knight takes e5 i
get the feeling that we're just going to
be playing
uh gtx c4 yes uh
and gta xc4 is borderline forced
because knight c493 is clearly
unattractive that is i'll take on d1
king takes d1 and there's a bunch of
moves here which interests me knight g4
probably and ig4 is keeps the initiative
alive i like bishop i5 as well but
knight g4 is the
because after takes takes why we'll have
to play f3 which is what what's
attracting me to the move
like the bishop just
crying and now just drop it back to e6 i
think
yeah yeah c4 is hanging i will play rook
fda check the other bishop is coming out
to f6
there's a there's a ton of play here for
black for the one exactly sacrifice
exactly okay so ali razaf's fans are
saying shut it down
don't let black do this to you how is
going to do that alejandro how does
alireza say look i just want a small
edge is there a wave he definitely does
not have a small edge he needs to be
careful not to be worse now the engines
are saying that if you want to avoid the
complications that are involved with
taking on e5 either before or after c
takes d5
you can just castle
play it simple now after d4
uh e takes d4 and 92 they think it's
okay you play this kind of binoni
position but there's an item before
that's a little bit awkward you're gonna
get your knight to f4 which is not so
bad or you could start with the more
sharp a3 remember the e5 is hanging in
many variations at the end so there's no
way for black to win a pawn and that
after knight c6 you have this let's call
it trick a knight d5 knight takes pawn
takes queen takes and knight takes d4 at
the end and corking this bishop against
the queen on d5 now surprisingly the
engines don't think that this position
is better white yeah exactly i was going
to say i would i would my initial
reaction would be we have actually
gotten somewhere with white yes but i
guess the d3 pawn is just just weak
enough it's just weak enough and it can
be taken so easily in the next couple of
moves right both bishop a6 hitting this
pawn as well as rook d8 hitting this
pawn are going to force white to counter
attack on c6 and trade one of the c
pawns for the d3 pawn because the d3
pawn is just dead and in that case black
is simply not worse
wow
fascinating variations by the way
we got to pull ourselves to task
and make our predictions before this
round has any results as usual you know
the big question here is who gets to be
maurice
[Laughter]
who gets to be maurice i'll take it
i'll i'll thank murray
whoever calls dibs on being maurice
magnus you got magnus i got magnus you
got magnus
and varusian is taking a lavon
okay
nastya takes wesley nasty takes uh
now farouza has just had such an amazing
result but
you know it can fabby pull up abby and
win seven in a row i don't think so but
farouza okay and i'll you know let's go
but
you know back-to-back flak i'll take mvl
yes our defending champion lovely so
we've got a whole gauntlet of uh
champions here um
i wanted to ask about this position one
more time bishop uh sorry uh d5
uh sorry this variation knight takes e5
do you take c4 d takes c4
d takes c4 yeah we take on juvon queen
takes d1 king takes d1 knight i like to
g4 let's go here
uh i'm trying peter that's a lot of
choices you want to play a3 yes yes so i
want to get the knight d5 yeah okay
i can see the cockpit
while they're spinning i don't know
whether or not they're they're that
they're catching fire i wanted to try to
get in at 83. let's see because
they can go after the rooks here and i'm
i'm trying to figure out if i can
actually go after like knight of two
king king e2 yeah and now i want to have
fun with you and play knight c2 okay and
because i like the b3 square i like the
fact that this knight probably is
escaping the other one isn't it
this one's dead
don't know if it's good i have a feeling
that unfortunately the saying replies to
take on e5 take on before and just
say i'm doing fine but yeah i wanted to
you know it's such a funny position
where black actually goes after both
rooks
yeah exactly exactly so this is what i
would budget i was just fine it's not
it's not just funny but taking the rooks
is correct i just correctly
oh great so the alejandra just jump
right in take over taking the rooks is
correct yes you cannot play the move a3
it doesn't think that white is losing
but it's not very good now if you want
to do it in the more sane way rook d8
check king e29 c2 is the easier way to
calculate it right and this is just bad
for black for white like really bad you
have to start playing rocket k2 hope
that you capture this knight on c2 but
it's going to take a lot of resources to
actually get to it this does hang the
knight on e5 this is easy to calculate
and that's dead but you could also
start with knight takes f2 here in
knight c2 and it does say that you're
going to take on a1 you're going to
retreat this knight and then the best
move again for white in this position is
to move this funny looking mover k2
hoping to actually trap the knight on c2
because as you mentioned this one is
dead and then hope that this knight
actually ends up uh the problem is that
yeah the problem is that there are so
many tricks and resources for black to
try to save it including this move
bishop g5 if i get knight d4 check in
remember that this is a pin on the
bishop on c1 i'm going to be up a full
exchange rook f8 is also coming so this
is absolute insanity for the white side
i don't expect to see it but it is fun
that both variations work for the black
side that is funny and uh lifetime
between these two uh yeah as we as we
mentioned earlier uh alireza currently
if you know if you can call it uh uh you
know a slight flaw
a character flaw of sorts he appears to
have a negative score against fabiano
and magnus but
i think it's i think it's fine he'll uh
he'll aim to put that to rights and uh
later on in his career
but he would he would very much like to
uh of course to start the tournament
with a win against one of his
um
uncomfortable opponents right
difficult opponents i wanted to
turn the game
our attention rather to the game between
lanier and mvl because
mvl did make a very
big decision he decided to castle long
we've spoken about that as a possibility
ar are you are you warming up to that
decision
it's it's always playable it's never
about a bad idea and then the game kind
of shifts into this really weird uh
uh state
where
not not much is going on but black finds
it yeah in particular this move rook c3
and uh as as our viewers can probably
see on their screens mvl is down to 54
minutes and lanier who uh generally he
plays very slowly very slowly once he
gets out of book
yeah but he doesn't but he doesn't get
out of book easily he works on chess
incredibly diligently and he currently
is on on 92 and a half minutes starting
from 90. i wanted to say i mean wait a
minute i i don't know if this is some
kind of a personal record for linear
pretty sure it is pretty
it's pretty impressive yeah pretty sure
it's not and okay rook d3 all
part of his preparation the point of
rook d3 here is that black as alejandra
also mentioned would very much like to
play knight g5 b6 in general kind of
decouple this knight pair from f6 and d5
which are currently kind of stuck in the
center of the board and
in particular item d5 is vulnerable to
all kinds of play i think roon g3
indicates some sort of bishop h3
followed by rook hd one or queen g2 but
i think more g1 because the point here
if i play ib6 it straight up loses a
piece in one move remarkably ruxin iii
and this is why this is why queen f2 was
played on the previous move as well i
thought it was a bit of a you know
mysterious queen move
sometimes you know normally it's a
mysterious rook move this is a
mysterious queen move exactly but after
rook d3 no longer very mysterious he's
just saying this knight on d5 is very
very misplaced and i'm hearing you loud
and clear bishop h3 rook d1 i can see
the threats piling up very very quickly
i'm thinking alejandro this is a bit of
a traffic jam
with black's pieces here how is he going
to untangle his knights you can either
be a complete engine and play the move
rook d e8 rook d that's a little
contorted
but think about it logically what's the
point he wants to go e5 with e4 e3 i
think nope he just wants to go knight b6
and you have the d8 square
[Laughter]
simple simple chassis
symbols another way to do that is to
take advantage of the tactics of the
current position and decouple the
knights immediately go knight d7 take
advantage of the fact that this bishop
is currently hanging so you don't have
the time to take on d5 but the bishop
will retreat and this is a clever idea
to play bishop d2 and then go bishop a5
the engines say it's still okay for
black you can put the knight on f on f6
don't put it on b6 because then bishop
a5 is such an annoying pin right but put
it on
f6 um
if lanier follows the engine which i'm
sure he will bishop a5 attacks the queen
forces the move b6 and then you just
retreat the bishop again and now these
two bishops eyeing the queen side will
give white enough compensation in my
opinion more than enough compensation
for the pawn and wide retains a nice
initiative so dominguez with excellent
preparation really asking tough
questions from maxime rook d8 is not a
natural move to play knight d7 bishop d2
you start looking at it deeply and you
start saying this doesn't look very good
the rook's already on d3 targeting my
queen side it's going to be difficult
for me to hold on to it long term
especially without a light square bishop
i don't want to be forced to play the
move b6 boldly stating the obvious mvl
is burning through a lot of clock
on these quite difficult decisions
here peter a few
were placed in mvl shoes the move rook
d8 to e8 uh yeah that didn't come too
easily
yeah i think rook d8 is findable if you
go like if we go through
uh a kind of a
list thinking exercise like yeah also i
wanted to mention e4
if iv4 might look logical for a second
there because fe4964 we've solved all of
our problems we're probably instantly
better because g5 is hanging we're not
winning because the knight on d5 is also
hanging but we're doing well okay but i
think rook d4 is incredibly incredibly
awkward here because yeah the pawn is
hanging if you take one of three after
queen takes f3 your entire happy yeah
your entire edifice is crumbling here
because everything is suddenly hanging
and if you have to play e4 e3
uh i'm not sure why this is even obliged
to take but even if we do take
the results yeah the resulting position
is i mean d65 this is sort of playable
actually i think this is maybe a bailout
option that uh mvl is exploring at least
not your favorite bailout option because
you're definitely worse even here you're
giving back the pawn under favorable
circumstances but so very importantly it
revives the bishop 27 if once again if
we go to the very last position there e3
double take
or a treble take actually yeah we go d5
i want to play bishop d6 i want to put
it on e5 like rook he8 my position
starts to breathe it's not that horrible
honestly uh so it it i think very much
depends uh on how mvl assesses yeah
sometimes this does worry me a little
bit yeah yeah if i could get that bishop
to either like if i could play bishop c5
or get it to b6 yes
but i can't but you were also about to
explain that e3 we're not even compelled
to capture so maybe
maybe you move like queen e2 and then i
go rook h8 and i mean it's it's a kind
of but then when you play c4 and you
take it like for free and you take it
without trading i love that i love your
concept of just bringing the rook to d1
and that's very fair this is right right
on the vine yeah but what i wanted to
say is i think the way you might end up
playing e4 and then e3 is
like you failed to find rook g8 and you
severely dislike the idea of ever having
to play b7 b6 and those bishops due to
a5 lines right which i think is as a
night of player i think and in general
like you really don't want to be
softening up your structure on the queen
side against the bishop pair and against
the very active pieces it looks
risky right so very a lot here depends
on how pessimistically
assesses the current situation because
the 43 is is definitely a bailout nobody
is happy about having a player in the
three exactly but if you feel that your
position is dangerous that you're
falling dangerously behind on on the
clock as well and you want to trade some
pieces off the board and perhaps play
something simplified sourcing yeah
simplify the enforcing even if it
doesn't equalize uh immediately you
might come to the conclusion as for rook
g8 in the current position i think the
way you get there is once again you
realize your knight on d5 needs to move
you realize 96 is impossible you also i
think well i mean it's it's like a three
second consideration but you definitely
consider the move rook c8
and then you realize bishop h3 makes it
completely pointless because
it'll have to run again and then perhaps
you look at other squares
so just to give yourself the d square
but i think
it's it's a difficult decision even even
though
you can sort of imagine the thought
process which lands you there lots of
difficult uh
decisions uh the players will let them
stew for a moment but we have a special
from cubitique a very natural decision
there for you
take a look at this
oh this is wonderful this is a sinkhole
cup polo a
cotton polyester spandex blend polo
features a the sinful cup logo on the
front and the saint louis chess club
logo on the sleeve here available of
course
for both men and women and uh
it's available as with
everything else we are showing you here
at
cubaticstl.com so do take a look
and uh yesterday we had a very nice
opening ceremony in a outdoor pavilion
but our friend alejandro he was a
magnificent master of ceremonies as uh
guys we had a
one of the better
maybe the best i thought i thought
yeah we've ever had generally i think
you know chess players and i still you
know
kind of remember
the feeling that i was one at some point
uh
just like the genre because the the
opening ceremony generally happens like
on a day prior to around one right yeah
your thoughts are already in particular
here where the pairings are announced so
everybody knows what they're what
they're going to be doing the next day
and from for players the the you know
the thought process of trying to prepare
for that game has already begun right
and it kind of gets in the way the cymo
was so nice because the juniors all get
to play against their heroes you and i
may never get to play a novak djokovic
in a game of tennis but you can say i
played against magnus carlsen and
alireza ferrugia
they all had to gang up on me to beat me
up
but yeah you kind of interrupted me
there at a negative point
not not the interruption but like the
point was unfortunate it looked like i
was you know slagging the the opening i
thought that was linear it was yeah yeah
but
what they did yesterday was just so nice
in so many ways that i think i think the
players couldn't possibly have minded
and uh yeah there was there was this uh
this simul five five players of the
tournament did and then a very very nice
streamlined opening with speeches by by
rex and uh
and the other the person in charge of
the
forest park which was
very very nice
and uh the whole ceremony is on youtube
and alejandro i thought the
the rap song about bobby fisher and 40
moves away
was
brilliant it was very creative oh i
loved it it's so fun to see the
creativity here in st louis and i love
that we have this cooperation with the
world chess hall of fame there you saw
brian owens and his band uh performing
yesterday and it was great how they're
able to bring all of this together to
celebrate chess in so many ways
and
we're going to see you on the other side
of our break see you then
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
welcome to our show
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
that's our show now go start yours this
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round one of the single
chess uh single cup 2022
and here are the pairings for the round
that we're watching with uh
as you can see the central game of the
round probably being the one between
magnus and yanipanishi but there is
plenty of action on all the boards
very very interesting round in progress
so far
indeed to echo your words uh peter it
seems to me that all the games have uh a
great deal of content
to them and i like the clashes that are
going on in particularly
i like the game between ali raza and
fabi after d5 knight takes e5 really the
most combative i want to start with now
we kind of dismissed this after d5 takes
c4 and we were investigating the lines
of d3 take c4 but during our break peter
we were exploring yeah we were trying to
figure out if we like if you like just
castling here for white so the idea
being that if you take with the with the
pawn after a2 a3 i assume knight c2 and
then let's say rook b1 knight takes d3
and then will be one uh the pawn g3 is
seemingly falling and if it falls the
lc2 will be in in desperate trouble so
as well yeah uh we were looking at
bishop i was i was trying to calculate
five which invites bishop takes b7 and
then perhaps queen c7 bishop takes a8 is
now forced and
maybe we can take on a8 but we can
definitely take on e5 to protect the
ball on d3 the bishop probably goes back
to all the way to g2 and let's say i go
rook g8 here
and crazy position and we get some kind
of a very very messy position where
there is this pawn on d3 which is
obviously extremely strong but white has
no weaknesses and is up in exchange so
trying to figure out without computer
help if this is any good for black it's
quite difficult we were having fun
alejandro but clara cobwebs knight takes
e5 the most dynamic position in round
one what's going on no i think we
certainly underestimated this move
castles in this position and it's
completely playable let's go down a
couple of these lines you guys were
mentioning taking on d3 here and a3 now
the engine is pretty adamant about this
there is no need to move this knight to
c2
if you do so after knight c2 rook b1 you
do run into a couple of issues they just
think this is still okay for the black
side both after this move bishop f5
uh because bishop takes b7 rook b8 you
mentioned already uh the move knight c6
here in this position right no we didn't
no
we weren't playing rugby we'll play
mitchy seven immediately we see seven
immediately sorry my bad uh and it says
black is doing fine enough compensation
for the exchange but that you can play
the move rook b8 uh and just kick out
this bishop the engines don't like this
so much they think that after the move
uh knight c2 rook b1
uh bishop f5 is perfectly playable but
that you should not take on b7
because you have to move queen f3
hitting this bishop and preparing the
move rook d1 as well as trying to take
on b7 with the queen hitting more pieces
96 would have a double attack against
the queen and the bishop and of course
i'm forcing some uh exchanges if i take
on a8 think that white is okay but the
problem for the engines is that after
castle c takes d3 a3 don't play the move
knight c2 instead play the move queen d6
in this position kick out the knight
first you could take on f7 but after i
take on f7 and you take on b4 i don't
take on b4 that would give white a very
strong advantage because this pawn on d3
is very weak and after knight b5 knight
d4 this pawn will eventually fall and
the engine keeps growing in evaluation
after you let it think but after c takes
before eight
after eight takes before i'm not
compelled to take this i can just
advance my pawn leave this as a weakness
and of course reinforce this pawn on d3
with a very strong black advantage and
what else do you do after the move queen
d6 your knight is currently hanging if
you take on before i take on e5
immediately you could take on c5 but
again nothing compelling me to recapture
immediately you don't have b4 because
this knight on c3 is hanging so let me
take the tempo and defend miss pawn on
d3 with the rook behind the pawn he'll
take on c5 eventually and it is saying
black advantage so certainly something
to consider here for our lorezza the
move castles but the more the engine
thinks about it the less it likes it
and i think we have a move
remarkable
no he has taken on c4 he's taken on c4
and by the way i think our
chess federation is going to have to
take the fingerprints of lanier
dominguez i i can't believe i'm saying
this he's an hour ahead on the clock is
this the is this the real linear
dominguez alejandro i mean have you ever
witnessed this before in his uh
we have actually i will i will be the
boring voice of reason here and i will
reiterate that you know for for he is
unbelievably well prepared and we have
seen this exact scenario before actually
him you know having 130 on the clock by
move i don't know 22 and then like
having 25 minutes on the clock by move
25
he's done this i think before our eyes
during bucharest
at least a couple of times but yes so
far yeah 132 on the clock for linear
he's finally thinking after uh this line
that we were discussing all appeared on
the board 97 bishop d29506 bishop a5
very natural provoking b6 very very
beneficial to white
the bishop drops back and uh
maxim played rook c8 here not the move
king a7 which
uh i think we were discussing uh
attacking the opponent c2 i think uh mvl
what he's saying here is that
your most natural move appears to be
rook c3 and i would very much like to
start trading so i'm just going to play
queen b7 and i will very very happily
trade away this
rather i blundered the knight a5 here
didn't i
maybe queen a7
because of that just to get away uh out
of the region yeah i kind of i kind of
interrupted myself mid-sentence there
because i realized that knight a5 there
right um
so but the idea in general of trading
away the rook uh on the third i think is
very valid because the fewer pieces
white has to immediately try to attack
the somewhat uh softened
right structure on the queen side the
better for black exactly and i'm i'm
sitting there thinking to myself well
gee if i'm white i just i just so want
to get in this moves bishop g2 f4 rook
d1
and
this long diagonal thanks to that pawn
being on b
six and not b7 it's just so utterly
compelling yeah it's like you're a siren
call uh calling um
is there another way that i can just
i don't know bishop eth should be three
maybe bishop g5 actually g5 is a good
square for the bishop in all of these
positions so it's just funny that the
bishop came from chief right right right
he did bishop d2 bishop a5 and then just
kidding bishop d2 bishop g5
it's a very funny sequence but it might
be a reasonable move here and not only
reasonable it's a top energy move by a
long shot claiming that white has a very
strong advantage after the move bishop
g5 and only after the move bishop g5 it
doesn't like trading rooks with the
movement it doesn't matter
it doesn't seem very natural but bishop
g5 puts this pressure on the light
squares it's spinning the knights
and if i'm given a free move i have
several options bishop h3 is one of them
i love bishop h3 of course this diagonal
has immediate tactical problems but it's
also saying on a good day you can go
queenie too
queenie two simply trying to get that
pawn on a6 you don't want to move your
pawn to b5 if it's already too exposed
you could play the move queen b7 but
when your queen goes to b7 then i'll
play bishop g2 i've stopped you from
playing e4 f4 is going to come with a
tempo and remember that the bishop on g5
because it's spinning the knight will
make d5 more uncomfortable to play so
yes bishop g5 is a very strong
alternative in this position and the
engines do think that maxim despite
being upon is currently in trouble
and also remember he is leading our
position
[Music]
and mvl of course as you started at the
top of the show leading the tour uh
the the the french tri-colors at the top
there number one and two 26 and a half
points every point vital
remember the winner of the grand chess
tour point a grand chess tour doesn't
just get the title and bragging rights
it's an additional hundred thousand
dollar bonus to the winner of the tour
and seconds not bad either but there's a
big difference fifty thousand dollars uh
i can't believe i'm saying this but
you know that pawn
i really do feel like lanier is the one
in the driver's seat this is a very
important game as we get the tournament
started but now i really have to go back
to the perugia game because this was the
position
that we were looking at queen takes d1
king takes d1
and i said pause here for a moment
because i think our initial
uh reactions were ooh knight g4 we may
be seeing this peter what what is ali
reza going to do against knight g4 not
sure i
because i kind of really dislike they
they might be
you know equalizable the positions after
takes takes f3 b6
but i am just so easily picking black
there i think
at some point do we want to throw in a
check ourselves as well or do we just
want to be true i think we don't know
which rook so okay bishop e6 is a move
we're going to need yeah i think hp6
always happens so uh i think it always
makes sense to start by doing things
that you absolutely will do yeah i don't
have to stop you there because f3 is
just a bad move it's just a bad it's
just a bad move i mean f3 kills your
game yeah you have links you have to
play king d2 yeah then likely yes but
king d2 with the idea that the knights
coming to d5
is going to at least put some pressure
on black to prove the compensation for
the pawn
i agree and i agree wholeheartedly
because this bishop g2 is just crying
after the movement three like guys don't
do this to me and as you're saying uh
you can you can block the check
uh with a future e4 e5 as well and i
much prefer trying to defend or
this position then for some reason my my
mind has completely blocked out king g2
because i thought there will be a way to
put pressure against this knight on d5
right he's well supported yeah yeah
then i'm pretty sure this is what he's
like that's his plan against knight g4
94 as hundred mentioned is not the only
move in the position i think he also
said bishop five was playable right yes
bishop f5 kind of invites e4 though e3
e4
um yeah but i guess then we maybe drop
drop it back to e6 and go from there
but that's the plug i wanted and that is
yeah but then we've got 95 yeah no but
the critical is to go knight g4 you're
gonna play it right now you can play it
after taking on d1 but i think that's
what you need to be aiming for
you can say you can do it without knight
queen takes d1 yeah i just don't see a
difference
[Laughter]
that's actually pretty amusing
you can see why that would be you that
would be the case wow
i must say uh someone
somebody plays knight g4 against me i
get somebody won that guy
knight g4 okay the queen let's do it the
the reasonable way queen d1 king d1 uh
naiji for takes takes king judo so this
is king d2 this is now the critical
position our tabby we need to figure it
out yeah and what is going on here peter
i don't know
what
don't you dare say i want to i want to
play i want to play i guess because of
the my follow-up i think i probably want
to play rook ada check here okay but i
still can't make it work and 95 b5 this
was my kind of plan
i can't figure out what i what i'm doing
against 82a3 in this position this is my
issue because
i'm one time for short from uh
doing the things that i want to do you
can make an argument that it's an
achievement that i'm taking on d5 and
forcing you to take with the pawn and
not the bishop and maybe it is but i'm
still
down
reason a reasonably healthy pawn in the
center and if white stabilizes here i'm
going to be in trouble and maybe you
stabilize maybe you don't the engine
continues this variation with the move
bishop e6 you can put it on your board
moves the king to e2 because now the
bishop on e6 is hanging e2 bishop and
then bishop f7 and just continues the
attack says well you haven't developed
yet bishop h5 is coming opening the
center against the king is obviously
going to be a good thing for me and the
engine is obviously say 0.00
of course it does yeah of course it does
in a position where white now has two
protected past pawns in the center
exactly exactly of course it's a dead
equal position dead equal gosh i'm just
i just
i was well this doesn't no this is there
no this is very very no not with the
king coming to e6 as well right i'm
playing for a win here with black king
of seven king six double on the default
play c5 c4
yeah but something like i mean if i
wants to equalize here we just play
bishop b3 we return the pawn where never
wars here i think like fe bishop take c4
take on d5 player d1 this one is very
very safe
and as white i'm actually referring this
greatly to the one with the protection
protect the passer yeah yeah like this i
like a lot better because i have you
know the position breathers and my
bishop is not completely dead behind the
point the form chain wow uh
you know
what to our eyes looks to be a
remarkably difficult strategic and
tactical position
uh we we can't bring anybody to having a
big edge alejandro was there a way to
keep queens on the board i'm wondering
about the woman of queen c7 right now
i don't think it will work but i just
want to bring up the the idea of perhaps
preserving the queens on the board for
for a bit
i want to drive this knight away and
then play rook g893 check that'll be
lovely but you don't drive it away i go
f4 yeah this is this was what i was
worried about that four looks kind of
ugly ugly
but yeah if white gets a tempo to play
to a3 and we haven't landed the knight
on d3 yet
we're not going to be very happy about
being upon down here exactly
but just finishing
the test i was hoping i can find some
way to play bishop uh
yeah yeah
oh but there's a knight b5
i'm completely on the wrong track here
uh no i i can't get behind your queen c7
uh oh what what what what what uh i
thought we had one boring game in the
round i no longer think that
let's take a look at shaq's game against
uh
well boring i i've rarely used the word
boring when to describe chess games but
it was kind of a measured you know
it was at some point jack offered the
queen trade and i thought okay this will
be some kind of an end game with a very
small plus for white remarkably king f8
was chosen by wesley by the way and a
move the five came instantly so
at that point was still very much in his
prep he still expected king of fate even
wow
wow
this is a this is a very instructive
moment where he goes bishop b5 takes on
c6 because we talk so often about the
advantage of the pair of bishops right
but specifically when you have an
isolated pawn
it's very useful to have knights because
you can use the squares e4 and c4
i was talking about black in this case
and you eliminate knights so that they
don't jump around using the d5 pawn as
protection
uh so that's a very instructive moment
for me this bishop b5 takes on c6 not
the most natural maneuver when you think
about it we were only looking at the
move bishop b1
right absolutely and wesley
said okay but let's steer the game
towards an ending and then didn't take
and then didn't take on b6 it was a very
interesting kind of a sequence where you
play queen d4 you offer the queen trade
black says sure let's do it on my terms
but yeah sure goes right dc8 and you say
nah psych you know i just wanted to get
it to a better square right
no
no queen trade for you goku and d3 and
this is where i i went a bit wow on on
our viewers here so you're sitting there
saying okay i want to play knight d4
yeah and g5 is unexpected and i would
need to be i would need to be
my my first guess is he wants to play
bishop g3 94.
that would be the the own uh he's played
bishop before instantly so he's it's
sort of similar but he wants to start
with this and i guess play knight e4 and
next move if we play bishop b5 hp5 being
far and away the most natural reply to
bishop before here
also it's sorry to interrupt you peter
there but also knight d4 uh
can i i i'm i'm kind of dreaming i
wonder
here aren't we we're just we just i
think we're going in though you're just
partially c3 you can include knight
takes c6 but then we're not that unhappy
with that position right now and if you
go bc i will take on c3 i think you know
i think that's that has to be the point
all 94 first but in any case yeah okay
which is why you mentioned bishop e5
yeah hp5 would be such a nice reply here
if not for the fact that i guess the
plan is to go 94 and once again we're
going in we've ruined our king side
structure but the king on the fate is
not as unsafe
as as all that can i confirm that just
yeah i was looking at that but
i don't think i don't think we generate
mating threats and also very importantly
the pawn is not on h3 so something like
rook c1 might just be winning the game
here right there
no uh
no no rook takes d2 uh
no you just you can give you can give a
couple of checks i will go to the g file
but your rook is pinned
and the game sort of ends yeah and as
you said there's no h3 in the position
so
we understand who's on the attack well
um
my goodness uh
g5 this is suddenly this is suddenly an
incredibly concrete position which is
you know not quiet and it's not going to
an unquiet position
chaos
bam
uh no escaping the chaos and what have
you been keeping your eye on uh
alejandro let's update a couple of games
this is the one between hans demon and
levon aronyan and you can see this is
not going well for black there's so many
dark square weaknesses on the queen side
very difficult to solve once this knight
gets to c5 let one just play the move
knight d7 attacking this rook on e5 i
expect it to go back to e3 just so that
it keeps uh some pressure on the third
rank as well and i'm going to play c3
i'm going to play rook a1 i'm going to
play knight c5 one day you're not going
to really want to take on c5 in many
cases because b takes c5 opens off the
position against b7 now because of the
symmetrical structure or symmetrical ish
black has obviously uh chances to save
this game no doubt about it but it's a
very uncomfortable position if i put
anything on e8 this bishop becomes spin
after rook a1 you don't have any counter
play on the king on the king's side to
speak off and that was a mouse slip
rookie one is coming and perhaps there's
no immediate threats but when you think
about rookie one and you start coupling
it with bishop d3 maybe one day go f4
even
hint at the move f5 black doesn't have a
lot of space and black does has no
active plan to speak of
there are no weaknesses there is no play
there are there's nothing for black to
target or attack and that's a very
uncomfortable situation to be in here
for black and this is why the engines
are screaming adventist white adventist
white advantage y i will take a slightly
contrarian position here and say that
while i don't disagree with a single
word you said
i also think
this is maybe best case scenario
because levon actually managed to get
all of his pieces out
now the knight on a4 is
sort of
countered by the 97 meaning that yes you
can get it to c5 but i will take i i
will take
you know on the protest and i will be
unhappy about it
but it does not sort of survive to you
know exert an incredible amount of
pressure against my position there i
will have a weakness on b7
once the trade happens on c5 but it's a
pawn so very deep inside my position
that perhaps i can just drop back the
bishop to c8 and say you know we're done
with this now
and
you know the sort of the battle lines
have been drawn uh white of course is
much better
but
there is i think still clear blue sky
between much better and winning the game
and this is one of those positions where
you will be better for the for the next
50 moves you will continue being better
until the moment where you finally
accept some kind of repetition and the
game is drawn because you can't offer it
uh if it doesn't go well for you i'm not
saying hans definitely will not win
today he could
but i'm saying that somewhere around
move 15 somewhere around the point where
we started thinking after bish before
i thought
even this might be sort of beyond black
to a degree because it felt like the
knight might land on c5 and be
unchallenged there right and those
positions are just kind of lost you know
this one isn't this one is wars but
those would be those would be
like unplayable right so i think levon
has done well to
realized he realized how dangerous his
position was potentially right and yeah
this decision on move 14 specifically to
go bishop g5 b5 bishop f6 waste to tempe
in order to trade the dark square yeah
to try to trade the best piece in his in
his position the bishop of six was the
only one that she was actually doing
something right and but he he realized
that with the bishop exerting so much
pressure on the h2ba diagonal he
wouldn't even get this
and yeah he will not enjoy any of it but
on the topic of the pressure along the e
file i very much like the idea of sort
of as soon as possible playing f6 bishop
seven
just to not have that stuck on e6 uh
because i'm very very uh worried that if
i play rookie seven or cafe eight and
white somehow managed i don't know to
triple along the e file yeah i will
never move any of those pieces again
you'll be uh stuck yeah so i would like
to play f6 bishop seven and i would like
to start yes yes
i'm afraid yeah i'm very afraid that's
but that's the thing that uh
yeah it needs preparing maybe you have
to go even one step further with the g6
only after you've played c3 all of this
is incredibly ugly right this is not
going to be pretty from levon's side but
then from hans neiman's side i mean this
is like hey i'm i'm in the driver's seat
everybody's uh looking at me how will i
collapse it's a positive free role for
white house white white has white has
everything under control
what was going to be our marquee game by
the way he kind of faded out on us here
a little bit oh this is a
magnus and yan it's it's on the slow
boil it's a slow boil but that's exactly
what magnus loves right when you think
about magnus and his traditional style
of chess before he became a more dynamic
player i would say after 2018
he loved these grinds this equal but is
it really fully equal some kind of
imbalance long term end games no queens
you just kind of uh outgrind your
opponent nothing too sharp nothing too
quick and if you see the current
position we do have these imbalances
white has the pair of bishops he's
currently secured the fact that he has a
pair of bishops with the move bishop f2
he was probably preempting white black
going bishop d6 and challenging the
bishop that was on g3 and what we're
going to have is just a very very long
game
black has this nice
queen side pawns they can't really be
challenged because there's no a3 b4 but
on the other hand what is black's active
planet if you see white spawn's
structure on the center and the king
side it controls so many squares it's
nice on f6 and e6 they're well placed
but where are they going what are you
going to be doing next there is an
active plan with the move c5 at some
point but that gives you an isolated
pawn do you really want to do that
questions questions yeah it's an
interesting one uh because
like i think there's a lot of temptation
here for jan to think
uh i don't quite understand how i'm ever
getting beaten in this structure so why
not just you know wait forever right
okay
yeah
but also i'm not sure it's entirely safe
to assume white never achieves any
progress right
and then and then c65 definitely comes
into the uh into the conversation
because if you if white replies by
taking on c5
very often with this knight on e6 being
exactly where it's supposed to be we
will be pushing for d5d4 extremely
quickly and it will be difficult to stop
in particular like even if we start
analyzing here if you play c5 here i'm a
bit worried about knight a2 though yeah
you cannot play c5 right away but let's
analyze it just for the terms of
structure
yeah so just to just to show our viewers
knight a2 here is incredibly awkward
because bishop take bishop a5 dc5 we've
just lost a pawn for oops for no reason
whatsoever so you have to prepare it by
perhaps dropping the bishop back to e6
first
uh but yeah in terms of structure if we
get c5 if white ignores it and allows
the trade on d4 we will have a very very
nice square on f4 for our pieces and if
this trade happens d5d4 might be
legitimately difficult to stop exactly
so it provides you a kind of a proactive
plan
uh
to search for for counterplay whereas
yeah passing is
is awkward here for black because you
propose for me
uh perspective mm-hmm uh let me be
you know uh
belligerent and not just i was wondering
about you
if i
uh
my most challenging best
the move g5 i'm a little bit concerned
that maybe there's a refutation
that starts with takes and bishop h4
maybe my king is misplaced but what do
you think about the move g5 or
can i get away with g5
um i was going to suggest in case you go
h5 you actually want to play
okay this is why i think i think this is
an improvement yeah
and i will start shuffling slightly
differently bishop d3 bishop g3 i will
yeah bishop g3 i'm always wanting to
meet with yeah but it's it becomes wait
a minute there's a rook h8 issue yeah
it's it it becomes awkward i'm not sure
we want to do this with blue no no we
can't go g5h5 and ignore it i think
right we can we can leave it there
and say
with this inclusion uh any kind of a
push on the king side has become
progressively more difficult
because organizing f4 is not going to be
anywhere
anywhere near as easy but yeah all of
these things are uh difficult to judge
jan for now goes bishop d6
and what a head-head rivalry these two
have had including a world chess
championship yeah that changed the score
a little bit i was about to say a lot a
bit yeah that was that was a four-nil
victory for uh for magnus meaning that
he was in the minus before the dubai
match started he no longer is as you can
see on your screen jan was yeah one of
the remaining
you know buzzers to have philadelphia
resistance against uh magnus having a
plus score but yeah
so here we've got magnus doing his thing
and slightly better and more space but
just a long long grind ahead
uh can we just take a quick look once
again at uh linear and i wanted to
we talked about uh he'll definitely be
below an hour when he makes a move that
was it
what's the over and under
i mean i'm thinking like 57 132 we
started with
no i think it was maybe one yeah oh
maybe it was actually one thirty two i
think it was 130 then after rook c8
lanier
we're on move 20 and i believe that by
move 25 mvl will have more time
and i might i'm 25 might be too long
yeah i think i think you're kind of
trying to hustle us here exactly exactly
exactly uh also at this time in the show
i mean because the sinkville cup is very
much unlike the rapids and blitz gives
us a time to talk and uh explore the
world of chess and answer questions from
the audience as well
as we opened up the show we said that
anastasia is uh
offering a lot of cool stuff on the
social media she uploads a lot of her uh
videos that she's been taking and
interviews but also
uh we'll pass along questions so any
questions that you might have of peter
or alejandro or myself even varusian is
good for a good quip now and then
absolutely
i will be delighted to answer your
questions what do you mean even even
well i mean i have a tough one somebody
sent me a text so i'll put it as the
question all right and it's about this
mvl linear dominguez one i'm gonna throw
it to you guys
the engine says a3 is a move and a3 was
played what is the purpose of the move
a3
uh
you mean way way way back way back
okay well this is easy for me gosh i
have no problem with this one i'm gonna
turn it over
i mean i got this i got this guys do you
know what do you think about aqa3 i
think we i think we covered it to a
degree during bucharest and i think i
should have a clue but i
it's uh
i always think of these moves as just a
kind of a useful uh useful passing move
but since we're replying to queen g7
with g3
um
it's i mean in some positions you can
you can imagine this being aimed
specifically there was this line how
does it go
there is a slime where the root gets
trapped on the sixth
what the sixth oh my
but it's not here right it's uh
like there are positions like black can
reply to most quiet things that you can
do here by just moving the knight away
from the g5 square and saying if you
want to win your pawn back you can take
on f6 and then d6
and then there are some positions in
which
uh
yeah i mean not with the knight on c7
but my point
yeah usually it goes to b6 yeah
and then let's say we go knight b6 here
let's say bishop f6
and bishop f6 uh queen d6 takes stakes
and i can play knight c8 in in this
position
and trap the rook yeah because if you
take on a six it gets picked up it's a
like it's almost a full rook you will
you'll get a pawn for it but no more
okay and i was trying to figure out if
a3 somehow improves on that but i don't
see how yeah i'm giving up you you
probably know the answer so
i'm not going to mess up our viewers
understanding of the position by sharing
what i think this is this is actually
the sun game is better for one this
actually is better for white with a move
a3 and now with g3 you can actually take
on f6 in this position the difference is
that after king e7 now somehow this move
works miracle
oh yeah we're providing the c6 square
for our rook right because yeah
is
but it doesn't work in the other
variation with g3 and a3 it's g3 instead
of a3 uh i'm not entirely sure why but
the difference according to the engine
between this end game sorry this end
game here
just retreating the rook back to d3 with
the pawn on g3 and the pawn on a3 are
completely different they think this is
much better for white and the other
scenario it's just equal so somehow so
it was actually sort of correct yes you
are correct random it is absolutely
random
absolutely randomly let's call it
[Laughter]
like throwing up a three-pointer from
from deep deep
near the half court line um shout out to
kevin mcphee well thank you for the text
question a3 that's why you play a3 and
just uh
help me out on the current position for
a moment because we're joking about
lanier going into a 30-minute 50-minute
tank how deep it can be we're not joking
we're predicting we're predicting okay
uh but we have predicted quite some time
ago and it won't be a surprise to lanier
i'm sure bishop g5 is
you know his go-to
move but
as he seems to be contemplating other
choices or maybe he's just looking at
bishop g5 and analyzing more deeply
alternatives to bishop g5 well rook c3
it really is it really is that
yeah i think he just doesn't like making
any moves without you know considering
the follow-up very properly it's i think
it's not in his nature
to like the way i would approach this
position with white i would
okay c2 is hanging i need to write
something about it exactly the most
obvious replies rook c3 but then i think
you come to the conclusion that this is
a valuable rook and you don't
particularly enjoy the thought of having
to trade it away okay
so you probably start looking at
alternatives you realize the bishop can
go to some squares
you consider bishop b3 but i think bhp3
is a bit anodyne i don't think it does
enough you know d6d5 i think is a
reasonable reply to it and you're almost
encouraged
yeah you're not it doesn't seem like you
you're doing it right you realize bishop
g5 exists you definitely spend some time
let's say checking out knight e4 i think
this might be an important conversation
there bishop g594 fe4 uh bishop takes g5
but then you see bishop takes a6 and you
get well it's
an illegal move right so oh
excuse me well b would be a strong move
it would be in a great movie yeah
right now if we
yeah
so i would get to somewhere here i would
realize there is nothing particularly
wrong with bishop g5 tactically at least
i can't refute it like in the first five
minutes
and i would think to myself
i've done my due diligence here uh
let's go i like this move the bishop
generally like i've
lanier has played this position a bunch
he has analyzed the bunch sure he knows
the bishop is g5 is arguably the best
square on the board for it
and i would just kind of move on because
i think
time will still be required later in the
game also i'm just
kind of a lazy person at the board so i
don't really
put lazy person at the board you
probably see as much in
your first 60 seconds as i do in my
first 10 minutes of thought so i would
have moved on i think if i saw the move
bishop g5 at all you know on a bad day i
wouldn't realize this exists you know
i've also done that
over the years i was attracted to an
idea that alejandro mentioned now you
mentioned this yourself peter
in fact you caught yourself in
mid-sentence so to speak rook c3 queen
b7 and you went knight a7 and wait uh
and let me take that back
you went to a7 with the queen
and then i was thinking what alejandro
said you know this pawn on a6 and this
queen it's over here yeah maybe that
maybe that
b6 b5 inducing b6
we're incredibly happy we're incredibly
happy right uh yeah this is actually a
good a good uh kind of a pointer towards
what he could be thinking about this is
very very solid
where's the queen on a7
because we were afraid to play oh you
mean queen d no no no
i was going to say b7 knight a5 the line
definitely doesn't end there you can
play queen g5 here you can play uh yeah
specifically queen g5 was kind of
bugging me a little bit queen d5 yeah
but i thought maybe we can find this
tingling here yeah we have all kinds of
moves i got rook d3 queen c5 i guess
queen c and also after rook b3 my move
here was rook b3 but i guess even here
maybe queen c5 is annoying
what
that's well i mean i'm attacking a bunch
of stuff i'm attacking the queen i'm
attacking the pawn on c2 which i assume
you can't ignore entirely even though
queenie two in this position remains
being a move right
uh
looks super sharp yeah to our eyes uh
andrew i just wanna kinda go go back to
my
no
this explains why you could tank for
half an hour here because i think i
think if it's just a straight up choice
between rook c3 and bishop g5 on general
grounds
you just pick bishop g5 and you go
exactly but if rook c3 uh you realize
screen a7 queen e2 might be unpleasant
and after queen b7 you do have knight a5
and maybe you are convinced you can make
it work for white right then you can
definitely imagine spending quite a
you know prolonged
time going down the rabbit holes here
yeah yeah there's a very unfortunate
thing that you know engines are engines
right right e5 is an issue
between a8 forces knight b3 yeah i
thought we could play knight c4 there
but apparently yeah 94 why can't i go
knight c4 there why can't you go knight
c4 i think that my plan was to go knight
c4 and then rook b3 and then claim that
i'm exerting pressure against the
acquaintance
but maybe you get hit with a knight c5 i
don't know no it's just knight d5 yeah
would be three
and then b5 and then okay
and once again it's something that
it's like that extremely famous uh
petrossian caspar of petrossian game
right
from
tilburg i think so right it's the one
where uh
actually e6 yeah yeah i used it i used
it as a in a lecture once and it's a
kind of a striking game because caspar
of you know remained winning for much of
it like completely winning and tigran
continued finding some ways to stay
afloat right and then gary sort of went
in for the kill
and then the king just just did the king
just decided defended itself somehow uh
just kind of marched into into the fray
and defended itself
and the fact that this game exists i
think it's kind of very prominent in our
minds
as an idea that you can play like this
you can actually kind of move move your
start you move your stuff towards the
attackers
but i think as white like 100 tells me
rugby 3b5 is good for black
and once i'm told b3b5 is good for black
i can sort of imagine why right but if
i'm if i'm sitting at the board here you
know considering it can be chasing the
quail
you could very easily continue that
variation looking for that you know
elusive and now i win kind of variation
which doesn't exist as we know uh for me
the move uh queen a8 is rather
remarkable in the sense that uh just
kind of just hangs around and this
this whole knight c4 and i guess knight
c5 just comes in this is this yeah we
don't have time to play let's say a3a4
here because knight c5 comes in and
collects everything and without the rook
on b3 we don't really have an attack
anymore true it's the one piece that
creates the creates the pressure not so
surprising peter we kind of did
yeah i i i i took 57 minutes right i've
already lost
i've already i've already lost aha
okay well we'll keep an eye on that one
and again i just want to go back to our
marquee game between magnus and nepo
is playing quite slowly here considering
it's his pet variation
and uh up to a certain point he was even
following his own game by the way that's
not a pose that is very familiar to me
with magnus he is really really
interested i'm more used to like
asleep he's kind of being a little bit
more relaxed a little bit more
california cool you know sitting back in
his chair but this is the posture of a
man who really wants to win alejandro i
mean he is really burning
and digging into the position i mean you
don't get to 2900 which is his goal by
drawing a bunch of 2 700 highs you're
gonna be ending you're gonna lose a
point per game this is white he
definitely wants to win doesn't matter
how long he needs to grind this one down
and he's trying to find a plan and
there's so many options in this position
and what he can be doing uh
but he needs to pick one he's already
placed this uh bishops on d3 and f2
which
they're okay but they're not achieving
that much we have to move bishop d3 and
i wasn't able to see what ian replied to
that he replied that very quickly
did he i still still not on my screen i
think he was going to go back to the
he's played bishop d3 yeah
instantly yeah i think we have quite a
delay actually between
the boards and our moves but yeah they
should be already on the board as you
can see there was a weird one for me
because the bishop we were looking at c5
ideas
i guess he wants to maybe support it
from a7 but
we are really i mean
if we in particular if we go [ __ ] by
seven we're really inviting before
knight a4 knight c5 and i do not want to
you're inviting it right now right
there's nothing wrong with knight a4
immediately i think we go back you have
to go back i think we go back and this
is why i'm surprised that bishop b8 i
don't quite know and the engines say
you're not stopping me if we go a little
bit further go knight a4 okay bishop d6
okay it says well the what i really want
to get is b4 in which b1 bishop b1
but then i would like to play c5 right
then maybe i kind of need to go back to
this plan because i i right right right
i really
i really hate allowing before knight c5
if i if if that happens i'm
but then you've kind of you're really
happy yeah but then you've kind of
reached this position where the knight
on e6 is missing so that d4 e4 you're
not solving your isolani not easily and
b4 b5 is coming and then i don't have 6
is restricted
i don't like bishop b8 i think bishop b
i don't know what he was supposed to do
and i guess the move was prompted by the
fact that
it's just very difficult to make waiting
moves
[Music]
well i'm wondering is the king all that
great on e7 if you're not going to i
don't think you're worried about h5 or
g5 attempts isn't it just time to kind
of like
rookie ape with the king back on f8
that's what the engine thinks yasser
thinks exactly like you but in a
different direction okay king d7 king c7
king v8 was the suggestion of the engine
just tucking your king away on the queen
side okay that's a little bit
well unexpected
like king walk across the
center i think you can sort of
understand the reasoning here because
you're expecting the game to be you know
eventually opened up in the center or on
the king side sure and not having the
king there will
will make it easier for us to deal with
those eventualities even
if so just to put some moves on the
board for just a second
the king ends up making this delightful
little march all the way across the
street and then we wait and then we wait
and then we wait because eventually you
will have to push for either e3 4 or
some kind of g5 and then something and
having the king on b8 i think will help
us in both of those cases because we
just don't have to worry far from the
danger
all right but instead of
that came the move bishop b8 and then
we're kind of warming up to magnus's
position is that what i'm getting here
guys yeah i think sure
i think so yeah
i i don't hate i don't like burning to
tempe this doesn't look like a position
where you can just burn to tempe and say
do your worst i've got a questions for
yourself
in a recent podcast interview lex
yes
magnus was asked what are your goals
has achieved just about everything in
fact everything he can in the world of
chess and he says 2 900. yes to get to
20 the first human i mean that's like
scaling
everest and
k2 uh in the same month
can he do it is it realistic
uh he's an underdog uh but
it's not impossible not a yeah
somebody actually made a research paper
on that you did yeah yeah so i think a
mathematician group from the university
of chicago actually took a look at it
there i saw the paper i wasn't entirely
sure about their methodology they came
up with a number though they gave them a
4.5 yeah i i saw that referred to and uh
to be clear 95 percent
unlikelihood yes
yeah they foreplayed in the meantime
yeah i think mission 6 will be blitzed
out i really don't understand otherwise
the reason why i brought up the question
in the first place is because in my mind
he he magnus had an outstanding result
in the olympiad undefeated on board one
scored something like plus five plus six
zero plus six everything was his four
points lost
which means like in a tournament like
this where he's playing his closest
peers he's gonna have to go plus four
plus five consistently
no for every tournament he plays in
right now i didn't text 2900 yes yes to
get to 2900
i mean what's his expected here
i should know but i would assume it's
plus three i think was there above i
think it's like plus between plus two
and plus three yeah exactly okay so a
very good result here actually gains in
rating even plus three probably doesn't
lose in rating maybe gains him a point
and you can imagine him score scoring
like
in good years you know if you remember
the years of his like proper dominance
when he was winning everything right he
was scoring like plus six and bike and
uh and things of that nature yeah so
let's say he goes plus four here he nets
five points right uh he needs to do that
consistently in 10 12
singfil cups
this is why he's an underdog
[Laughter]
i started with that
i started i certainly did you certainly
did i i'll be your witness
but it's not impossible and we've seen
him we've seen him do incredibly well
over long stretches you know this will
have to be perhaps the longest
purple patch he's ever had but it's not
impossible uh
age 31 his peak was 28
his rivals were much closer right too
there was a lot of people above 2 800.
yeah it helps when favi was 28 40 right
right but now he's 27 like 60 or
something like this it's a big
difference so it
is
if the 2800s consistently lose their
rating it becomes much much much harder
it becomes harder for magnus as well of
course yeah all of these mechanics are
in place but
um
by the way just taking a quick look at
the game of thrones
shock kind of agreed with that that
there's no mate and just played rook c2
bishop takes c3 chosen by wesley and
shah is now thinking
we're assuming he's going to recapture
yeah the normal recapture here i think
is the bishop but maybe there is some
argument to be made for bt xc3 and then
just saying i don't want to any more
trades the bishop will be quite good on
g4 but it's just that i'm crying to be
able to play the move queen h7 if i
don't induce your knight
to try to capture
how will i ever get my queen to h7 i
don't think i think this knight only e4
is too valuable and i think black
doesn't actually go knight takes e3 if
you take with the bishop anyway okay
there might be some tactical things we
need to calculate on for like bishop f5
perhaps 94 94 looks very strong
well when i take c3 actually
this line yeah we need to continue
because z1 is hanging
and maybe this works out for black and
if hp5 is playable hp5 is definitely
something that you need to be paying a
lot of attention to exactly but the same
will be true about beta 83 i'm pretty
sure it's not like we're stopping bishop
five by taking with the pawn true
um yeah as i said suddenly just a very
very sharp position which you know all
of a sudden kind of reminds me of some
very very well concrete regardings more
than this same entires that they started
with
all right well weigh in on this one uh
alejandro we're we're trying to decipher
some tactical
motifs in the position after the move
rook c2 we are anticipating well in fact
bishop c3 has been played and we're
anticipating the light squared bishop
getting active on us
all volcanic bishop f5 what's happening
if beat e3 bishop f5 you mean yeah yes
bishop f5 is a dangerous move here
exactly yes there's a lot of tricks uh
knight g3 with the idea of
skewering the queen on d3 and the rook
on c2 as you mentioned it's not so easy
to get out of it you can play bishop d4
but doesn't help you very much the queen
simply retreats to c7 and you have this
awkwardness this problem with the pawn
on c3 and even though you have a very
nice bishop it's pretty much the only
good thing about your position as we can
see the head to head between these two
players
as many decisive games as you would
think with shock being there very
decisive player himself but a slight
edge for him against wesley so now the
engines don't really like taking on c3
with the pawn which is a more combative
way of playing and instead they prefer
taking with the bishop because of the
problems of bishop f5 but unfortunately
can we play it anyway i was wondering if
we can play it anyway if you play it
anyway i think uh
because queen takes d5
the rook on c6 uh remember the d5 is
hanging in many positions so you have to
move it somewhere kind of clever and
because sometimes you have the problem
with the move bishop before remember
what is the problem with playing
something like knight d6 and corking the
bishop on f5 to the skewer well now i
can just take it
take this this is why knight d5 yeah
this is why knight e5 then you give it a
check very clever you take take well
wherever this goes no you can't go to g7
sorry sorry i don't let you do it i'm
just trying to don't pull a mamidaro
game right
and then you take on d5 at the end you
lose a pawn and you pretty much lose the
game the bishop on c3 is very powerful
because it prevents king g7 and you
already see the move bishop takes c3 not
b takes c3 on the board bishop f5 is
unplayable but you can simply snap this
bishop off the board as we mentioned
it's a powerful bishop you kind of have
to take with the pawn if you take with
the rook i can take on b2 be greedy
enough to do that and i have enough
time now to prevent the queen incurs the
incursion on h7 both king g8 and king g7
seem to be okay for the black side
you'll have a nice knight but the
pressure on c3 pretty much balances the
position about equal according to the
engines wow just uh and this is one this
is one of the structures where i would
be just
very very clueless because
if we go back to that final position
let's let's put this on the board for a
second unite c3 let's say
king g894 rook c4 i guess right right
my first instinct is like this is so
happy with white exactly my knight is
dominating the bishop what alejandro is
saying is but you're also tied to a weak
pawn let's say i go i don't know h4 here
or maybe maybe on the previous move but
also here and
i was thinking that you didn't play h4
or f4 yeah because you were thinking
about maybe f4 you know like you start
to get but either one h2h4 or f2f4 you
kind of feel like with the knight you
can
leverage it to a king-sized attack sorry
peter now this is this is a kind of a
position where i think it very much
uh depends on how much how much
experience you have with this particular
structure because i play zero orgasm
with either color
so i've never had an experience of
either playing this position with white
or black or analyzing it for more than
three seconds
and
without this kind of a
you know personal experience of trying
to figure out how this balance is yeah
i just i just flounder in positions like
this because yeah i i go back to my kind
of standbys of saying you know knight on
d4 good bishop only six bad we've also
played g5 but what would you say when i
wouldn't be saying all those words of
course right with apology 7 i recognize
this is always going to be fine for
black but with the pawn on g5 it feels
like
this this has to be a safe advantage but
as i as i saw on alejandro's screen
machines don't think it's anything at
all machines think plenty of counterplay
but that's also something that we have
to
avoid ourselves is that
you know machines have their way of
making a judgment about a position but
you're sitting on the other
side of the board your clock is ticking
and you've got all of the baggage knight
d4
good bishop e6 bad
so that's what's going through
your opponent's mind as well yeah
absolutely and you know i
kind of
uh consciously
made a kind of a caricature there of
your thinking process but sure in in a
way this is how we're hardwired this is
this is a very very solid knight on d4
which cannot be challenged by anything
you will be there for the rest of the
game as long as we want it there for the
rest of the game the bishop on e6 has no
future it's just there purely to protect
the pawn on d5
uh
very difficult for me to start disliking
this exactly exactly but yeah there's uh
there's developments in the fobby game
so we should probably go there all right
uh indeed when we left it we left it a
very oh look at this we've analyzed this
not this position we actually had it
with 95 cd5 first
uh that's right
yeah takes check
e4
and here we were
yes f5 no we yeah if i be completely
issued the whole b5 a3 inclusion he just
went for this straight away exactly
now
there this is a very sharp position a
lot of things can happen the king on d2
of course not very well placed but it is
an extra fun what i'm worried about for
fabi is the clock situation we joked
about linear but fabio has 20 minutes
left and it's moved seventeen yeah
yeah
they've just made their 16th yeah and by
the way can i play devil's advocate for
a moment how are you going to win the
pawn
six i think is the idea here bishop f
six i just went king e2 everybody so the
idea is you don't have time to
that would be a a costly uh blunder of
the bishop but bishop f6 says
i mean i i'm always reluctant to offer
this trade of a knife for a bishop but
if it if it gets the knight from d5 off
the board right
yeah i'm a lot happy about
the whole thing
alejandro
well let's continue analyzing this one
but before we go too much in depth i
want to take some time to look at this
because it's not very common and i'll
say it in the way america's pronounced
el alakai's gun right here with the
queen on e1 rooks on e2 and e3 all
barreling down the e file you can see
what this kind of symmetrical structure
sometimes achieved because every major
piece almost is on the e file then the
edges are saying that hans niemann here
has a very strong advantage against
lavonna ronyan but it's very far from
those kind of advantages where it's easy
to make progress i think in this
position hans is going to have to come
up with something creative to keep up
the bind because you can imagine that
currently black is completely stuck this
knight doesn't want to move because the
knight comes to c5 this bishop doesn't
want to move because it has no squares
you don't want to play f5 and ruin your
structure also you're going to have to
watch out for tactics on the e file so
black has no moves but where do you
increase that's not entirely true i
think the idea here otherwise the
position i think would be lost the idea
here is to go knight of fate on bishop
c8 knight f8 and bishop it actually
allows the knight to c5 but then we're
hoping that once all the rooks are gone
we will we will actually go back to
trying to trade it for our knight
otherwise there legitimately are no
moves
like i don't know like queen c7 queen d6
maybe forever but
yeah
the only way to continue here is knight
of bishops eight but it appears to be
borderline playable because as we
mentioned like the position remains very
very solid and in the meantime by the
way chakri are
i mean wesley just played bishop five
the move we were criticizing but i think
specifically because of knight t5 if you
don't find 95 here yes you are probably
not better at all but 95 is a very nice
move in this position let's go through
the engine line here 95 as we mentioned
this knight cannot move because queen
takes f5 there's only one move in the
position that doesn't lose immediately
and it's retreating the rook to c7 you
have to cover the d7 square as well as
defend your rook now you don't have the
ability to put the rook on
by the way 95 not found
uh shakuya has actually played the move
bishop d4 very quickly as well yeah very
good very quickly as well but this
allows if i've had to play queen c7 and
yes this is definitely better for white
i'm going to be able to kick out your
queen yet again bishop b5 hits the queen
and after queens he said when i can
trade one rook and play something like
94 92 you don't have any pressure
tactically on this diagonal anymore but
after bishop d4 queen b5 is the issue
yeah i'm really sure wesley this is what
wesley is intending here absolutely yes
he does need to to start offering
offering trades as much as possible and
if you avoid the trade with queen a3
check if we go back to that position for
a second
uh after let's say king g8 or k8 queen
e2 will start because the rooks are
coming off and then we will we will have
decent counter play here connected with
the idea of dropping the queen to uh
yeah it starts to look bad for a white
actually yeah it's nice to look double
edged at this yeah you can definitely
imagine this going off the rails a
little bit so yeah uh i think there's
the whole tactic of 95 followed up by in
some positions queen takes a five i
think is very miscible
and i think shah also perhaps trusted
wesley a little bit that bishop five
played after some thought will not be a
bad mistake
and for uh wesley uh he's obviously
a tournament ago i wanted to say he was
in first place in her grandchild
standings he got leap frog quite a bit
he's still in the mix but he needs to
make about four
grand a chess tour points to overtake
maxine yeah so uh
yeah he just needs a good result he is a
good result he needs to uh perhaps do
well and you know have magnus beat
everybody else
so that nobody else gets any any point
they're gonna take a lot of points
forever but as we go on break uh we have
a special for you we asked the players
what's it like
for them to be back in st louis and
these are their answers let's take a
look
how does it feel to be in st louis
playing in the sinkhole top it feels
good it's um
it's also one of those um rare occasions
when magnus is playing he he's
i think taken more of a back seat in
terms of like playing all the events in
the world compared to uh to a few years
ago
so
i haven't played an event with him in
besides the olympiad where we can
we didn't play um but an event like this
with him in quite a while so that will
be interesting of course it feels great
i mean i love playing here in san luis
it's a home for me now and
this year is going to be very
strong
even though even magnus is playing so
uh sounds like a very interesting uh
tournament so i mean
uh really looking forward to it
i'm
always very happy to
be in st louis especially now that i
live here it's going to be
of course a very strong event
as always
and
recently i had some
mediocre results
in classical chess so i would like to
this is normally my forte classical
chess so i'll try to
play better
i i like to play here because here
you play in three two tournaments every
time and
after every tournament he thinks next
will be much better
and this time also i am very happy to
back play in saint louis it's
really
just here is very important
it's a great feeling to be back in saint
louis
i've been i've had the opportunity to to
enjoy a bit of the us
in the past few weeks so i'm well you
know
acquainted now no more jet lag so ready
to play ready to fight right it's my
first time to be in saint louis um
it's a very interesting experience i
always wanted to play in one of these
tournaments in saint louis because it's
a
it's a legendary place i was always
watching growing up
um saint louis tournament so it's
it's a pleasant experience for me and
i really look forward to the tournament
last time i played in 2019 until
everything yeah
so
i wonder how it goes because yeah it was
pretty much up and down last time and
hopefully it will be only up this time
yeah so we will see i'm so glad to be
back here in st louis it really feels
like home to me
i hope to be able to
play well this year i mean my
grandchildren this year has been quite
so and so like i've
played okay in romania but then the next
two wrapped in this didn't really things
didn't really go my way now i have to
see if i can turn make up for some of
the lost points here in the last leg but
i'm very glad to be back here in st
louis all the people i know fortunately
have to focus on jeff and playing well
but
i'm very happy to be here yeah it's my
first grandchester event and playing in
america is
already not something very unique for me
so even being in america um
so obviously i'm honored to play in the
sink field cup it's like the first super
tournament that i've played in classical
so it's a great opportunity and of
course playing chess in st louis like
there's no comparison it feels good to
be uh be back it's been it's been a
while now i've been here for uh for
three years um
certainly this is
uh as tough as the tournament can can
get basically with
nine
with nine opponents so
it's definitely an exciting prospect
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to round one of sinful cup
2022 and uh this is what we're watching
and we're actually watching an
excellent first round and truly
in terms of the variety of content i
think five different openings and five
great positions five very very
interesting positions uh so let's
actually jump back uh jump back into the
action yeah peter uh rewarding and
challenging moments in each and every
game let's just jump right into the
shakriar versus wesley so game because
this is what we we ended with and uh
when we left it we saw the move queen b5
was coming trying to trade off pieces
wesley said let's get off the queen
shack said no i want to go keep them on
check
rook takes pawn takes uh a significant
um
detail here is no more isolani
no more total command over the d4 square
and
queen e2 is a little bit bothersome i'm
wondering if i can afford to play b2b4
here it's very double-edged to stop just
i i so very much want to stop c65 from
happening and after queen e2 we're still
we still have rook f1 as a reply
i'm not in love with this but maybe we
can somehow make this work my biggest
worry actually is before a5 maybe just
to make sure if c65 happens just a6 a5
straight away while there is no way to
play a2a3 right and so something like
this now outcomes 65 and the bishop kind
of gets driven by
one yeah we've also given ourselves more
squares on the long diagonal i'm not 18
i'm not hating b2 before obviously well
and and this is the type of games that
we've been having where you know each
each decision is very very challenging
then we have linear and uh what's what
was the over and under on lanier did he
achieve it uh alejandro
well actually he's played pretty quickly
in the next last couple of moves but
they were a bit on the forcing character
let's take a look because he did find
the move bishop g5
maxine replied with the move knight c5
and i remember it mexico doesn't have a
lot of time himself he burned time in
the opening and he's left with 21
minutes by this point after knight c5
you could go back but who does that you
take on c5 of course can't really take
with the b-pawn and expose the king this
way so you take with the d-pawn and
quickly actually in the air play the
move rook b3 only a couple of minutes
think uh the rook on b3 uncorks the
bishop attacking the pawn on a6 and if
you play the move king a7 you kind of
run a little bit uh into the into the
move queen e2 you could start with the
move bishop c4 as well but queen e2 more
or less prompts you to push your pawns
forward you would like to play the move
queen b7 but that unfortunately hangs
the pawn on e5 it's currently undefended
and i can take it for free so
uh you have to play either b5 which is
kind of ugly king on a7 or play c4 which
is equally ugly because after rookie 3
again you have problems with the pawn on
e5 not easy to defend at all and once i
recover my pawn i have the pair of
bishops and this king long term it's not
feeling very safe these pawns have
already advanced too far away from
from the king to give it shelter so
instead maxine plays the move knight d5
gives back a pawn tries to get rid of
the pair of bishops currently that
linear has there's really no alternative
for linear if you don't take on e7 you
have to retreat the bishop and who wants
to do that so you take on e7 you take
with the knight you take with the queen
doesn't make any sense uh you take with
the knight and the idea is that you're
gonna maneuver this knight either to f5
or c6 and start trying to get it to d4
while this rook's on b3y because white
doesn't want to play c3 as long as this
works on b3 it doesn't he doesn't want
to trap this rook on the third rank now
the engines don't like this for maximum
at all they think that after bishop
takes a6 rook cd8 the bishop is more
powerful and now that material is even
the bishop is just going to overpower
the knight now remember that this pawn
on e5 is also a little bit of a weakness
they like simply playing the move rookie
one and you can imagine that white is
better in this position yes the rook on
b3 it's a little awkward you might need
to re-maneuver it at some point but it
can always come back to d3 if need so
and the long term problems with the king
they haven't gone away do you have a lot
of light square issues with the king on
the queen side currently
i'm going to have to check myself
because
i i'm really confused alejandro in the
current position after knight d5 i'm the
pawn grubber in the family over here but
for some reason my eye is attracted to
the move bishop c4 bishop takes g5
bishop takes d5 and i'd like to play
bishops of opposite color position am i
i'm going nuts i'm not so sure that
that's a bad idea the end just violated
a sequel but i don't really know what
you're gaining if i play rook cd8
not the move bishop c4 because i'm
saying the bishop g5 is the engine's
choice right but if you see bishop c4
and you see that your opponent can play
rook cd8 i'm not so sure that you're in
love with the idea of bishop c4 because
the engines still want to take on e7 but
basically you give up a free tempo well
i the difference was taking on f7 versus
taking on a6 i'd rather take on a6
frankly and then why did i play bishop
c4 right good point and the opposite
call of bishop position i think is not
that horrible for black there because i
get to play king a7 i get to
uh sort of stabilize on the green side
i'm not getting mated in fact your
attack is going to
uh be uh
postponed for a while you get to support
your bishop on d5 by c2c4
yeah we don't have to talk on on an
empty board but then if you play c4
attacking the pawn on a6 becomes much
harder because there's no longer any of
those queen e2 motifs which we were
exposing earlier right and black
eventually maybe pushes a five pushes e4
even immediately why not yeah just f5 e4
put the bishop on the long diagonal
ourselves and like bishop d5 versus
bishop d4 yeah i understand why white is
not worse white is obviously never worse
here but
i think we're minimizing our advantage
here a little bit and the a6 is such a
such a tasty tasty little morsel there
no i agree with what you're saying peter
will be it'll be hard to resist taking
that part in a second it's the only
defender of the light squares currently
exactly outside of the board no i love
that too um again across our whole
spectrum of games uh we are seeing
challenges and very much so in the ali
riza game versus fabi
when we left it we left it at these
parts we expected f7 f5 a move that
hadn't crossed my mind but once you see
it it makes perfect sense
h3 yeah there's a very concrete very
interesting idea here by loresa saying
that if the xc4 is the only threat yeah
if i stop it physically by by pinning it
to the most important
uh light square or like the light piece
on on the board
i'm stopping your counter play fabric
calmly replies with bishop f6
and now we have a kind of a weird
equilibrium where
black is not really threatening fxc4
black is
actually in some positions shockingly
for me knight takes d5 is something you
can play really while the pn is still on
on the g file you can in some positions
play 95 and then if you take the e pawn
i have b7 b5 and this is one of the
pluses of the move bishop f6 because wow
we're pinning the b to pawn to the rook
on a1 meaning that let's say we play a3
here just okay
let's do it yeah a3 we can take on d5
and if you take with the e1 i can play
b7 b5 here and even if you unpin
yourself over the over the default let's
say you play yeah this will be this is
the the desirable b2b3 and so let's say
let's say you're playing c2 here after
b5 okay picking up a tempo against the
bishop and we still play bishop f7
and shockingly bishop f yeah and
shockingly this position like the center
will still crumble bishop five b takes
c4 we still get to pick up both the c4
pawn and probably the g5 pawn as well
with a very playable position this uh i
am
you know disclaimer i i did disclaimer
i did inquire a little bit okay okay uh
this is not me being smart it's me being
able to clever yeah yeah um a2 you know
a2 a3 the knights bothersome but on the
other hand you know i just want to solve
the king huh yeah that's the point if i
go king e2 i'm always allowing the
knight to jump here if i go king d1 i'm
still in the pin and bishop bishop d2 is
still a little bit problematic so i need
to unwind uh the position alejandra for
ali reza should he start with rook e1
how does he
get over this kind of conundrum he's
facing
well he's gonna have to do so in a very
concrete manner because the engines
don't find an easy way for him to play
everything has a problem so he's just
going to have to choose which direction
he was to face kingitu is actually one
of the top moves in the position
allowing knight c2 rook b1 knight d4
check and just the engines don't care
they just say king f1 i'm up upon i
still preserve this pin yes the knight
is defending the bishop but do you
really want to take the pawn this way
allow me to play bishop e3 get my king
to g2 and you can see how strategically
this can be dangerous the knight on d5
is very well placed e4 is a long-term
weakness and only a few moves away from
playing king g2 and putting my rook in
the center after which you have to favor
white actually the engines already favor
white in this position but there's
you're not forced to give this check and
after rook b1 the knight is actually
pretty annoying you can play something
like bishop f7 which is a very
surprising move in my opinion wow
rerouting with the idea of bishop h5
check forcing you to go king f1 and in
those positions continue with bishop h5
bishop d4 yes you can take on f5 in this
position but let's for example take with
the bishop in this case i have check
knight takes f5 and i take on d5 i again
get both of my pawns back if you take
with the e pawn
then this crumbles knight d4 check as
well here and if you go back to f1 which
you really don't want to do this you now
take with the rook
on
bishop takes d5 and the coordination of
white's pieces is simply non-existent
bishop b4 is a big problem bishop takes
h1 of course the current threat so not
easy for ali reza to get out of this
bind king 2 is a very non-human move the
engines also want to play the move rook
d1 and i think maybe he'll go for this
because it just transfers the rook over
to the center and allows him to start
thinking about running the king to the
king side so for example something like
pawn take well you cannot start you
cannot take them in this particular
position something like bishop d4 is
what i meant to say uh now allows a3 to
be played and the rook and d on d1 is
going to be preferable in those
variations that you guys were looking at
the bishop on d4 is not going to be as
stable so rook d1 i think is a good
version of a lot of these moves the idea
is just that the rook is slightly active
that the king when it does land on the
king side doesn't trap the rook on the
h1 square so perhaps this is what
alireza is looking at
very very nice rook t won king e2 and
the immediate king e2
uh again challenges everywhere uh peter
and
more so even in the magnus carlsen game
as magnus i mean there's actually one
upon well
one is a i mean he was he
yannick here sacrificed the pawn to get
rid of the bishop player
they got to this position perhaps we
could show how uh the whole 94 bishop
one uh uh
sequence did happen in the game night a4
was played quite quickly followed by
more or less an immediate bishop one
allowing v3 before as i say is
completely unthinkable hans niemann game
you know but better because things are
not locked down in the center on the
king's side okay so jan very
understandably goes c5 here all the
trades happen bishop d rook he8
just a second
my my system seems to be loading ever so
slowly bishop d2 yes sorry rook h8 and
now magnus played before bishop b6b5 a
very concrete idea
obviously if you take on b5
bishop xb5 will drive away the rook from
e8 there's also bishop before check
ideas you have to kind of consider they
don't win the game but it's all
extremely awkward and the bishop player
does start looking progressively more
and more dangerous so jan after some
thought goes a6 a5 here saying uh i will
i would rather be upon down here
but not have to face the bishop bear
and perhaps yeah i think c5 probably
will be met by b6 check is my
is my guess
my mother became a very nice nesting
uh spot on but for now after king of
tsuyan doesn't even play king c5 even
though i'm pretty i'm pretty sure yeah
if not for the existence of b6 check
i think you very very much like the idea
of placing that king on b6 where it's
entirely safe from the entirety of right
yeah i should be using some other words
as well uh
from of of white's entirety of white's
army nobody can bother the the king
number the truth rookie seven is a
choice for now uh perhaps hinting at
doubling uh on the file for the time
being perhaps hoping to
uh don't we have a feeling that
magnus achieved yeah something this is
this is a very something outcome what do
you guys think the evaluation of this
position is oh better white better white
how much
i shouldn't have looked i'm gonna say
one
three and a half what
three and a half no way
three and a half yes it just makes like
absolutely dead in this position i would
have said whatever yeah uh
clear the cobwebs why is black dead now
you could play roxy one or rook d1 and i
think i saw magnus reach for his rook
but the engines actually want to play
the move b6 immediately and they think
that there's just nothing black can do
in this position you want to play the
move knight d7 and capture that pawn
sure but it runs into
e4 and yeah i'm just opening up things
against your king you're not going to
survive this one rook on a5 is doing
great jobs great job taking on d5 taking
away the spaces for the pieces for
example knight takes b6 is of course
unplayable because i just kick out your
knight
you can't defend it right anything on
the c file that gets met with rook c1
check d5 is going to be hanging with
chuck this is dead uh magnus does not
play the move b6 instead plays a very
logical move which i also was mentioning
the move rook d1 and it's not plus three
and a half it's only plus two but that
means you have the pawn and the
initiative you have this isolate you
still have to worry about this bishop
can maneuver and attack it g5 always has
to be in nepal's mind and the idea of
playing b6 rook c1 rook c7 at some point
can also come into consideration where
is the compensation
everything that i mentioned is advantage
white positionally and remember he's a
pawn it's an ugly pawn because it's
doubled but it's a pawn
wow and here i thought i was going out
on the limb by going 1.0 i didn't give
the double pawn
that much value but i must confess
that the move e3 e4
suddenly this rook on a5 is doing this
fabulous job which means
knight d7 is essentially unplayable b6
would have really put uh
the onus on black but now having said
that and everything that alejandro just
said rook d1 looks really good
i mean
like i mean it's like beast he's coming
next you know your position is bad when
like the dream scenario for black hair
as i see it
is
something like and i understand the line
is nowhere near force sure 97 yeah
e4 yeah knight b6 yeah it takes d5 no
you can't now we don't take it back to
f6 and now we don't touch anything right
right we're two points down but we have
a very very solid blockade the knight on
b6 cannot really be touched the king
only six cannot be touched we go rook c8
rook c5
yeah yeah and we can pass right and two
pawns down yeah and but i think we don't
get this
it's not the fortress because you're
afraid of yeah i think we don't get this
after 97 i'm i get the feeling uh even
e4 is nowhere near force you can
like even maybe 97 b6 might still be
very strong actually right b6 because 96
rook b5 remains
right probably winning because knight
goes somewhere i can even take on
i can even take on d5 and then give a
discover check with the bishop and
chosen maybe sensing the fact that his
position's not that
dear let's say he uh nepo after the move
rook d1 rook h8 says uh hey dude yeah
but i think
i get the feeling this loses by force to
like d4d5 here sorry g4g5 like icons g4
g5 g597 doesn't change
actually
best move yeah you know you have to
create some counter play yeah yeah
clearly and very understandably the best
choice yeah you you like the same
combination of moves no but i want to
like i can think you can play bishop c4
here maybe
or bishop e4 and if you go knight b6 i
want to take on d5 and then play on b6
or e4 and then b6 i understand you
completely sir
that's very you are very sensitive you
are struggling to survive the next five
moves here with black but if you do
maybe your position improved because
maybe you can pick up the pawn on h4 and
then not get mated
and then perhaps the the rook endings
might start looking saveable
maybe i'm i'm you know i feel like we're
no we're in in very bad territory here
exactly uh by the way i mean we've just
watched an entire world championship
match between these two players but i
saw
jan fiddling with the pawn
is that a tell of nervousness or is that
just comic um
does he like i i've also covered the
world championship but we did not have
the picture so i i can't i can't really
say but i don't i think that's fine i
think that's uh that's not really a sign
of anything that's just
[Music]
perhaps the the most famous twirler in
current world chess is boris of course
and for him i think he just twirls
because
that's what he's used to doing yeah
all right and then after magnus we will
continue
all the way down to hans versus lavon
now
hans has been got this positional grip
but the four rooks as you prescribed
have been traded and
slowly slowly slowly a lot of pressure
is being relieved
of course white's for choice it's still
extremely annoying though right because
it's four h5 yeah that plays itself yeah
this this this is about to happen and
then yeah you you just want to you put
your king on g8 you're queen on e7 and
you try to you roll with the punches
yeah you
your choices will be extremely limited
for the rest of the of the game i think
g8 specifically is aimed
at
having the option of immediately
threatening a nitrate if the knight
comes to c5 so we need h7 to be
protected like if you play knight c5
right i can immediately play knight d6
or 97 i don't know which one is strong
yeah i'm just trying to make a passing
move you're saying that the h7 pawn
needed for defending in order to
challenge the name feels to me that it's
very useful for black to be able to
immediately say i'm i would like to
continue trading pieces here sir
absolutely if we don't lose the bishop
to xg6 but i don't think we do i think
there's too little material left on the
board for any kind of peace sacrifices
exactly i don't actually win much yeah i
go 97 my position still looks horrible
but i am now up a piece
you've got something to look forward to
at least at least we have something
going on exactly we're thinking h4
yeah queen e7 queen e7 is a a very
useful pass but aren't we alone of
course
that's not gets in yeah i don't know i
don't know levers despite and once again
this is the the maximum black could have
hoped for at around move 20. all four
rooks gone no real concessions offered
apart from the ones apart from the ones
that were offered much earlier yeah uh
so yeah and now we continue passing h5 i
don't know like how are we supposed to
react to this
uh
we're struggling trying to hold on to
lev levon's position and neither of us
really want to champion his cause only
an engine would be very
yeah but also just look at this life is
just so unfair right you know magnus's
position looks like black has some
counter play white has some weaknesses
blah blah plus three plus three this is
this is like no counter play every
single white piece better than the black
counterpart barely plus one
why why why it's not so easy right you
guys played h4
yes we did but h4 has an issue h4 queen
e6 ah and then queen h3
okay
that is
and i think that's why hans starts with
the move bishop f1 hmm
i wonder if there are some positions in
which we can actually offer that like
wouldn't that be something if this
position is only eventually won
by offering a trade of a bishop of one
of the worst defending bishop of all
time for that idiot on c8 right it's
just
probably not but bad bishops
protect good pawns yes there you have it
only 1.0 alejandro 1.0 that's it it's an
advantage for white but it doesn't think
that there's a way to penetrate just yet
black has a bunch of options they're all
retained just about the same evaluation
queen c7 is one i don't understand that
move it's just a move bishop f5 at least
gets the bishop out but unfortunately
after knight c5 you're gonna have to
find somebody to defend that since this
idiot on c8 as you mentioned might be
traded you might want to do it with the
queen play queen c7 immediately and i
think that's why the engine wants to
play queen c7 to start off with still an
unpleasant position here for levon we
let him stew there's a big time
difference though levon with almost 40
minute advantage
hans only has eight minutes that being
said they are already on move 33. let's
go back to this craziness of ali reza
and fabiano corona because he did play
uh
the move king e2 yes we have this
position on the board the king on e2
extremely vulnerable and favi says you
know what rook f8 your king is under
attack how are you going to defend it he
didn't even bother with playing the move
knight c2 another top engine move uh you
could imagine a human just takes on f6
hey get rid of the bishop but this
knight on d5 is too important it's
blocking the rook it's blocking the
bishop you cannot really give up this
knight despite the fact that you get rid
of this bishop and you double the
structure there's problems with the
taking on taking on c4 is too difficult
knight c2 d4 is stronger now that the
rook is open so the engines actually
want to play the move bishop e3 just
cover up the e-file yes it costs a pawn
on b2 but at least you get your pieces
out you get bishop takes b2 rook c1
bishop e5 and here you can claim that a3
rook takes b7 continues the game and
continues uh trying to be up upon so a
lot of tactics for both it happened just
as you prescribed bishop three bishop b2
rook b1 bishop e5 on the board bishop e5
on the board excellent so yeah i would
expect a3 in this position remember the
players don't have a lot of time if we
can get a shot of them and their clock
this is not the situation that hans
demon is in where he has 33 moves
already played in a very quiet position
where the worst that can happen to him
is that he destroys his advantage and
they make a draw no everything can still
go wrong for both of these players here
very very quickly and we're talking
about 23 minutes against 13. now the
pressure actually went all the way i
know no we will oh
no the picture is lagging a little bit
they have played all of those moves but
okay uh wait what
because my board is updated
there there appears to be a little bit
of lag currently which will no i
apologize that
my board
didn't make the moves it was like news
going around guys some things yeah yeah
yeah yeah
the live shot of the play we've got
we've got a bug in the system over here
i apologize because
what
linear linear linear
oh oh sorry uh uh
farouja
we're jumping why are we jumping whoa
he took the f7 pawn not
oh he took the a6 pawn and the f7 yeah
okay okay now we're talking this so this
is a this is an exchange like it's not
actually a bishop sacrifice it's an
exchange sacrifice i think queen f7
rogue b6 is completely lost
you just get mated but you can play 94.
and exactly because queen takes e5 as
you say you just get yeah but you can
play 94 which i'm sure he intends to
reply with bishop takes g6 knight b3 he
takes before b3 put the bishop on d4 and
he's still going to be quite safe but i
think he maybe is selling this short a
little bit because black will have a
very nice hold over the reopen d file we
do have knight d4 95 it's just been
played in bishop takes you six blitzed
out by lanier and again so we're picking
up two pawns
and a very powerful bishop like you
could anchor for example let's just put
some moves on the board not necessarily
the hd yeah yeah we get it here
and i suppose we tuck our king and again
we don't know exactly why
but uh two pawns great bishop
safe kings
light squares everything i was taught
is the white is better yeah of course of
course why the engine says zero zero
zero it's not zero zero it's like zero
three but it's still so much less than i
would have expected right i would have
been on the highest but i think that i
think the control over the one open file
on the board is just one it's also it's
also the quick counter play the engines
want to go rook d4 rook v8 and
immediately jump to d2 and start
generating threats against the king
because if they i got the queen to the
uh a rank somehow
you might actually be in problems like
b5 queen a5 if i ever get that in
yeah queen this is actually a
counterpart yeah q64 here is uh
maybe interesting
if you have to play something like queen
g5 for queen d4 rugby one maybe you're
still completely fine but yeah c5 c4 at
some point will happen rook d1 might
happen at a as an opportune moment this
becomes a mess this becomes a mess and
clear counter play yeah we do have to
wonder because if we go back to the
position of 27
uh instead after knight five uh bishop
c495 you can play something like a3 a4
here for instance yes the knight will
land on d4 probably d4 and not d6 and
then we go i don't know rook g3 rook hd
one c2 c3
so i think absolutely better bishop
versus a better minor piece every single
end game better for us still but we are
not obliged to go into end games we
could still shift towards attacking the
black king side of queenside sorry if
black sleeps up
right but linear after some thought
clearly shows he decided that the
position he is playing right now is more
because i'm sure he realizes that he is
better pretty much no matter what he
chooses right
interesting decision i
probably wouldn't have given up the
material myself i like playing those
bishops versus knights positions
especially with a4 and rook d3 as you
prescribed and it just feels like white
should be the one you know whereas here
very interesting choice and uh you know
something
maybe i just did it wrong
let me let me try to
do
a little bit better move order windy six
i guess maybe oh that's actually picking
up a tempo oh my well not really i mean
we're we're sort of equalizing the tempe
here i will i will most likely still
have to play rook hd8 i don't really
envisage a situation which rook hd8 is
not going to be a good map right now i
was putting the bishop on e4
you know instantly instantly
do i want to keep the the the action on
the e-file open
i don't know
yeah there's some argument for that for
sure
i'm also you know from black's
perspective i'm at some positions i'm
looking at h5 so h4 uh h3 to fix the
pawn on
h2 and then perhaps play against it but
this also gives white additional tempe
to start pushing the g pop like g4 d2 g5
g6
it will become a source of great
annoyance for black as well yeah very
very uh interesting double age position
double edged but sorry uh
it wasn't like the breaking news where
your game was over let's jump back to
the farouza game versus bobby for a
moment after the move bishop e3 there
was no bishop takes place we had some
kind of a glitch in the market in the
matrix apparently right right yes
exactly well but i mean
and we had knight knight c2 instead
uh the knight captured on e3 and
thinking yeah because i think he has a
very legitimate uh choice here between
uh jack oh give me three things actually
yeah you can take only three with both
the knight and the pawn i think both of
those make sense
uh and there is also the inclusion of
knight takes f6 if you wanted
um
my first thought
i want it knight takes f6 what about you
peter
i was very drawn to after xc3 but okay
i'm i'm sort of bugged by the bishop xd5
reply
bishop takes david yeah this is this is
what i dislike yeah this is but maybe c
takes d5 here is strong
my point is if you take with the e pawn
i have bishop d4
yes and
i get it and i get a lot of counter play
because my pieces become quite active i
think even though the pixel 5 even here
is quite unclear even bishop takes b2
and bishop uh d4 but you're
you're
you're going down uh but cd5 is very
interesting because i a different tree
yeah yeah rookie four which takes a five
is annoying and the c5 pawn is also
hanging now in every single position so
i think this one handles rook c1
okay so i guess maybe after if it's
ftacc you have to uh you know greet your
teeth and actually go after xc4
which g6 rookie 6 and i go i don't know
b3 here and this is the position i
wanted with white because we have a
clearly
dominant dominant light piece but maybe
it's difficult to make progress maybe
this is the issue i am surprised by you
you're a grunfell player you you worship
your dark squared bishop and here you're
kind of uh giving the knight the edge
well uh for concrete reason
now this is this is what you're trying
to avoid to
to not have your
beautiful dark square bishop be unhappy
for the rest of the game because it's
attacking nothing the long diagonal is
empty right you know very inconveniently
for us has removed everything from the
long diagonals would this rook okay it
kind of patrols maybe on a good five
maybe five minutes you could get in
and uh
i'm eagerly awaiting the
the inclusion of alejandro in the
conversation
like
he tells us
look this is what's happening no the
engine absolutely hates knight takes f6
okay thinks after xe3 is definitely the
best way to continue in this position um
and after bishop takes d5 because this
it really does not like for black for
black no it thinks that after f3 it's
plus one rook cd one is coming so many
end games in which you might lose the e4
kind of for free so you don't really
want to do this uh instead it likes
bishop takes d5 as the main option after
f takes e3 bishop 65 you're correct
about c takes d5 if you take the e pawn
you include this this bishop b4 and
white is still a little bit better
according to the engine after bishop
takes f5 because this past pawn but it's
not a big deal um
and already on the board by the way f
takes e3 f takes e4 but the engines were
finding some very strange moves because
perhaps what five we saw was bishop to
hd5c takes if i didn't like his position
g6 is jesus it's so cute it's the
engine's
move and it's so easy to miss g6
defending the pawn that you could have
taken on e4 the point is that if you
take with the pawn then after rook takes
d5 or bishop d4 you get so much counter
play right things are starting to happen
against the king and what the engines
think is that after g6 actually the best
move is ship g2 just to make sure that a
rook doesn't land on the e4 square
that's very cool but favi does not find
that instead plays the move f takes e4
and the engine is giving alireza this
one point advantage because of this
beautiful knight on d5 by no means dead
you do have as you mentioned rook a6
counter play b5 might be a possibility
at some point but the knight is dominant
and now the king only two is very safe
i that that move g6 and bishop g2 that
is just so so
beautiful it's also so easy to miss yeah
oh my goodness uh i want to pick up uh
because we might be going into some
decisive territory in the game between
magnus and yan when we left it we had
seen the move rook h8 uh v7 and here
magnus says yeah don't really want to
calculate if i can decide not to
calculate let's just protect the one
weakness we have exactly yeah also maybe
implying i'm ready to double on the d
file and go after unplayed knight c5
king c7 and now after bishop b1 seems
like things are kind of falling apart
because rook gt4 or bishop a2 or rogue
gd4 followed by bishop a2 it seems like
the pawn on d5 is also falling now very
very quickly yeah shout out to sassy the
super computer that follows all of
magnus carlsen's games gives a definite
answer on what is going on says it gives
plus seven
plus seven yeah yes those are but yeah
but that's a norwegian super computer
and it's biased yeah well the unbiased
leeches has plus four and a half so
reality yeah reality has a magnus bias
yes
help me out here guys come on you cannot
give this position to me and say it's
plus seven because that's a rook yes
that is i mean that's that's a
tremendous depth but right if i tell you
the d5 pawn is going to get picked up
without even changing the structure you
can't even force me to take on d5 with
the e3 paw like you can't play g4
enforcement against the fortress you
mentioned yeah i'm taking on d5 and
keeping my beautiful structure your
opponent f7 is remains weak
plus seven damn
it's early but uh i think i like my pick
already yeah nobody's talking
on the tournament where he has one extra
white this was not the most difficult
project
no but i mean the guy's chasing 2 900
get out of here you're playing this game
on easy mode though like it's uh you
know we give we give you maurice
and your point is
jan
is looking off like
no he knows that the rails where do you
know off the rails yeah he knows
because he's just fallen into
i think king c7 may have been like i'm
not really going to suggest this is a
good position but you probably have to
greet your teeth and maybe take on d3
but it's just lost by this point the
engines are saying it's just lost i mean
you have to take on d3 after rook g4 but
the resulting end game is hopeless you
just pile up on the d-pawn bring your
king to f4 play e4 trade the rooks
i can understand how long term this is
never ever holdable but
yeah keeping that bishop you know we
should be one bishop i think once you
realize bishop b1a2 exists
you you just know you can't play king c7
so yeah if you like if you if you want
to actually continue fighting you have
to get the bishop off the board because
once the g5 pawn falls the game is over
and it's just going to fall yeah
especially with the bishop so nicely
anchored after e3 e4 oh my goodness uh
magnus
well being magnus and
looking uh superb by the way i mean just
where
where did his opponent go wrong
okay this is very confusing to me okay
where's the reservoir
traded alireza actually traded that
night away
that beautiful what
why
i do not know
why
does he have some ideas that he's going
to round up the e4 plan no i'll
i mean i am so confused by this i was
thinking that he's got ideas
yeah i guess it's a long long long long
term idea of bringing the king to f4 but
no he's
played rook t1 he's he's jumped into a a
rook ending does he think the spawn
ending is winning somehow
very certainly drawn that king has no
way in yeah like
i think this is where we headed because
like you you i mean if he thinks this is
winning i mean uh that's why he would
play this uh
otherwise it doesn't but i mean if if if
one of the two kings actually has a way
in it's the black king so you have to
you have to keep yours on the king's
side because if you're locking g4 you're
not going to be a very happy bunnies so
well i'll play h3 and if you play h3 and
i don't actually have a way to break
okay so okay so let's find out give me
an
g7 yeah i think if you go in that
direction you probably lose yeah okay so
let's let's just uh tempo g5
you'll have to play h3 right
uh yeah otherwise you're going after the
e3 pawn and i'm not happy about that so
you go h3 i go f5
i go king a4 i go h5 king b5 h4 it's a
queen just over right it's a queen
it's just a queen gh king h4 king c5f4
it's a queen exactly
yeah yeah no the the yeah i mean if
anybody is faster here it's not it's not
white
okay
that that really puts the kibasha and uh
yeah and that thought if he wanted to
continue playing he would have gone to
hf1 rook d6 rook c2 and then perhaps
rook f4 and played something like this
but once you go once you go to kg1 after
rook d6
you're kind of committed to this end
game because if you take take yeah and
you don't offer the trace there will be
constant rook b6 or
count to play which will always be
faster than whatever that is that that
we're doing over here yeah yeah
so uh i think maybe he was so short on
time and so unconvinced by his advantage
that he just decided okay let's uh you
know let's make things
uh let's look clarify i don't know
rookie six played in the meantime by
here by by fabi but yeah that's not a
surprise
i'm so
so uh surprised i'm surprised by knight
the xf6 move 22. absolutely absolutely
it's just like i i can't figure out why
he wouldn't think he was better
yeah i don't know but it's just kind of
logical to keep the night now yeah i
mean it's just such an obviously better
knight than than the bishop on f6 you
you take you play b3 you go rook hf1
rook cd1 and you start asking all of
those niggly niggly little questions
exactly h4 g4 somewhere like
yeah it's just uh
and you press and you just press
uh very very surprising i just want to
take a look at uh
the hans niemann the vaughn aronian
position because
the knight did not make its uh
road to c5 it was on c5 for a second oh
it was yeah it was yeah
yeah he's uh
yeah
i think what he's doing here is reaching
40.
yeah
without without committing to do
anything which i think is you know
prescribed in books and and so
yeah russian books actually
many many of them russians
many of them were many of them russian
books absolutely were you taught that
by your trainers that when you were in
the driver's seat you should repeat once
so that you tell your partner that i
never really took that particular bit of
teaching never really felt to me like it
was you know sensible enough but the
idea of not hiring in positions with
advantage that is very deeply ingrained
like
you know that that famous quote which i
think is uh ascribed to to mark graytsky
the late great
much lamented mark varensky of this idea
that you you should not be in haste to
try to convert you know you
you still have time to strengthen your
position further to explore some options
right in particular if we talk about the
position like the one hans has right now
where
you know whatever he does the structure
will not change the material balance
will only change if he wants it right
you know he's in full control over built
the position for a long long long long
time
and okay we'll leave that there uh
magnus we think he's in the tri ali riza
we don't understand anything
lanier
yeah uh and they'll just give up on the
pawn on h5 just for tempe and
immediately yours if you want it yeah
absolutely i wonder if bishop takes h5
will be met by rooney two or maybe even
e5 e4
to give you so give yourself more
squares to try to get h5 queen h7 oh
sorry yeah i'm blundering i'm blurring
in one move okay yeah
that's relevant
very relevant good morning saint louis
yes
nice uh
okay uh
having said that something to be said
for king a2 just getting ready to maybe
defend
uh you mentioned e5 e4 i can just
imagine a queen no but then i put the
bishop 24 i'm i'm pretty much never
taking on h5 here i think
you know the bishop will be needed in
divin and then i go rugby one yeah and
then
it takes h2 dude yeah queen h6 and then
i start
saying i also have some mating threats
eventually
that's not fair you're supposed to be a
punching bag no oh man
but i mean king c7 and then
but that's not what i uh
well i could have got no queen g7 is a
different uh bag of worms i was going to
uh stop queen h6 for a moment yeah make
sense makes sense
to here
absolutely exactly for check i guess i'm
still trying to land uh a big blow yeah
king a7
yes yes yes yes yes bishop c6 which does
create something bishop c6 oh oh
whatever we do
yeah you have rook d4 in response i
don't know this is very tricky too okay
we're on shaky ground over here uh
with the
lanier mbl game if you were to go triple
o's that wouldn't be completely
surprising to me alejandro what do we
got as an engine assessment of this
position get ready to be completely
surprised yes okay zero zero zero uh but
specifically because of the move c4 in
this position that is which we didn't
look at
but this is kind of the key if you play
some of the other variations like rook
d2 allowing the queen in then you're
gonna be in a lot of trouble you can
start with queen a6 or queen b5 don't
want to be doing that so c4 cuts the
queen from the queen side so you may be
wondering what's the point what if i
take on c4 and the engines just think
that if you trade queens and you solve
the problem of the king even though this
is a dominant bishop and you might be
able to get a long-term pass pawn on the
king side it's still a rook and it's
gonna be easy for it to catch it on some
kind of dark square especially because
you're going to have rook d2 coming if
the rooks ever get traded off then it's
a three result game so c4 apparently is
an important move in this position if
you just stop start waiting when some
play something like this and then allow
rook c1 then you are going to be
suffering for quite some time the move
c4 is basically
key in this position and of course the
point is that if you go uh rook c1
immediately now i can play rook d2
remember that h2 is hanging and you
don't really want to trade the queens
but at this point you don't have that
much of a choice you go queen e3 i'll
insist with the move queen c5 and again
the danger of allowing double
rooks on the seventh is gonna outweigh
whatever pawns i shed on the queen side
wow yeah this is quite quite interesting
because of c4 yeah that was amazing
specifically this idea that pretty much
every single end game there is fine for
black it's not obvious
it's not obvious like you imagine this
bish 24 supporting a passer somewhere
around the g6 square you think how you
think yourself how is this ever okay
right but yeah
i can i can definitely buy the idea that
it's better than anything else
but i'm still surprised that just how
much the engine thinks this is not a
problem for black i would be i would be
quite worried in the meantime i think we
have a game heading towards a draw in
wesley against
i thought
i thought it was very cute and i wanted
to point this one out for you peter uh
when we left the game you know we were
very very focused on queen e2 and rook
f1 because we didn't want to lose the f2
pawn
move that we didn't really look it was
queen e7 returning the favor before we
even
i did think about it but i thought we
can we can reply with c5 i wonder why
wesley thought cc7 c5 here is unplayable
i couldn't really work it out for myself
queen e5 i'm not that worried about
i don't think maybe it was actually that
maybe it's queen e5 cd4 queen five
exactly yeah i kind of thought i will
find a good root move there but maybe
there is none there's a good night move
though
ah yeah 96 is 96 is strong here
uh which one which moment
and now
96. and then i guess d takes e3 if the
queen goes to e5 or f6 that's correct
yeah and then we have a lot of count to
play with queen e2 and then ef2 and so
on right it seems like
yeah jan decides not to not to resign
just yet goes bishop to f6 but
yeah we know and he knows
how this movie is going to end what this
is and how it ends yeah yeah
understandable decision for him to
continue playing he
you know
doesn't really want uh to to give magnus
the the satisfaction of winning well i
mean it's going to be a miniature it's
move 37 or something unappreciated
win for for sure what's what's going on
peter prior to their world championship
match
four four to two i believe
or maybe more in favor of jan and uh
the riddle of the world championship
match uh was finally sold by magnus and
now he has having a very smooth
victory here that's right the the
dynamic
changes and uh the the personal the
personal score
starts reflecting this this new
uh new kind of uh relationship they have
since since dubai where you know and
once again like it's it's a kind of
weird thing right because the scoreline
says
it was perhaps the biggest blowout in
world
matches since i don't know
if short right uh
but you know the first five and three
quarters
i think you know if you were in the
boxing match yeah you'd give you'd give
you an advantage on points right right
he was consistently early yeah he was
consistently better with white perhaps
not much better but consistently he got
something in those in those rule of
dispositions he was for a very brief
moment much better in game two with the
black pieces yes and he was at one point
close to winning in game six the
marathon yeah so you know
there's also this uh this storyline
which i don't think entirely ignoring it
is fair
but
you know the final count is plus four by
by game 11 and like the second half of
the match where it was just just a
massacre and uh
yeah clearly
now magnus feels a lot more comfortable
playing one of one of the reasons i just
want to
this victory or
impending victory is that
during the candidates
nepa was so untouchable i mean
right uh alejandro i mean nepa was going
every day getting his draws with black
unless
the players wanted to commit suicide
against them which uh farouza and richie
repor both did
and he was well untouchable and suddenly
vulnerable here but yeah this is this is
why magnus is magnus yeah this is i
mentioned this earlier when we got the
type of position right it was a slow
maneuvering game and when it came down
to that nepal looked really bad compared
to magnus all of magnus's moves were
more or less logical and the moment he
played bishop v8 right the moment let's
go back to the south
uh that's the wrong game may be hard to
find right uh let's go back to this
position right because the engine had
been saying equal equal equal equal up
to this point
and it said maybe white's a little bit
better but not very much and magnus's
moves are slow he went like bishop g3 f2
put the bishop on d3 he wasn't really
creating anything just yet and yet
nepo goes wrong all on his own bishop
beat immediately strategical error
knight a4 comes in he has to retreat
again or uh
bishop e1 and now you're preparing b4 c5
and knight c5 and it looks like magnus
just makes it look easy right now
suddenly you have to play c5 because of
dynamics of the position and your
isolating pawn is bad your king on e7 is
bad b4 b5 comes right on time and to me
it looks like he loses this game like he
lost a lot of games in dubai where
magnus didn't really do anything but at
some point nepal went wrong and
immediately comes to punish exactly yeah
in dubai was maybe slightly more
justifiable because in dubai after he
lost game six yes he could no longer you
know play with entire entirely
objectively because he knew that if he
doesn't win a game for the rest of the
match the match is over right so he was
sort of you know incumbent upon him to
to do something and he kept on trying to
do something
pushing perhaps the envelope a bit
further that it
could allow yeah or could have been
pushed in those positions today that's
really not on the menu at all today he
would have been extremely happy with the
draw but
i think yeah the the the scars
you know he will he will continue
insisting that
you know no scars everything is fine
he remains he remains a very confident
young man and
but i think
you know judging by what we're seeing on
our screens
playing against magnus is no longer as
as comfortable for him as it was prior
to dubai because yeah he did have a very
very good score against him and i mean
deservedly so many of those games were
for when from when they both were much
younger but still it doesn't i mean that
doesn't
mitigate mitigate the fact that he was
at some point i think he was maybe even
four nil up then magnus won one finally
yeah then he won one and uh
and
and then in recent times magnus started
started winning games against against
yeah wow
um yeah but this
this this one looks
really yeah why is two pawns up with an
active bishop in the center of the board
there's really not very much going on
here and
not only that but all more weaknesses
are ready to be things are things like
falling apart
three check yeah and you can play king
into uh king eater i thought kind of
liking it to 95 and then i thought
uh
i don't know you know no i was playing i
actually had this in my
king's three is also completely fine i
don't know why i was insisting on being
so yeah
95 and then anywhere and then of three
four i'd say
um even b6 check is
well okay that may be extravagant but
yeah rookie force rookie four followed
by a four yeah it's just it's terrible
yeah it's terrible just everything is
wrong with this position truly truly
truly uh so that looks uh shaping up to
our
uh
well i was about to say our first result
but uh i'll take that back and
all you raise uh
doesn't look too happy guys and uh i
think with reason
that decision to play knight takes f6 is
very confounding and we do have a draw
by three move repetition yeah and uh he
looks
disturbed that's how he raises
i want to credit uh some of our fellow
commentators who are also covering this
tournament i saw a quote in chat there
yes that apparently uh rustam
kasimshanov who is also covering this
tournament when he saw knight dxf6 he
said i wonder what vladimir kramnik will
have to say about this man
and uh yeah
that's a funny thought there uh for
those for those of you who are aware of
this particular little bit of drama
uh
it would be it would be interesting to
hear uh the
and the the big vlad's thoughts on the
knight on d5 and the key moment that uh
we're talking about is this moment which
move was it uh move 22
and we're very very confused that bishop
takes rook takes b2b3 yes this is bishop
but it's rather
uh doing
little very very and this knight on d5
on the other hand seems to be very
dominant and the desire the
the move knight takes
f6 was just
perplexing to us we we
we thought that perhaps alireza was
ready to go into a king upon ending
which she did yeah which he did but then
you have to you have to play it
conservatively you can't really
if you treat it as a race you will lose
that trick yeah the race is very much in
black's favor and as the game ended uh
it was just like the kings held one
another at bay
not the most comfortable draw for fabi
but he was black
yeah i mean for five it's a perfect like
it's not a bad result for elires either
this is not a tragedy for either of them
it's just that specifically like if
somebody like like myself played knight
xf6 there like i would know what to
attribute it to you know i've uh
uh
i i tend to perhaps underestimate my own
positions i tend to you know take you
know safety based decisions very often
and uh
but alireza is one of the most ambitious
players of
recent generations i would say and for
him to
just voluntarily kind of end the game
there
instead of continuing he must have
really not thought he had anything at
all in that end game with the bishop
against knight which is weird because it
does look very attractive right okay so
one of the most sharp tongued
persons in the chess world uh in his
time was viktor korchnoy he was just
like what an idiot that guy is and how
dare you play like that and
gary kind of took up the mantle a little
bit uh
chess tourists
yeah
was quoting for vladimir putin yeah but
that that sort of is refers to a very
specific story of of vladimir being
vladimir at some point recorded a
two-hour plus video okay on the
candidates which he also covered for uh
uh
for a channel of my good friend lia
levito
and he recorded a long video
dedicated to only i think the first five
or six rounds
of the candidates not even the entire
tournament right uh and the general like
tenor of the video was
we this
is the war this is the worst candidates
ever ever in living history in terms of
quality of play just look at them making
these moves right and the thing is
like
you know
as a grumpy old man
it's it's a bit of a caricature
but
he's also
yeah and and and there you see magnus uh
accepting ian's resignation
but but also it's kramnik so he's not
very wrong about the chest he's not he's
not very often entirely wrong about
chess things right uh so it was a very
it was a very uncomfortable watch for me
because i really dislike the idea of
like harshly criticizing the play of
people
who i very strong chess players and
we're a great
great pressure yeah but we have we have
the first interview of the day so let's
perhaps
ask some of those i want to pursue this
conversation later but over to you
alejandro well we have alireza ferrugia
here with us the first result of the
round with a draw against fabiano carana
alareza welcome to the show just come
from blasting away your opponents at the
saint louis raptor and blitz take us
through some of the key moments of this
game yeah of course
the first game of the classical is not
easy to switch from rapid employees so i
wanted to play
something solid so yeah this queen b3 i
was thinking about it to make things a
bit not less forcing so
so this was uh preparation
and no you just played it over the board
yeah but
i think fight is a bit worse but um
it looks like playable position so right
so take us through some of the
complications here at after the move d5
fabiano offers you a pawn what went
through your mind yeah i was calculating
many things um
maybe i should have castled here but
yeah also taking the pawn looks literal
but this knight before d5 looked nice to
force things
forcing things so
maybe after night before i had better
move than queen d1 actually the engine
thought quindy one was the correct move
the only other better option was to
castle do you consider doing that here
yeah he considered but then yeah giving
up the pawn then it's not so great yeah
absolutely now after the move knight g4
knight bishop takes you found this move
king d2 how did you feel was the
evaluation of this position it's around
it called he felt that he's much worse
for some reason which was weird he told
you this after the game he thought no he
didn't say he's much worse but he said
he was under a lot of pressure but i
think
black is here who is maybe playing for
advantage well the king's on d2 after
all right yes so but he was thinking a
lot he was burning lots of time so
yeah then he played this
i think he played correct kind of he did
the yen just didn't like the move rook
fva precisely because of what happened
in the game and you played this
excellent move after xc3f takes e4 and
here we're all wondering
why did you take the bishop on f6 i am
yeah i felt that this if i keep the
knights versus bishop i don't have more
chances and i miss evaluated that the
rookie game is just raw
so
but i don't think it's much anyway after
takes takes p3 bishop e5
so you considered that both variations
were about equal right yeah i didn't see
big reason that i'm better there because
i have a nice knight but he has also a
nice bishop on e5 a nice bishop yeah
we're definitely going to be hearing
about from vladimir kramnik about this
game well alaresa thanks for joining us
we do have another interview coming up
but good luck in the rest of your games
thank you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us there
uh alireza and i was just wanting to go
back to the candidate's match candidates
tournament in berlin
that uh
that vladimir played and there was this
hilarious moment where vladimir and like
say the first half of the term was
coming on and i was winning i was
winning i'm an idiot
you know like how could i not win this
position
and he was doing this for a number of
rounds he came on with dingleran and
danglorin
uh
and what do you think mr ding loren and
that thing says i agree with vladimir i
was slightly better
they shot him right down
but we have alejandro with world
champion magnus carlson absolutely the
first decisive result of the tournament
a victory for magnus carlson against his
rival magnus welcome to the show tell us
a little bit about this opening how did
you choose it and where did you think it
was going to go yeah i
decided to play something that's pretty
harmless but at least you get some sort
of you know typical position that's
generally
um
equal if like knows what he's doing um
but
i mean i thought it would be a decent
decent try
and then yeah i
feel like uh it was was a massive uh
success uh eventually i eventually got
this
end game which um or queenless middle
game that is uh
that is not not much but it feels like a
massive success already to to get this
tell us a little bit about your thought
process in this position you have the
double pawns on the queen side and
certainly that's going to i feel like
more about what
about what happened later because at
this point i still felt like maybe he
could have played a bit more more
concretely but
yeah i know i i don't know also
i i really don't like the double g pawns
for for him it feels like right here as
long as he cannot get
anything going there soon that could be
a target in the in the future as you saw
in the in the game his pawn structure
became
pretty immobile and also um
and also a bit weak uh towards the end
but yeah i just felt that i have the two
bishops of of course it's unbelievably
solid but it's a position to
to play and i didn't know if it would
particularly suit him either so i i was
pretty happy um i was thinking thinking
quite a bit over the next few months
because there are so many
there are so many possibilities um on
each move there but
um
so many so many plans and it's not clear
if any of them actually did anywhere um
what do you think he went wrong i think
he made a number of uh inaccuracies um
starting where
uh so
uh i didn't like the
first of all i'm not sure i like the a6
from him a6 on move 18 i'm with 18 yes
this particular i think it was okay but
i was wondering like if conceptually if
if a5 was more challenging here just to
keep the bishop on b4 and the queen side
out so this could be a weakness
eventually but i just didn't see how to
to exploit it and otherwise i'm sort of
shuffling and not doing not doing all
that much and uh that's why i also made
this move bishop f2 and move 20. i mean
first of all i thought it was useful
just to anticipate bishop d66 because
rook d8 really indicated this bishop
yeah so um
after bishop d6 also i spent a lot of
time on bishop d3 i just
um it was really hard for him to find a
a move here um rookie eight you could
play but it's not clear if the rook is
is can we start with c5 here
c5 is peter's question in this position
uh g5 g5 just twins yeah well yeah with
the [ __ ] one six we can't at all yeah
yeah okay yeah so i guess not in this
position yes yeah
i don't know maybe he had it in some
other positions but it wasn't it wasn't
obvious yeah according to you what do
you think black should be aiming for in
this position
uh wait and
and try and prevent my plans i don't
think he can do anything active like
right like if i don't play poorly i
don't think he'll be able to play
c5 under decent circumstances so he
should mainly wait and wait and see
which is not always a pleasant
proposition especially not for a dynamic
player like
and the angels were actually considering
to even just hide the king on beat as
their way of waiting for white to do
something did you feel that after yeah
it wasn't obvious that the king was well
placed in e7 yeah at all no so uh bishop
v8 uh the engines thought this was
actually a big mistake i know i really
really really was happy to see that as
well um
uh because i'd seen this knight a4 b1
yes up here knight a4 bishop d6 bishop
e1 trying to get before yeah as soon as
i get b4 that's a huge strategic
achievement then i think we can talk
about something a little bit more
tangible so i
was sure he was going to go for c5
but that leads i think more or less by
force to the position that we got i mean
first of all knight c7 was monumentally
stupid
uh because it gave him the chance to go
bishop c5 and then d4 i mean i assume
it's really bad
where when he fights when he plays c5
knight c5 knight c5 in this position uh
takes and then d4
um
yeah i mean in general it just doesn't
no no no
bishop c5 ah bishop c5 in this position
yeah because i could have gone dc5 and
ryan doesn't have a choice you can go
bishop c5
d
dc5 and then
uh and then d4 but i assume that he has
way too few squares here and that in
general white is much better but it was
he was not very uh very professional
anyway after what he did yes we get this
position
moral no i think we get what happened
more or less about force i mean he could
computer indicates 97 for some reason i
didn't see what he'd do in this position
yeah i didn't see what he'd do and then
in case of bishop c3 yes um
but yeah okay favorite very computer
super ugly that's super ugly
i agree um
yeah anyway i thought this was more or
less forced b5 e5
uh sorry a5 that's one you were
surprised by a5 or they don't expect i
expected that 100 percent high five
times five disposition but this is
is it's i mean nothing is happening at
the moment is but it's really unpleasant
that my my extra pawn is
kind of meaningful because i can
um because they cover a few extra
squares like if you remove the pawn from
b2 then there's no question of me being
being better but
right here they cover they cover some
some squares obviously if i give one of
them away and
and i have um he has a couple of
weaknesses both on f7 and on d5 and my
bishop is a better bit better than his
knight
eventually
i think the game proceeded pretty um
logically there rookie seven yeah that
wasn't that wasn't ideal but uh
it was logical at least and then it
didn't seem like he put up a lot of
persons i mean especially king c7 that
was just resigns on the spot right like
he has to go for this rook ending but
it's it's truly terrible yeah to be fair
the engine was already giving you plus
five here at least the super engine yeah
i mean also knight c5 i think was
conceptually wrong you should have put
it on b6 and it's it's a really horrible
position i'll double the rooks and
on the
d file eventually i put i'll push e4 and
once we trade my bishop will be very
strong and f7 and b7 will both be weak
but at least there was a way to
uh to fight after what he did bishop b5
he could have
resigned with uh with a clear conscience
that's very true magnus it seemed like a
very smooth sailing after you got this
queenless middle game he didn't
wasn't able to maneuver as well as you
did and he kind of fell apart do you
feel like this are a little bit ghost of
what happened in dubai
no i didn't get a lot of these kinds of
games there
so um
i don't know he didn't do so well in the
in the rapid either so probably
i mean this was just a game of somebody
who's not in
not in great shape was not finding
he was not finding the right maneuvers
overlooking
[Music]
um overlooking
some of my ideas also he was playing too
fast i mean
at critical moments
didn't really sense them too much so i
think i did well in creating a situation
that was not pleasant for him but yeah
certainly should have done better well
definitely that's not the shape of a man
that can hold the game against you
especially with the black pieces
congratulations on you're starting with
a win here at the sing field cup and
good luck with the rest of your games
thank you our congratulations as well
magnus a very very fine effort indeed
we're going to take a very short break
and we're going to see on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back with the continued coverage
of round one of sinfield cup and we have
two games concluded and three games
still in progress all of them in end
games only one of them still has queens
on and that is a game between uh hans
neiman and levon iranian which improved
significantly for levon considering
where he was round above move 20.
exactly we left the position off in some
kind of position where we saw the move
knight b6 peter bishop e
finish four finish what was maybe you
know dauntingly one a little bit too
much because the queen the queen on h6
is a nice piece i guess i guess hans
couldn't really figure out uh how to
make progress and one way to make
progress would be to perhaps force the
queen away from the b8 h2 diagonal and
put his own queen on f4 and that would
give him additional squares for the
future but queen h4 here uh it arguably
maybe semi-forces g6 g5 but g65 is not a
stupid move if it forces the white king
to h q to h6 where it has no squares
right and now knight five is a
legitimate threat provoking uh hans to
play uh g3 g4 okay
and levon instantly opens everything up
here with f65 i was also wondering
timing is terrific really good because
it just happens that king is on the
f-file highway exactly yeah and suddenly
uh you know a thing that we uh
officially proclaimed will never happen
in this game
is
actually happening black you know has
counter play has ideas
bishop ii uh played here by hans and
even between h5 instead of king of fate
was playable but king of fate is also an
understandable move
queen h5 eyeballing the pawn on h2 but i
like king after if it was chosen and
hans i think queen g5 is a very good
recognition that allowing queen h5 was
or
[Music]
these counter-threading ideas and by the
way
more and more i'm feeling this knight on
b6 is really yeah it'll get returned to
c5 post haste yeah i think so too it's
just to go back to it's certainly on the
wrong score queen g4 probably just
stopping also the more direct takes in
bishop g4 ideas queen g five on the
board i think we caught up with the
players yeah we can even play knight f6
here creating more threats shockingly
for black but oh dear yeah black is not
going to win no matter what you do here
i mean as long as you like white doesn't
blunt an id4 check there's right very
little here in the way of actual winning
chances but of course this is a
tremendously tremendously dream come
true it's improved for black yeah the
black pieces have squares and
things
let's jump to the game of wesley and
shaq shaq when when when as we were
coming up uh is a pawn up he's enjoying
live maybe
it's
short-lived uh
yeah there was there was one interesting
point earlier there if we go to move 37
i believe 30 yeah 37 for black getting
there getting there yeah so they got to
this position uh it seems a slightly
weird structure but basically there were
light pieces on e5 and e4 and they were
both attacked and taken by pawns right
so f3 was met by f6 and after knight f3
here uh
uh yeah rook takes b4 it takes d5 and
here uh wesley just chose to to give
away this pawn not to try to preserve it
in in any way just very confidently uh
assuming that the strong bishop
and an active rook will
compensate we'll compensate for the
extra point i think he's completely
correct rook c3 but now we just play you
know a move of some description bishop a
a yeah nf6 perhaps to maybe hint at some
h5 h4 things
uh to come as well although h5 pretty
much always gets met by
h2h4 no
look let's just make a move here okay
three okay
h5 h4 g4
and uh the knight does not have that
many great squares we've lost the pawn
on g2 so uh
okay let's put this game to rest uh
stuff um okay sounds like wesley will
hold this
and he of course is absolutely not
obliged to play h5 at any point he can
preserve the pawns on h6 and g5 where
they are very safely protected
i think i think this is just a draw i
don't i don't really foresee any issues
for
fair for wesley despite him being upon
down and let's jump there to our
remaining third game between lanier
and maxine uh
this ending of uh two pawns and a bishop
versus a rook
it has to be a draw this has to be a
draw i think we can play h4 now even
i think with the king on a4 i think we
can reasonably safely page play h4
because if you play g4 i have rook g8 d2
either without the h i don't know i
think both are okay-ish oh sorry that
was that was a mouse slip it was
supposed to get it i think we can go
rook g8 g5 rogue d2
comfortably
um h3 let's say rujituro g3
yeah
and uh
i don't see it like if if you play like
this you might you might regret not
taking a draw earlier with white exactly
about meaning meaning i had time to play
something like this
and vale does it from the other from the
other angle he goes rook g8
right away without even playing uh h4
and yeah uh over here understands that
leaving the age pawn alive would be a
mistake
exactly so he's immediately played
bishop g6 and yeah this just feels like
a very very comfortable draw for black
now okay very good so those are our
remaining games jump in uh
did we blow it uh
absolutely correct especially the
evaluation of that endgame you can see
the rook already landing on d2 and it's
time to pull the parachute you can you
don't want to be messing with the pawns
here on the king side just take on h5
take on h2 you might argue that the
rook's a little bit better because you
will get another pawn uh it's very
difficult to well it's impossible
actually to keep these guys alive but
you're on time to liquidate the position
bishop f7 is a very engine type move i
would like to just put my bishop on e4
and shuffle i think that's just a draw
but you can also do it this way where
you go uh rook h3
and even f4 according to the engine
which i think is a crazy move allowing
yeah but e4 king b3 you bring the king
in you calculate it to a draw the other
way to do it which i think is much more
human play bishop d5 take on g3 and go
bishop e4 bishop d5 for the rest of the
game not really sure what maxim can do
about it this is very much headed
towards a draw you guys were absolutely
correct in your assessment of this end
game the engines don't really give even
an advantage the reason is that after
king f6 rook a3 not don't go h5 here
there's this problem of rook a6 check
and then you have to let go of the g5
pawn but you can just shuffle go bishop
b7 and then back to e4 what does y do
the knight is stuck because of the
problem of g2 right now pushing your h
pawn doesn't help you the rook is tough
defending the pawn on e3 and the king
doesn't have a useful move so
there's not a lot going on in this
position and uh the only one that
remains with some intrigue will be this
one between uh hans neiman and lavone
still a lot to play for because both
kings are a little bit weak this knight
on b6 is controlled by the bishop on e6
on the other hand if it does somehow get
back into the game you can imagine that
and this king on f8 won't be too happy
about it currently the engines think
that white is slightly better because of
the move queen g5 it was already there
he repeated once cringy 596 was already
played once and after knight d6 don't
repeat
but find this craziness
with king e3
only move the idea is just one pin if
you take take somehow the move bishop h5
will be slightly annoying and if you go
check we just run
so very difficult in my opinion to spot
this resource the engines think this is
the only way for an advantage for hunts
uh everything else they're evaluating at
zero zero and queen g5 on the board i
expect knight d6 and i expect the
repetition more than i expect to move
king e3 especially he's also unfortunate
against 50. yes and i'm about to say
that yeah even even for somebody who is
as well versed in in short time controls
as hans i think by this point you
realize most of your advantage is gone
it's still a very very credible very
nice kind of a warm-up game he did not
he did not play for a draw he actually
got a very large advantage out of the
opening he has absolutely nothing to
you know if he takes a draw here nobody
will
criticize his you know lack of willpower
or will to win and this is just not in
not in play here at all
uh and yeah even that position after
king three king two doesn't really look
like white is necessarily all that
winning frankly so why not just uh
we do have two results of the five uh
draw and a very
impressive win by magnus carlson i mean
he just sorry guys i mean i'm just again
and we do have a repetition and we do
expect a second draw in this first round
a very impressive win by magnus and you
know
again i i mean ice spent you know some
really really uh long days broadcasting
uh the candidates where
where nepo
nobody came close it felt like i mean he
just felt like you know he was never
going to lose a game he was playing in a
different tournament to the rest of the
field right he was just absolutely
dominant people people were sort of sort
of throwing themselves at him towards
the later part
but that was because he was leading so
comfortably and people realized that
they need to you know if they don't we
had a personal game against him they
just are not in the running and what we
saw today by magnus first day today
it was difficult here was magnus picking
apart this was slightly bad move this
was a slightly bad move i like my
position when i got the double g pawns i
like my position
yeah it was it was actually a very press
conference
if you if you get magnus to talk about
chess it's always it's always such a joy
to explain you know
the finer details of things but we have
chess is so easy right alejandro when
you win
the sun is shiny when you're 28.7 here
just as pretty yeah
nice nice and we do have a draw once
again that remy that means we have two
remaining games also we expect both of
these i think it's extremely likely that
will remain the the one decisive game
yet by magnus is extremely likely to be
the only decision game of the day yeah
and there's lanier
yeah lanier is considering his moves but
he just played bishop g6 i can't imagine
him not taking yeah i mean he's looking
at the other stuff like he's looking at
the movie could he be
could he be looking at h4 or h4 h4 is a
bit awkward though because like rook g2
you're still going to lose a pawn on the
queen on the king's side there h4 rook
g2 bishop h5 rogue g3 and
you can't play bishop g4 because of e5
let's put that on the board so yeah the
desert
the desirable
uh
instinct to to to save your extra pond
which might still be okay but why should
i think in a more awkward position here
than you are because you should this
might be lost because you're you know
after bishop h5 uh rook takes g3 you
have king b3 e4 is still somehow somehow
a draw i think she looking g2 you're
just on time e4 king c4 yeah but like
nobody does this i agree this is
terrible but it's still just a draw it's
just it's just impossible to play like
this like you why why why would you do
this exactly
exactly okay so we don't expect that
instead we do expect what we
we
uh pointed out earlier yeah just put the
picture only
foreign yeah i was about to say bishop
f7 a very engine move uh we're expecting
uh this the big question for me here is
if i play king b3 here do i lose or not
and apparently the answer is no then
then we're just completely fine now
exactly like
if if i had to shuffle specifically only
with the bishop maybe i could imagine
some positions where where is the
diagonal
or if it's king if kimber iii is
playable you just go for this position
exactly you smile because you you know
you're never losing it right exactly
exactly so king b5 will always be met
with czech and then back here exactly
exactly and i mean if with the king on
c4 how are you ever going to be worse
here if blood goes after the b pawn we
will be able to either win the e5 pawn
or at least trade it for the f3 pawn
exactly
uh so again uh whoa
whoa whoa
alexander told us not to play h5
right
very specifically told us not to play h5
yeah but i mean it's wesley so who are
you going to listen to
[Laughter]
i mean
yeah in this particular position
apparently it's still okay it should end
in a draw anyway um still a draw yeah so
rook a6 check we go to i guess
g7 g7 and taking on g5 is awkward
because there's a g4 there i i suppose
yeah
so we go rogue g4 we take on g5 the no
this this just loses the h2 pawn was
checked like so i give a check on g4
here king e5 and i guess the simplest is
just to take and go g2
and i'm not even like this is not even a
pawn down end game it's a it's an equal
point well my table base just came up
and intruded on our analysis with draw
draw
very very strongly draw yeah okay
so uh
there is no tricks yeah this this round
is going to continue for a little bit
longer but i think we can fully say both
of the remaining games will end in a
draw yeah a very
very gentle safe bet i've got to say i
enjoyed today's round i like the
the the diversity of the the openings i
liked uh the challenges that the players
put themselves in and uh
well i just uh i i loved the magnus's
fantastic technique yeah yeah that was
just everything about it
i felt really really really good but
we're about to have uh one one more
interview yeah
with this song and i like that game too
i liked
how hans was putting the pressure
on the vaughn
essentially throughout and that's not uh
not a lot of people can say that but
for sure they keep the vaughan
glued to a seat a4 i'm going to go back
and look at that one because
let's
yeah
let's do that let's go to alejandro and
ask
uh hans directly about a4 and a6 well
here we have hans demon with us and the
commentators want to know what inspired
you to play a4 and what did you think
about his reply a6
well uh
not a lot of tries against berlin so you
have to
it's like the one thing you didn't have
any games against so
i had to surprise him
well it seems like you got a very
favorable position from the opening when
did you start feeling that you had a big
pull well i always i don't think it uh i
never uh never stopped until in time
pressure
i was just the clear breakthrough was
very difficult but uh it was obvious it
was obvious that i had an advantage the
entire game right
take us a little bit through what you
consider were the problematic moments
you were trying to break through
throughout most of the game you got this
really nice bind on
yeah so here okay okay of course it
gives plus one and okay this is like low
depth anyways but you can just continue
rookie seven we should be like it's not
no death it's 40. yeah but this is
alicia's engine is a bit uh weird
sometimes but uh bishop b3 queen of four
yeah uh i mean well he played
rockefeller yeah c3
ricky okay i don't think i made any
mistakes you can continue here i'll tell
you when to stop okay well we can just
go to directly where you want to go
bishop c8 all the way here yeah tick
tick tick yeah king of king f2 uh-huh
queen did you know g3 yeah i should just
play uh and then he plays king jade i
need to play h4 yeah
well h4 the engines weren't so happy
about the there was this c7 or queen e6
coming to h3 with some so i need to go
knight b6 first and then
h4
it wasn't so clear but yes they wanted
to play knight b6 bishop e6 and only now
that the bishop is now that makes a lot
of sense yeah but and then here it
should be
technically lost
wow you would consider it to be that
high of an advantage
well 1.3 is usually
should be
okay it's obviously very very difficult
because
the engine always gives a huge advantage
here and these types of okay like the
pawn structure yes it's obvious what is
going wrong but to to find it over the
board is always
it was very difficult absolutely where
did you feel like things went wrong okay
he's like playing so quickly i have no
time and i was just trying to make it to
the time control without um like giving
away my advantage but
at some point um
once i
you know i i just was just making
i was playing without a plan
and uh lost a bit of control and then
i didn't really have the time to to
to
put significant pressure because i don't
really think it's
i think this is h4 or knight b6 h4 is is
the main main try
yeah but after this there's just nothing
yeah especially after queen h4 g5 they
just did say that at the end they liked
your position a little bit better how am
i supposed to play for 96. okay but 96
king e3 we thought it was very difficult
to find no no of course i saw it like
it's not a question of uh like okay
knight d6 king e3 and out of five
uh
king d3 no no king uh
no no this is equal
king d3 okay ticks ticks
okay i guess i miscalculated maybe at
this point i was just i'd give it up but
though
no here i would still be able to push
him
a little bit i mean the king on fa per
house bishop h5 type no but again this
is like so difficult to play with black
because there's always trades and you
you never know if an end game is just
going to be lost yeah so
that's true
well hans it's a good way to start the
tournament you put pressure on lavonna
not an easy thing to do he's such a
well-versed berlin player how do you
feel about your starter you seem a
little disappointed
well of course i'm
it's it's not terrible um
the thing is that uh this g3 h4 idea was
so natural to me like the entire game i
just felt like i was completely
outplaying him and uh
there seemed to be a difference in uh
evaluation of the position and i felt
like
the time management you know could be a
better
h4 chance but even after h4 it's unclear
if i'd be able to win but
i think that
perhaps with a
bit better time management than i would
have
liked to play h4 even ip684 is not like
such a difficult thing which is slightly
frustrating but uh
in general i was never in any danger so
at least
it's not that bad
this is your first real incursion into
the elite of chess at the classical time
control how does it feel the preparation
on the play differently than for example
determining that you played in miami or
all the tournaments in which you've
played a rapid time control against this
best of the best players well i enjoy
this much more because i feel like i'm
able to show my best chess here you know
it's very serious preparation and just
the conditions that everything is just
so much better
these rapid events
can be quite dependent on your form and
uh things can go there's more variants
i'd say in rapid but i'm very happy to
be here of course
to play these players
um you know i expected maybe to be a
little more intimidated but i feel right
at home here so uh
definitely looking forward to the rest
of the tournament sounds great and tell
us the viewers a little bit about your
adventures because you've been
ping-ponging around the world playing
playing chess what happened in the last
few weeks
well i was in belgrade and
beginning
to august let's say 13th i
then i was supposed to go play turkish
league and then um
champions chester says oh we got an
invitation to miami and i'm like oh
great
so then i fly from belgrade to miami and
then um i'm thinking okay i'm gonna go
to turkish league play five games so i
fly across the world of course
and then once i arrive you know someone
calls me he's like oh you know maybe
you're gonna get invited
and then i get uh invited to the sinful
cup first it's the rapping of blitz and
then i tried to tell my turkish like
team you know maybe i can go and uh
let's say that didn't go too well let me
go over to both of them and turkey is
probably not my um
where i'm safest
and um
so then i was like you know i can't come
so then thankfully they gave me a sing
for the cup invite and then i'm like
okay well i've just played five games in
turkey time to do my third at cross
atlantic trip
all the way back which obviously was
miserable um and uh
but the bright side now is i should be
staying in america for quite a bit and
uh obviously saint louis is much better
than ankara turkey no offense but that
place is absolutely miserable
no offense i'm sure
well thank you for joining us here and
the commentary and good luck in the rest
of your games thank you
indeed good luck
no offense
but i realized
i'm getting the first taste of what i
referred to earlier
you ask a question you get a return very
honest answer there you go and this is
good and this is very very exciting how
it should be yeah um
i noticed in the game between shaq and
wesley uh
they're
is trying to make something out of this
can we do it it's a bit awkward but i
think you still hold like i want to take
on you with the rook okay and then i
need to find i need to find a
comfortable move there after king of
four and i was looking at i'm actually a
bit surprised the king went to g7 but
maybe i shouldn't be
because it's difficult to find a much
better move yeah i think it's all good
yeah so knight g4 rogue took a four and
we can play a number of squares here
i would like to stay on the long
diagonal but currently basically i
blundered well blundered i wanted to
play in bishop b7 here that was my plan
bishop boyce seven yeah but then i
realized neither five check exists right
this moment not later not not not before
now this is and now i'm struggling for
squares you're now struggling for
squares a little bit because
king of fate appears king of king g8
appears to be the only way not to lose
material immediately but okay it's
awkward right i will get a check from g6
i'll have to go to f8 right i'll get
checked from g f6 then i'll have to go
back to g8 other everything else looks
like it's risky
and we did
yeah
my point here is if i have time to play
rook f2 check in a favorable situation
then in many cases i will have to go
back to g3 perhaps because the the g
pawn will be dangerous but it seems like
by doing all of this white gets so much
time that i my my counterplay never
really materializes i'm not i'm thinking
this should be seven majors probably not
right or wrong yeah so d3 maybe bishop
g6
yeah that as well bishop my issue with
bishop f3 yeah he's played bishop d3
bishop to defend my issue with bishop f3
was it stops both rook have to check and
it also completely stops g4 g3 counter
play because we can't do this while the
bishop is going giving white time to
play it on the e45 e6 or something good
point uh all around this actually
i was about to propose e3 e4 in some
positions here yeah i completely failed
to realize that you wouldn't be the only
person to ever leave a rook on brief i
could wait
you
four um okay now having said that we're
here um
why would uh shaq
not be attracted to this how does how
would this it's definitely an
improvement because you you can imagine
you know here we go i guess request to
check king g3 and then somewhere we need
to play more aggressively i think rookie
six is too slow
i want to
yeah but if we give a check we no longer
have a check right like if i give a
check from my seven after king of six
that's
tentative
plan but it also doesn't look like we're
winning very much yeah
just a second uh why are you uh
shying away if you can get an e5 maybe
it's a good uh
maybe it's a good opportunity peter yeah
it's so it's something and uh
the difference in king activity and the
difference in weirdly king safety
because even though it's an empty board
i can definitely envisage some
situations where the the three white
pieces can launch some kind of an attack
against the right mating mat he's played
rook d6 and
rook d6 should now be a
draw star oh this is clever though there
is yeah because i i i thought i could
play jack yeah i thought i could play
rook after rook of six but that loses
material does it really how does that
happen ah maybe maybe rook out yeah i
have king h6 there in the end it doesn't
lose any material very good exactly yeah
696 check and only one square i believe
doesn't lose material because it's a
goodie but it's a good square yeah okay
so if rook have to check we go forward
let's say we try king g5
oh
well then after g3 we might yeah spidey
sense might start tingling suddenly uh
we
letting this pawn really
yeah that doesn't sound great something
96 checking of seven we might start
fighting for gravity here
regretting something uh i i mean even
though i i i i disparaged nimzovich he
did have some wonderful
uh quips including
the past pawn is a criminal that should
be kept under lock and key that was a
good one um
we're trying to make something work here
uh one guys i'm letting you i think
it's just a draw there's absolutely
nothing it's important to have this uh
rook f2 rook f6 if you want to equalize
the easiest you can also just move the
bishop somewhere even the move bishop h7
as awkward as it looks whoa the engine
thinks this is okay they think for a
little bit the 96 knight g5 gets an
advantage and then they realize no it's
nothing
but if you have this i think this is the
solution to go for king j3 it's kind of
worse you could go forward it's not a
bad move but after king h7 getting out
of a lot of checks you can start
thinking that black also plays for a win
uh
after rook f2 king g3 as you mentioned
rook f6 the only try is knight e6 but
it's just not enough after king h6 it is
a dead draw so i expect this one to be a
draw lanier is playing slowly but he
finally got to this position with the
bishop anchored on e4 and of course
without the b4 pawn we're talking about
a different game but with the b4 pawn
there should be absolutely no danger for
lanier at all you can keep the king on
c4 and see sure it would be an
interesting conversation if you take the
b4 pawn off the board and but the white
king is already only three for instance
i believe that that probably is winning
but not so easy right but i mean
definitely not easily and good could
actually be a draw uh i'm always very
confused about those positions because
uh
it seems very arbitrary some of them are
winning and some of them aren't and they
all look very similar they all look very
similar sometimes it depends on the
length of the diagonal of the bishop
sometimes yeah but actually the fact
that our table base right now says
b4 b5 is a draw in the current position
you anchor the bishop on c6
but you lose it you lose it immediately
for check this is my point yeah this is
an issue right yeah 85. and this is
still a draw yeah now
the funny thing
rook king b3 loses
yeah okay you you you can't this is you
some kind of tactic right
no you you yes this is a this is
specific you have to cross the g4 cross
yeah you have to cross you cross and you
get to e3 and you should before f4 is
unstoppable i think
no rooker 4 always will stop that no no
it's actually that this piston is a draw
yeah it's just a draw this is what i was
wondering maybe it has to do with the
fact that pawn is on f3 and this
diagonal is long enough it's a long
diagonal and we just stay and we never
yeah like the point is the king doesn't
get
doesn't get pushed away from e3 yes if
we continue talking about the sun game
because it might be somewhat instructive
it's instructive yeah let's say we play
i don't know rook a4 here king e3
probably rook f4 because if you allow me
to play king e3 bishop yeah i just
wanted to talk about specifically like
about how the setup works
king six bishop before
all right we've lost yeah we've lost yes
we've lost okay
maybe we should stop that hanging before
you
yeah
uh bishop d3 was played instead and well
i mean this is just going to be no i
mean lanier obviously is yes not obliged
to give up and he will not give up the
people you mean
for our entertainment yeah and why why
would he but why would he no no no no
let's see if there's any updates in the
wesley yeah he's planned to move for
rook f2 of course wesley calculates
these things very well and we also
expect
this to end in a draw very quickly no
material advantage anymore for mehmed
very f a fascinating game though with a
lot of strategical concepts i love the
move g5 earlier by wesley
changing the dynamic of the position by
the way if we go all the way back to
this position the engines were pretty
adamant that g5 was the best move and
the only one that fully equalized
for me uh the extraordinary part about
this game was the the decisions to go
bishop to d3
to b5
rip off that knight give up your nice
bishop and then for black to return the
favor bishop to b4 rip off that yeah
nice on e4 so they were these
kind of yeah
the strategic decisions well played game
peter
chess maybe thrall maybe oh yeah
good game going on and again i i was
following your conversation that you
were having there
uh with uh alejandro about the b pond
and if your king was on e3 and maybe we
could just again just explain that for a
second here uh how we were doing this
um we're going to make a move we're
going to make a move and then the point
that you were making is the 33 here is
the only drawing the only drawing move
because otherwise you're not in time to
get the king to e3 but now we do get the
king to e3 but even this position is a
bit tricky right okay [ __ ] e3
right king d6 and then the then the
point was was bishop
i'm interested specifically in the move
king d6 because i wonder okay like
bishop loses i guess to uh rookie three
okay three check and then we get pushed
away and this is exactly what we're
trying to avoid the position where after
bishop d3 black has specifically the
move king d65
and then we're going to get pushed back
and we're suddenly in sukswang and we
have to abandon the g4 square and once
the black king gets to d4 this mission
you no longer say then you get pushed
back some more and then the king ends up
on your doorstep on e3 so instead of
before uh
we should be just paying some more
attention like king d6 here excuse me
yes okay six we play
any move on the diagonal
yeah pretty much as long as as long as
we can uh attack the king on d5 with
check if it goes there or play king e4
if we get checked ourselves wow
uh and this setup is just uh very very
solid something about this very basic
position on the other hand tells me this
is something our viewers need
need to know this is an ending that they
can actually save
even though they're a whole exchange
down
and we do have the move
uh king b5 bishop jack on our board yeah
we'll see a repetition very quickly yeah
i don't think maxim is going to even try
very hard here he also knows that you
know the margin is you know extremely
extremely safe here for white right
okay uh i'm slightly curious uh
regarding uh the the wesley position
because um you know shaq played king e5
in yeah wesley king of seven i was
wondering if you can even play g4 g3
after king e5
um g5 396 check and i wanted to play
uh i think
yeah this doesn't really we don't just
we just don't need to get involved with
this no no especially because uh the
king just doesn't have a square yeah
it's just difficult to find to find h7
maybe
if you put it on the seventh rank if we
follow that variation knight e6 king h7
you allow me to catch the pawn from
behind
oh yeah it is stable on g7 actually yeah
rd3 g2 and then rook d7 g7 just
because it it seems like a shaky setup
for white but it's not everything is
very sturdy and kind of impossible you
have do you have a remaining pot on g2
so rook f5 is not a move
yeah exactly it would have been a very
nice very nice stalemate idea but there
is still a ball on g2 alive yeah hi vl
actually went to a3
i thought he was going to repeat but nvl
actually goes for
for this but i like this move king
you're saying there's a very nice move
you're writing all the checks yeah and
you're ready to just drive the king away
too
absolutely
one day g3 will exactly bother you yeah
perhaps it's time to find to find a you
know a real
reliable bailout here for white and just
well you kind of mentioned that e3 e4 g3
uh
yeah
oops i mean if i guess what you do it
gets i mean
we're probably still not losing in
particular if we uh
uh give ourselves the the g6 square for
the rook but
yeah it's a bit different no no no no no
no
yeah it's starting to look a little
effortless not at all i don't know um
okay
wow um
i didn't expect this pawn to be actually
that dangerous so dang it it's really
good
i mean i think the easiest way to make a
draw here is to go to d7 check okay if
you play king eight i'll put the rook on
g7 and okay your your password is yeah
they're really running and right we're
at least completely safe so i think g6
is probably logical here
and then we just i mean we can give a
check from d6 if we want
can i
finagle a bishop g6 intermezzo but then
after 96 it becomes a bit awkward i
think 96 right now yeah 96 here you've
got a check i got a check and if you
play bishop g6 i have knight of four
you're kind of getting pushed around
there a little bit like you start
running i understood
sorry i mean i plan to look at five
again now yeah it was good and then g3
maybe even no three you still haven't
seen yourself
okay let me just
cross off the diagonal there a little
bit and again i'm thinking g3 e3 four
yeah i mean we're not really playing
yeah i was i was ready to sacrifice and
hide on you but probably
even that would not have worked but e3
e4 definitely dents my uh ambitions
all right uh very very good uh
what's the time situation there i'm just
gonna go it's uh uh well both of them
have plenty of time uh
shaq has 26 minutes and wesley slightly
shorter wesley is on 13 but by the way
maxine's really pushing
his well
he runs zero risks so he is provoking
bishop g3 and then i guess he wants to
play king a four king a5
and then return the rook to g4 and then
go around so he's claiming that by
provoking before b5 he gave his king a
bit more squares and how come the bishop
wouldn't have been on the c6 square yeah
and that as well like he
yeah he moved the bishop away from the
e4
square so that was clever yeah i get the
feeling that there might be a way to
make a draw immediately here
oh i'm just going to put some moves on
the board for just a second yeah i
wonder if bishop b4 is not just a draw
and then f4 but right i was trying to
keep all right but this is still
completely fine yeah of course yes of
course you're still good
[Music]
the b5 like it's good for black that you
have the c5 square for the king but it's
not enough
exactly and as we've established even if
you remove the pawn from b5 you know
your opponent if i from the board here
it's still a draw even so yeah bishop e4
f4
still not the ending position that uh
linear bargained for when he went into
this ending you know 30 moves ago
probably not yeah probably not but and
by the way we do have e4 g3 on the board
i stopped
once you pronounced g3 i didn't want to
touch this it's still completely fine i
don't think wow there's
why is this completely fine
check
check
yeah
okay
i mean once the rook lands on d7 you're
just not really
you're just not really playing
yes it stops it stops the g pawn very
very conclusively
so and here i can play knight e6 i think
by the five rooker five i might lose but
yeah okay
rook g7 check yeah you said on rg5
we're just not wars here with one
well just maybe we're a bit better
i was going to play bishop to g4 to try
to cut off your rook
do i can i give you made somewhere
maybe you can i don't know
it's possible okay
i didn't realize this was available i'll
play rook g3 yeah that's a very good
point by you but i can play rook g3 and
stop that from ever becoming an issue
right
and then there's
a very good point yeah yeah and then
like the four next move
yeah why is remains very safe white
white remains
sort of more or less entirely risk-free
cool
okay i don't think i was it was an issue
i wanted to explore with you for quite
some time and somehow we've never gotten
the chance to really get this discussion
in once more more insights into
um
magnus's withdrawal uh abdication if you
will obligation yeah
uh
nepo's perspective and uh how that
impacts him or does it impact them i
mean it's up to
nothing he could have done about it so
something i wanted to ask you please
think about it as we get and we'll just
take a short break and be back for the
remaining two games
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the continued
coverage of the first round of the
signal cup we have three results so far
magnus carlsen won a very very nice very
convincing game against yandy bomnishi
uh just got a playable position out of
the opening and won it uh in his kind of
nickable style
absolutely the two remaining games
however
uh linear and mvl and bl was
trying to uh
get something peter but yeah it's uh
i i think he knows it's a drawing near
knows it's a joke we've already uh
pointed out to our viewers that it's a
draw even without the pawn on b5 which
was the one the one topic that i wasn't
entirely sure of right uh even if you
remove it off the board
it would still be it yeah you you can
lose those positions but you shouldn't
right as long as you keep to some very
very simple rules you shouldn't but the
presence of the pawn uh should mean it
provides an additional
layer of security for sure right
now i can see how four minutes though i
think this is why mbl is playing because
uh
you could go wrong right you would put a
king on c5
you could definitely imagine some took
swans right if you let's make some moves
bishop to king c5 bishop let's say f1
which i think is incorrect king d5 okay
bishop d bishop d3 okay so this is three
this is essentially the best position
that black can achieve and after the
move rook b3 we're blind you have to
play b6
oh if you if you step back here you
actually lose like a move like king
before you've resigned yeah you you can
no longer you you can no longer get back
to e3 the b5 pawn is also gone you're
just completely completely okay that's
and and this is why mvl continues to
play because lenier also realizes that
that there are still pitfalls for him to
uh to be very old to fall into it and
this is why and this is why he's
thinking
and while he's thinking you know the the
perpetual time travel of the second time
control
is getting nearer and nearer so mvl of
course continues continues being
somewhat interested because you know
defending this position on 30 seconds
is still manageable of course for a
player of lanier's caliber but it's less
fun and in this position the game is
drawn because of the move f4 but even
before check is still a draw it's not
even a force you can you can even play
this before check and we get back to our
setup
we wouldn't have guessed that that would
have been a draw just and just step away
yeah [ __ ] page seven the movie oh
showing in a similar special way just
step away give yourself the e4 square to
reply to a check with gotcha you you
just need to have king four as a reply
to a check from the third and then
you're safe
and from uh the clock's perspective uh
yeah he's down to three he's down to
three against pretty much half an hour
pretty much the entirety of the second
time allotment for mvl and vl is doing
the right thing in playing as quickly as
he can without blundering f3f4 somewhere
which would be unfortunate right uh so
he keeps the rook on the fourth he
provoked b5 the the diagonals for the
white bishop have become shortened
and yes there are things to think about
here for for lanier uh meaning that as
we as we're watching he continues
burning time he continues like
the question you might be asking
yourself as viewers like why hasn't he
played
bishop
right right and he will eventually play
bishop
but he does need to check that he is if
he plays passively if he doesn't try to
do something that he doesn't run into
some kind of uh trunks
i see and by the way just a quick
question for you in case i give you
everything you could possibly want yeah
you've driven me yeah we've lost yeah
we've lost yeah
yeah just let's say rugby three let's
don't give a check two stories will be
like
you've lost more
space
the diagonal is just not long enough and
i can't go king g3 because of e4 yeah
there's there's always going to be some
tactical issues yeah you you this is
already this is already losing wow which
is why yeah well you've got to play it
yeah you you have to play it carefully
you have to play it carefully you have
to kind of play by first principles and
the first principles here are
like just never allow a situation where
your king will be pushed away from
from the e3 square kind of yeah and this
i think will just be a perpetual uh in
the uh uh our other live game of the day
because here after some thought after
king james just played rda check
have we seen any repetitions no since g3
we've just gotta talk da check um if
black plays rook f8 we can just take
white is uh running zero risks there as
as does black i assume but
king of four here is a draw i'm i'm
guessing and
knight of three and pretty much anything
else should also be a draw it's not a
very exciting position
okay and i'm guessing if king of seven
he will play rd7 checked back so looks
like that one is headed towards a draw
both players i think
tried you know there were some
repetitions available to both white and
and black earlier in particular
he
he's continued trying for quite some
time but i think and we do have rook f8
on the board the game is about to
conclude now
exactly fate you can't really not take
any more because then g2 yeah
i mean there is rook d6 actually but 268
check it it doesn't really sound like a
winning attempt right rook d6 or k6 yeah
okay
uh so yeah i think he takes he goes king
of four and we get that position that
we're just discussing which
is just very very safe g2 knight of
three and then i start bringing my king
in like i play king of seven or king e7
or whatever right just a very very safe
draw for everyone
everybody really happy
all right
very very good news
yeah this will i mean
as is the uh
the fashion these days i think they will
play to to an empty board yes they will
find a way to get everything off the
board in the next five to ten moves
i always admired the professional way
that they do manage to do that too by
the way they they find some some concept
where
people are giving pawns yeah i think i
think the absolute
like the the the biggest
uh show of professionalism in these
types of positions is
to time it
so that the final capture happens on the
same move
like if you play pawn against pawn and
both kings are very very much in in the
square in the square
you time it so that king takes g4 is
made by king takes b5 on the other side
of the board got it that is yeah king g3
is like a very very good indication that
he's not really very interested here
in trying to prove any kind of an
advantage and yeah chris bird there
saying yeah you can stop here if you
want no i think it was actually giving
um the score sheets for 16 years yeah
but uh uh i think they probably will be
allowed to to stop somewhere around here
you don't like because otherwise
somebody oh very
very very nice yeah longer longer
position there by wesley also very
stylish yeah and now we have a
three-fold coming out yeah these guys
are these guys good
good at their job yeah right the fact
that because of the rules here they will
actually have to undertake the second
scoresheet because it's not just the
moves they also have to write who is
playing like it's a whole big deal it is
it takes
about 30 seconds yeah a whopping
a whopping 30 seconds there
uh so far alejandro again uh a
well-played
round we saw some good games uh not
too many well one decisive result but
good chance i'm happy with the games
that we got today i thought we had so
much action especially when we saw that
alireza against fabiano carrana fight
there were a lot of things that were
left off the board as we finally see the
handshake between mamedyarov and wesley
so and this one was also a fun game it
was very thought uh it was equal
throughout if you put it into an engine
but i don't think that they thought it
was going to be equal thought it was
just a fight right and i love the
imbalance the way that shaq got a little
bit of something from the opening with
this new idea trading office bishop for
the night so much content and not to
mention that well this game yes it was
the draw but i think hans showed that he
came in prepared he came in with ideas
and then he has the possibility of
pushing levon adonia and almost to the
brink yes absolutely yeah
and he wasn't shy about it
yeah it was it was still kind of an
interesting interview because
uh
yeah he it's just
i no longer remember that feeling and
it's very interesting for me to watch
people who who still possess this level
of self-confidence like
i was you know that kind of a slightly
more annoying kid when i was younger
definitely was i you know i i have like
secondhand accounts of it and i even
have some memories
but it was so long ago
excuse me mr grandmaster mr grandmaster
didn't you miss a win
yeah
but
but yeah it was so long ago that i can
really no longer you know get better
back to that you know beautiful feeling
happy moment of like the you know
the world being your oyster and all that
and just your knowledge you knew
something about something yeah
nice uh but with one game remaining once
again we'll just uh
uh bring to our audience the four
results that we do have
yeah there you have it uh as we keep on
mentioning very very nice victory by the
world champion over the uh
uh the challenger i wanted to say the
former challenger but also the car in
general world champion participants yeah
but maybe not even the challenger
because he actually won won the
candidates
he starts as the the number one seed in
this in this world championship match to
come and so far three more three more
draws and lanier is low on time but
doing the right things
i assume he doesn't lose exactly
uh in the old days we used to have uh
these world champions with
uh
draw odds and then and those types of
things but now
nepo would he have draw odds because he
defeated dinglerin and the candidates
and he was the number one let's not
let's not go there i mean
okay back to the question i have yeah
from the russian
uh challenger's point of view from uh
jan's point of view
the abdication
well i would very very much like not to
speak for other people like i i've had
some conversation with him on this topic
but uh i i don't feel like i should be
fine
the russian public
i've i remember
you know i've sort of removed myself as
much as possible from uh
you've sort of from from the public eye
in in recent months but i remember on
that day i i
i was doing something and i was kind of
not connected to the internet
for a couple of hours and i missed the
announcement
and uh suddenly i realized that a lot of
kind of unknown numbers are calling me
and this normally means that
somebody has questions for publications
of some sort right and
yeah
people were shocked i think uh this
narrative that you know he's only saying
this to i don't know to
for for clicks or to attract attention
to you know appear magnus yeah yeah
i think i think a lot of people did not
believe it until the very very last and
discounted this over very severely right
uh
but
you know
in terms of
jan's chances
i legitimately think
that he actually wanted a rematch i
think i think he very much wanted to
play magnus i think that was very clear
when i interviewed him in zagreb you
could see that
it was like something had been taken
away from him right yes absolutely i
interviewed magnus right after the
announcement and he explained all of his
points of views but i also got to talk
to nepo immediately and it was like
something sour on his face when he
learned about it i think he was very
much looking forward to becoming world
champion by defeating magnus carlos he
felt that dubai was an unfinished
business he felt that he didn't do
himself
justice and i think the first half of
the match i think very aptly illustrates
why he would think that right uh
but
i'm sure he also realizes that his
chances in general of becoming the world
champion improved
by by this happening like those those
two things those two things i think can
very easily you know be both true
that you know he would much prefer to
win a match against magnus but
his chances against and it's this is not
to say that ding isn't no in some way
not a good player it's just that you
know
not at all uh so
yeah i think uh it's a it's a kind of a
mixed bag i think he he very much
regrets uh
this has happened
because i think he has a lot of respect
for you know the the chess history the
the legacy of the title the continuity
of the title and things of that nature
but uh
i mean
it's out of his hands it was like he
couldn't influence that decision and now
he has a much to prepare to so he will
be preparing for that much exactly
well a new deck of cards so to speak
have been shuffled uh new jokers in the
in the deck
world championship match in 2023 coming
up uh where do you reckon the match is
going to be held
i've heard some rumors but i don't
really know once again like i've uh
i'm
very much out of the loop i feel like
until i arrived here i didn't really
know anything about it but apparently
there is a there is a venue that people
think is likely but i feel that you know
for us to announce it would be
completely wrong before okay before
things are finalized because you don't
want to influence that process and i
assume once again once again magnus is
perfectly within his rights to do
whatever he pleases sure but also
clearly this is not great for the chess
world and finding sponsors
must have become
more difficult
very much so uh when when the match does
not involve magnus so i think you know
whatever tentative negotiations are
currently in place we shouldn't really
be interrupting them in any way because
we you know we would like them for the
match to happen you know yeah of course
one thing we would very much like is for
for the much to actually
match the two players to earn very good
rewards so yeah
hopefully there are hopefully there are
bids hopefully something uh something
gets
gets established wonderful
back to our game obviously we're still
in the table i mean
you're still doing the right things yeah
king d5 now i think is the try just to
uh
[Music]
perhaps provoke samsung swans yeah i
think you go king d5 and as we establish
bishop d3 is a draw actually like most
moves which aren't moves with the king
which i think every move that isn't to
move with the king or f3a4 is a draw
currently right shockingly like bishop
what is the drop bishop g1 even is a
draw as we keep on saying even just
completely abandoning this pawn
is still a draw but yeah bishop d3
abandons the pawn right bishop three
also abandons the pawn but bishop d3
balances the pawn but also gives you a
chance to play three or four straight
after
right so in a way it's slightly stronger
than those other moves because if if
black goes rook b3 rook takes b6 here
you just make a draw on the spot with
f34 you don't even need to demonstrate
this fortress yeah and i think that's
where we're going yeah rook b3 no i
think unveil will try to take on b6 in
such a way that this is not allowed like
i think b6 you go like king g6 maybe but
why can't play b7 yeah there's there's
no stopping f4 i mean you have to take
with the rook
yes b7 here and i mean you can play king
c7 but eventually this becomes a bit too
laughable like king e4 here xb7 bishop
anywhere bishop f1 whatever right get
out of the way get out and then we will
eventually play f3f4 with the king on b7
we're not really winning this mission
with black uh so yeah this this will be
as long as long as lanier realizes he
has to play b6 but i think he will i i
don't like lanier is way way way too
experienced
do not
do not play
uh king e2 here
he knows he can't he can't allow it yeah
b7b there we go b6 yeah
on the board
and yeah i mean it's so
they're having a kind of a quiet
conversation sort of like do you do you
know you can't abandon the e3 square
yeah i mean i know yeah i know so what's
what's the etiquette here rook versus
bishop nah do you do do you three-fold
it
i think you go rook f6 check rook takes
a five like a four-year [ __ ] f4 rook
of six check bishop five snap
snap just snap yeah like this this
doesn't get played out right these guys
know each other too well and i mean rook
against bishop really is not very
difficult no yeah it's just i mean i
i've i've seen a lot more in recent
years i've seen a lot more rook and
night versus rook being played out than
i expected because i always thought this
is completely pointless but people have
even lost one or two really shockingly
and i mean shortness yeah winning
against irwin
yeah
so obviously once they get lost every
now and again people other people become
more interested in continuing
but rook against bishop you just don't
like what's the point exactly
king d6
he'll play somewhere king c6 but we can
go king e4 now and just
comfortably trade off i think he will go
king [ __ ] g6 actually i think this is
what he's planning he wasn't breaking a
[ __ ] d6 and
kind of
i think
legitimately claim that it's an
improvement for him because the king on
e4
is bad when you want to play f3f4 yeah
that's sort of like king d6 king e3 yeah
yeah he won the exact tempo but we're
just looking e3 back we don't exactly
it's
oops kingdom six played yeah so king c6
king e4 has been played i'm pretty sure
he's he's going to play kingdom 6 here
and again
the desirable f4 check is being met in
this case whether before actually i
don't know
with upon b6 we can't do that
but if we play king e3 yeah king c6
still a drawing kingdom six is going to
is going to be the choice at least it
asks a question
well this is what it's all about you
keep
putting questions in front of your
opponent and they answer this one right
what about this one they answer that one
they get all the answers right it's a
draw but if they get one of the answers
wrong
yay-hey
we can win this game king d6 on the
board
yeah we fully expect king e3 if you look
at your table base it might look like
every move is the same but they're not
there's a lot of moves that will just
end up in suffering king three is the
clean one yeah you you don't really want
to play that that that position if if
you give the b pawn up yes you probably
suspect it's a draw or perhaps even know
it's a draw but why why allow it if you
can just
right do this and
not even play that end game at all
exactly that makes no sense
strangely enough i
i mean
i'm sure there's a three-fold right now
like if you wanted right you can
flicking c6 i mean this is the way they
could end the game right away like king
six can you [ __ ] 16 e3 true uh i just
don't have that much experience myself
uh with rook and bishop versus
rook versus bishop
it's just
strange it doesn't have had ripping
bishop it doesn't really come up very
much and also if it does come up people
kind of agree a draw immediately maybe
even maybe even the moment they realize
it's unavoidable the drug gets offered
right yeah and uh yeah this game is okay
he's actually going to take on this
interesting
i kind of assumed
uh that would not even be played out
yeah shockingly even if three of four is
a draw now which is whoa
f4 ef and i guess bishop f1 or bishop c4
i would feel like playing you know
playing with fire uh yeah like why why
do that why am i doing bad yeah but
bishop f1 is very logical just play
bishop one rook b1 bishop h3 exactly and
then get ready to play f4 and or
king takes e5
yeah we just uh
round up the pawn on e5 and we
he'll play with b1 and then the cleanest
is i think
bishop h3 rookie one czech and king d5
and then this is the the famous you know
shouldering uh shouldering the opponent
the opponent uh opponent's king away and
then i just go bishop five before and i
collect the quality fight
you know you collect the pawn oh that's
uh
you don't trade the pawn well rookie
three will win the pawn on the three
right yeah we we still win the
the when we we when we talk about the
word shouldering we're we're using our
king in a sense and creating a bubble a
force
shield that the black king can't pierce
so we're shouldering and keeping the
king out of because
if if you think about it if you're
playing a five there king of five kings
c5
might that's not shows still a draw but
you suddenly you know will feel the urge
to calculate right because
you know give me one more give me one
more tempo it might not be a draw
anymore exactly exactly but the
shouldering technique
again as you said mark doveretsky
is end game manual really uh
had a big impact uh for a lot of people
and uh he's just he used certain terms
that uh have now become commonplace yeah
this particular one i don't think was
invented by him but he invented a lot of
other things and then did a lot of
really groundbreaking work but right
first time i met mark dovrick 1978 you
world junior championships he had arthur
youssef off and sergey
and almost uh
students and they were really really
good with won the world uh junior
championship that was a very interesting
relationship because they were very very
close friends for a very very long time
both both the varetsky's people and also
they they just gelled very well together
and then eventually they played the kind
of candidates march against each other
together yeah and i spoke i believe to
both about it uh
and very awkward moment for mark right
i yeah that as well but
what was interesting to me was that
and they were
not just colleagues they were
legitimately very close friends
and they said the relationship actually
never is the same after that even though
they realize you know it's a knockout
like it's a knockout kind of the cycle
right you know no decision making is
involved anywhere and one of them has to
win exactly so it's completely
unavoidable there's you know no no
actual recriminations or anything but
still it impacts your it impacts you
when when it's something
so important to both of you yeah
and and you you get in each other's way
and there you see the moment the moment
rook and bishop appears on the board
they both disappear professional uh rook
f5 you snap it off says peter svidler
well
well spotted peter and again
four
uh draws full of content and one uh
incredibly
smooth
victory by world champion magnus carlson
absolutely yes
he puts his mark on this event as we
started our show alejandro
you asked anastasia are we going to see
one player running away with the field
or why or is it going to be a a group
and uh
well
it's early but magnus is already putting
his stamp on the tournament i never like
to think about it in terms of decisive
games i like to take think about it in
terms of how good was the chess how fun
was it and the one berlin that we saw
today we saw black get squeezed so these
drops were very fighting they were very
they gave us a lot of content so i'm
happy to call these types of games we
didn't get a lot of games in which
nothing was happening actually we didn't
get any game in which nothing was
happening yeah absolutely
peter
marvelous starting up to uh
2022. one running in in the books and
yeah let's uh once again take a look
understandings even though they are
perfectly straightforward so far with
only one victory
yeah at the top
lapping the field
laughing in the field after one game
again a nice start to this tournament
which was so eagerly uh look forward to
uh grand chess tour it's the final of
the grand chester
everybody's looking for those
grandchester points as we see
the top players
and uh
close out the show for
and anastasia what are your thoughts
well you guys got my thoughts i'm
curious on your thoughts anastasia what
happened for you today now you were
around in the ambiance of the event yeah
exactly actually while you were watching
the games a lot of fun was happening in
saint louis chess club we had today
american very famous american rapper
logic here and also a hockey player of
saint louis blues 40 club whose name is
robert thomas both of them were here and
they were playing some games they were
watching the games of the top players
and also they met with magnus and talia
reza ferruja it was really nice to see
the players in a good mood and
actually ferruccio was got the
invitation they went to visit the
concert of logic rapper but and he was
really considering it so
there was lots of action behind the
scenes and if you want to watch more of
it you can just follow our instagram
accounts and our twitter accounts of
saint louis club and grand chester
very nice and uh great that the saint
louis blues hockey uh stars are visiting
and uh welcome welcome welcome it is a
very special atmosphere here every year
people people come and watch these
tournaments because they're by this
point so so legendary in the world of
chess hype exactly i've seen a lot of
people sort of make special special kind
of uh
arrangements to to free up parts of
their september to be able to uh to go
to go and watch this because it's really
unlike anything in the world the central
west end while the tournament is going
on is a very very special
special thing to do to behold no it's
not what i meant it's meant like you you
walk in the street and there's a
yeah yeah but uh that's not the end
single single club doesn't end the the
very very busy summer running into the
fall of chess here in saint close
immediately after the events it's team
randy versus team rex in the ultimate
moves trash talking required
then of course we have the fisher
random chest 9lx that's coming up
september 14th to the 16th and finally
things do get wrapped up with the us and
u.s women's chess championships in saint
louis in october we have a very special
guest maxine mdl is uh with not not just
no he's not there yet i'm sorry i
thought he was getting uh yeah miked up
i apologize i could i i we could perhaps
as a kind of a teaser for tomorrow uh
uh
we could discuss
ah not anymore
i like the teaser i was ready for the
so utc briefly announce what the
pairings are for tomorrow we have hans
neiman actually starts with two whites
hanson even tomorrow plays white against
chakariyama minjarov fabiano caruana is
white against lanier dominguez yanni
pomnishi gets a chance to to get back on
on the track uh on the track with white
against there's a ferocious potentially
a very very interesting game they will
they always seem to be playing very
sharp game games against each other
and uh levon irony is white against
magnus carlsen while mbl is white
against uh wesley and these are
the predictions with only one round i
mean we're all we're all okay here
everybody yeah what if we're all okay
we're all okay
get out of here right i mean maurice
would be proud that that makes one
yeah
nice nice nice are we waiting for mbl do
you know
not not that we know no nvl well that's
a good good chance to
uh alejandro for final thoughts of a
very eventful round one i liked it i
liked today's round i mentioned the
quality of the games was high the
excitement of the games was high and
it's always good to see your pick win
when nobody else does so for me great
round one here at the sinkhole cup
good stuff let's say that's
thank you everyone for joining us and
sharing your day with us be sure to do
it tomorrow this weekend is going to be
full of exciting chess we hope you will
join us peter as always marvelous to be
in pleasure a pleasure to be doing this
yeah thank you night everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited